ACED OUT.
TWENTY NINETEEN MEETING OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE
WE'RE GOING TO BE STARTING AS A
SUB COMMITTEE AS SOON AS WE CAN
FIND A REPUBLICAN MEMBER TO JOIN
US.
WE DO OF OFFICE WAITING SO IF
YOU'RE A MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE
PLEASE TRY.
TO COME UP AS SOON AS YOU CAN TO
THE COMMITTEE ROOM THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN AS A SUB
COMMITTEE AND THEN VOTE AS SOON
AS WE ARE ESTABLISH A QUORUM OUR
FIRST BILL UP IS SB.
ONE BY SENATOR ATKINS WELCOME
SENATOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MISTER
VICE CHAIRMAN -- COLLEAGUES.
IT IS GOOD TO BE HERE TODAY.
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
COURTESY.
ALLOWING ME TO START SESSION.
OUR SESSION STARTS AT THREE SO I
REALLY APPRECIATED [inaudible]
I I'M HAPPY TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT SB ONE THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL PUBLIC HEALTH AND
WORKERS DEFENSE ACTIVE.
TWENTY NINETEEN SB ONE IS
SENSIBLE AND NECESSARY
LEGISLATION IT MAKES FEDERAL
BASELINE STANDARDS FOR OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND WORKER
PROTECTION.
ENFORCEABLE UNDER STATE LAW.
WHERE THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION
IN WASHINGTON DC ROLES THEM BACK?
SINCE THE ADMINISTRATION IN DC
TOOK OFFICE IT SYSTEMATICALLY
UNDERMINED DECADES OF REGULATORY
PROGRESS.
DOZENS OF VITAL CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER AND ENDANGERED SPECIES
STANDARDS HAVE BEEN WEAKENED OR
ELIMINATED.
THE AGENCIES CHARGED WITH
SAFEGUARDING OUR HEALTH WORKER
SAFETY NATURAL RESOURCES HAVE
BEEN CAPTURED BY THE INDUSTRY'S
THEY'RE MEANT TO REGULATE.
A COLD LOBBYIST NOW RUNS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AGENCY
AND AN OIL LOBBYIST IS IN CHARGE
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR.
AND THEY ARE SYSTEMATICALLY
UNDER ENFORCING THE LAWS THAT
ARE STILL ON THE BOOKS IN
ADDITION THE ADMINISTRATION OF
PROPOSED A BUDGET BLUEPRINT.
THAT WOULD REDUCE THE FUNDING OF
THE US EPA TO A POINT WHERE THE
AGENCY WOULD NO LONGER BE ABLE
TO MEANINGFULLY ENFORCE CLEAN
AIR.
AND CLEAN WATER LAWS.
LIST GOES ON AND ON AND IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT THE ENVIRONMENT --
THE ADMINISTRATION IS ALSO
PUTTING WORKERS AT RISK OSHA
ENFORCEMENT IS DOWN SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN IN THE NUMBER OF OCEAN
SPECTER'S HAS REACHED AN
HISTORIC LOW.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS SLASH THE
NUMBER OF INSPECTORS AND REDUCED
OVERSIGHT OF WORKPLACE HAZARDS
INSPECTIONS A WORKPLACE HE
CONDITIONS HAVE FALLEN 50% IN
TWO YEARS.
AN INSPECTION OF DANGEROUS
CHEMICALS AND PESTICIDES HAVE
FALLEN BY TWO THIRDS.
MEANWHILE THERE'S STRONG
EVIDENCE THAT WORKPLACE
INCIDENTS AND FATALITIES HAVE
INCREASED.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN MORE THAN
FIVE THOUSAND WORKERS WERE
KILLED ON THE JOB.
AND MORE THAN THREE MILLION
WORKERS SUFFERED SERIOUS INJURY
OR ILLNESS.
THE NUMBER OF WORKPLACE INJURY
IN FATALITY INVESTIGATIONS.
TRIGGERED WHEN AN INJURY OR
DEATH HAPPENS ON THE JOB ROSE
DRAMATICALLY IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN SB ONE WOULD
INSULATE CALIFORNIA FROM.
BACKSLIDING ON ALL OF THESE
ISSUES.
IT'S SIMPLY PROVIDE SO WHERE
EVER ACTIONS THIS FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION MAY TAKE OR
WHATEVER ACTIONS CALIFORNIA WILL
CONTINUE TO ENFORCE THE SAME
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC HEALTH
PROTECTIONS THAT HAVE BEEN IN
EFFECT. FOR YEARS AS A MATTER OF
STATE LAW.
THE FEDERAL CLEAN AIR CLEAN
WATER SAFE DRINKING WATER
ENDANGERED SPECIES AND WORKER
PROTECTION ACTS WERE ALL ADOPTED
ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES THAT'S MORE
THAN FORTY YEARS AGO.
THIS BILL ENSURES WE KEEP THOSE
COMMONSENSE PROTECTIONS.
I HAVE BEEN WORKING WITH THE
OPPOSITION FROM THE BEGINNING TO
ADDRESS MANY OF THE CONCERNS.
WE'VE TAKEN A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS SINCE THE BILL WAS
FIRST INTRODUCED INCLUDING SOME
JUST LAST WEEK.
LAST WEEK -- WE ADDED ADDITIONAL
IT THIS IS THE FIFTH HEARING I
BELIEVE FIVE BEEN AT THREE IN
THE SENATE A AND TO THIS IS THE
SECOND IN IN THIS HOUSE WE WILL
GO THROUGH ONE MORE COMMITTEE
AND APPROPRIATIONS.
SO WE'VE DONE A LOT OVER TIME WE
REQUIRE THE APPLICATION OF THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
AND WE CLARIFY THAT ALL AGENCIES
MUST PROVIDE A THIRTY DAY PUBLIC
NOTICE.
AND COMMENT PERIOD PRIOR TO
ADOPTING ANY FEDERAL BASELINE
STANDARD.
THE AMENDMENTS MAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR.
THAT IF AN AGENCY ADOPT ANYTHING
OTHER THAN THE SUBSTANTIALLY THE
SAME STANDARD.
AS THE FEDERAL BASELINE STANDARD
THE AGENCY MUST GO THROUGH THE
FULL ADMINISTRATIVE -- PROCEDURE
ACT PROCESS.
WE ESTABLISHED A MORE OBJECTIVE
HEALTH AND SCIENCE BASED
STANDARD WE CLARIFIED THAT THE
BILL DOES NOT AFFECT VOLUNTARY
WATER AGREEMENTS NEGOTIATED BY
THE STATE WATER BOARD.
WE'VE ADDRESS TROPHY HUNTING
CONCERNS AND SUNSETS THESE
PROVISIONS IN.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND NARROW
THE LABOR PROVISIONS TO APPLY
ONLY TO WORKER HEALTH AND SAFETY.
SO WHILE THESE AMENDMENTS DON'T
REMOVE ALL OF THE OPPOSITION
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT STEP.
AT ADDRESSING SEVERAL CONCERNS I
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES AS THIS BILL MOVES
FORWARD AS I TOLD ONE OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES.
I BELIEVE EVERY STEP GIVES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO GET US CLOSER TO
AGREEMENT AND I WILL TAKE EVERY
OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT.
AS LONG AS IT RESPECTS THE
INTENT.
OF WHAT THIS BILL IS TRYING TO
DO WERE SUPPORTED ON SB ONE BY A
BROAD BASED.
CROSS SECTION OF PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKER SAFETY AND ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS AND I HAVE A NUMBER OF
FOLKS WITH ME -- AT YOUR
DIRECTION MADAM CHAIR TO SPEAK I
QUE POOL FROM IN OUR DC AND KIM
TO FINO WITH DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE FOR HERE WE'RE HAPPY TO
TAKE COMMENTS AND IF YOU'LL LET
THEM SPEAK THAT WOULD.
IN LINE WITH YOUR RULES THAT
WOULD BE GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I WHEN WE TYPICALLY
GIVE TWO MINUTES PER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KIM
DELFINO AND I'M THE PROGRAM
DIRECTOR FOR DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M AS YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD THE
THREAT TO CALIFORNIA'S AIR WATER
WILDLIFE AND WORKER SAFETY IS AT
THREAT RIGHT NOW IT IS A REAL
THREAT -- CALIFORNIA IS A LOT TO
LOSE -- IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS SUCCESSFUL WITH
MANY OF ITS PROPOSED ROLLBACKS
AND HAS ALREADY DESCRIBED AS BE
ONE IS A SIMPLE BILL.
IT DIRECTS STATE AGENCIES TO
REVIEW FEDERAL EFFORTS TO
ROLLBACK ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS AND WORKER SAFETY
STANDARDS AND UTILIZE THEIR
EXISTING POWERS. TO TAKE ACTION
TO ENSURE THAT STATE STANDARDS
PROVIDE AT LEAST A BACKSTOP
AGAINST ROLLBACKS. FOR EXAMPLE
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT -- WHICH HAS BEEN I
THINK PROBABLY THE MOST
CONTENTIOUS SECTION AT THIS
POINT IN THE PROCESS ALL THE
BILL DOES IS IT PROPOSES THAT IF
AN ACTION WAS TAKEN TO WEAKEN
SOME OF PROTECTIONS FOR A
THREATENED OR ENDANGERED SPECIES
UNDER THE FEDERAL ACT THAT IS
NOT ALSO STATE LISTED.
THAT THE DEPARTMENT THAT THE
FISHING GAME COMMISSION JUST
SIMPLY REVIEW WHETHER OR NOT
THEY SHOULD LIST THAT SPECIES OR
NOT THEY COULD CHOOSE NOT TO
THIS DOES NOT MANDATE AN OUTCOME.
AND IF THEY SO CHOOSE TO PROTECT
THAT FEDERALLY LISTED SPECIES
THAT'S NOT STATE LISTED THAT
THEY THEN PUT IN PLACE
PROTECTIONS THAT WERE PREVIOUSLY
THERE IT IS AS SIMPLE AS THAT.
AND FOR THESE REASONS AND FOR
THE FACT THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A LOT TO LOSE WE
WOULD PERJURE AYE VOTE ON THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KATE COOL
I'M A SENIOR ATTORNEY WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL.
I'M I'M ALSO GOING TO FOCUS ON
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES SECTION
OF THE BILL BECAUSE AS THE
PROTON MENTION WE HAVE.
BEEN WORKING WITH THE OPPONENTS --
LONG AND HARD AND I THINK HAVE
RESOLVED MANY OF THE OTHER
ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
ABOUT THE BELL -- WITH REGARD TO
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES SECTION
THAT HAS THE SAME INTENT AS THE
REST OF THE BONE.
WHICH IS TO GET THE STATE THE
AUTHORITY TO ACT QUICKLY TO
PROTECT STATE RESOURCES IN THE
EVENT OF FEDERAL ROLE BOX.
UNLIKE THE OTHER SECTIONS THIS
IS NOT AN AREA OF THE LAW WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
DELEGATED AUTHORITY TO THE STATE
TO ISSUE PERMITS BECAUSE IT HAS
IN THE AIR AND WATER CONTACTS.
INSTEAD BOTH THE FEDERAL AND
STATE GOVERNMENT CURRENTLY ISSUE
ENDANGERED SPECIES PERMITS.
AND THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
ROLLING BACK PROTECTIONS UNDER
THOSE PERMITS AS THEY APPLY IN
CALIFORNIA.
SO THIS PART OF THE BILL ALLOWS
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE IN THE FISH AND GAME
COMMISSION TO RESPOND TO THOSE
SPECIFIC ROLL BACKS.
BY LISTING SPECIES IN THE STATE
WHERE WARRANTED UNDER STATE LAW.
ONE FEDERAL PROTECTIONS ARE
REDUCED.
IN BY ISSUING THEIR OWN PERMITS
FOR SPECIFIC ACTIVITIES TO
ENSURE THAT THE EXISTING LEVEL
OF PROTECTION IS MAINTAINED.
SO WITH THAT WEIRD YOUR SUPPORT
PRESS THE ONE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NOT ASK ANYBODY ELSE
WHO WANTS TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD AND JUST NAME
ORGANIZATION YOU'RE REPRESENTING
PLEASE.
VENTURE COMMITTEE JUST MILAN ON
BEHALF OF THE LOCAL ENVIRONMENT
HEALTH DIRECTORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON LEAGUE BY ENEMY
W. ASKED ME LOCAL THEIR NINE
THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
BILL MY GOVERNMENT COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR SUPPORT. EIGHTEEN A
GAL YOUR RUTH RECESS AND BARBER
GARDNER FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO ON FOSSIL FREE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO AT THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
BRENT ALSO SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE ABIT ON BEHALF OF THE
CLEAN SEIZE LOVING COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
RECALL MONSTER DID NOT A WITH
THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC LAND THANK
YOU PRO TIME FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN SUPPORT.
CARE TO SO ON BEHALF OF HEAL THE
BAY IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE GOING TO
HAVE A NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING A SOUL.
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND LATINO OUTDOORS AND
CALIFORNIA REALLY FALL IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER FEARING
ON BEHALF OF THE MOUNTAIN LION
FOUNDATION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
HI ALLISON BROWN ENTIRE DAILY
HERE ON BEHALF OF THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION SAN DIEGO. THREE
FIFTY THREE FIFTY SOUTH BAY
CLIMATE ACTION GROUP AND THREE
FIFTY RIVERSIDE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
AND AS THE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA DAN
JACOBSON STRONG SUPPORT.
NO OPPENHEIM WITH PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT.
CAITLYN COLOR WITH CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE KEEPER ALLIANCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
EVEN HER WAS SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE JEREMY SMITH THE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL
ALSO IN SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW WITH THE CATHOLIC
CHURCH OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
NATALIE KNOCKED ON BEHALF OF
BREAST CANCER PREVENTION
PARTNERS OCEAN CONSERVANCY MID
PENINSULA REGION OPEN SPACE
TRICKS DISTRICT IN CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE IN SUPPORT.
ALEXANDER WITH CAL START IN
SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY -- ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
ENSURE MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS LUCAS
FRERICHS ON BEHALF THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER RUN ON BEHALF
OF NEXT AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HUNTINGTON SHARP BEHALF THE
HEALTH OFFICER'S ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CAROL WE'D WITH SUSTAINABLE RUSS
MORE IN SUPPORT.
JULIE LIEBERMAN WITH
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE IN
SUPPORT.
YEAH BUT BECAUSE WILL WITH
CALIFORNIA ROOMS AS A SUMMONS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YEARS ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO VOICE SUPPORT THE BILL.
WE'RE GONNA PAUSE BRIEFLY TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HERE FRIEDMAN
HERE FLOOR FLOOR HERE CHAU
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE GARCIA.
GARCIA HERE LOW MOAN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS HERE MCCARTY. TO HEAR
FONG.
BROUGHT TO G..
STONE [inaudible]
STONE HERE.
THANK YOU NOW WILL MOVE TO
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
OR ANYONE WHO WANTS TO EXPRESSED
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL
[inaudible]
KATE
.
CAPTION CHAIR MEMBERS ADAMANTLY
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING THE AUTHOR WE
HAVE WORKED EXTENSIVELY WITH THE
PROPONENTS.
TO ADDRESS A NUMBER OF CONCERNS
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE.
THAT COLLABORATIVE STAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WE DO HAVE TWO REMAINING
ISSUES AND THEY WERE FOCUSED --
BUT THEY WERE HIGHLIGHTED -- BY
THE PROPONENTS [inaudible] ONE
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
SECTION IT'S THE ONE SECTION
THAT WE HAVE NOT ADDRESSED -- TO
CONCERNS THAT -- MY COUNTERPART
JENNIFER PEER WILL HIGHLIGHT --
THE OTHER THAT I'D LIKE TO
DISCUSS IS THE ADMINISTRATIVE
PROCEDURE ACT -- WE DID HERE
TODAY THAT THAT HAS BEEN
ADDRESSED WE'D LIKE TO CLARIFY
THAT FROM THE OPPONENTS
PERSPECTIVE.
THE THIRTY DAY COMMENT PERIOD IS
AGAIN ON THE BOB PROPAGATION OF
A LIST OF FEDERAL ROLL BACKS THE
ACTUAL.
PROPAGATING OF RULE MAKING THERE
IS NO A. P. A. PROCESS CURRENTLY
UNDER THE BILL OR UNDER THE NEW
AMENDMENTS.
THEREFORE OUR REMAINING ISSUE
AGAIN IS WITH THE EXHAUSTION
REQUIREMENT OR LACK THERE OF
AGAIN WITHOUT AN EXHAUSTION
REQUIREMENT OF THE APA ANY RULES
PROMULGATED UNDER SB.
ONE THE ONLY REMEDY AGAIN IS
THROUGH LITIGATION.
THAT CAN BE BROUGHT AT ANYTIME
BY ANY PARTY WE ARE ASKING FOR
EMERGENCY RULE MAKING UNDER THE
APA IT'S A FIVE DAY NOTICE AND
COMMENT PERIOD.
WITH TEN DAY -- OIL REVIEW THAT
PROVIDES AN EXHAUST REQUIREMENTS
SUCH THAT YOU ARE THEN LIMITED
TO THAT POOL OF ISSUES RAISED
AND BY THE PARTIES THAT RAISE
THEM -- WITH REGARD TO THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT SECTION
WE WOULD DISAGREE THAT IT'S A
SIMPLE -- PART OF THE BILL
AFFECTED WHEN THE MORE COMPLEX
AREAS.
SPECIFICALLY ARE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WOULD REMOVE ALL
OPPOSITION INCLUDING THE STATE
WATER CONTRACTORS AND ALL
INDUSTRY.
WE PROPOSE AMENDMENTS THAT
PRESERVE THE INTENT OF THE BILL.
AND TO THE EXTENT SB ONE IN OUR
VIEW EXPANDS CURRENT CALIFORNIA
LAW ON THE ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT SECTION WE'VE TAKEN ISSUE
WITH THAT WE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
THAT WOULD ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
A DELISTING OR DOWN LISTING OF A
FEDERALLY LISTED SPECIES SUCH AT
THE FISH AND GAME COMMISSION.
CAN LOOK AT THAT DEALERS HERE
DALLAS SCENE.
AND ANALYZE WHETHER LISTED UNDER
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
CALIFORNIA'S VERSION OF THAT.
AND WE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS THAT
PHIL WHAT WE CALL THE GAP WHICH
IS DURING THAT INTERIM REVIEW
PROCESS WE'VE OFFERED AMENDMENTS
THAT WOULD PRESERVE.
ALL OF THE FEDERAL PROTECTIONS
DURING THAT -- REVIEW PROCESS TO
ADDRESS ANY CONCERNS THAT DURING
THE REVIEW THOSE SPECIES WOULD
NOT BE PROTECTED.
I WE'VE BEEN HEARING IN EACH
COMMITTEE THAT WE'VE WENT TO
THAT THIS IS NOT THE PURVIEW OF
THEIR JURISDICTION BUT CANDIDLY
WE'VE TRIED TO BRING THIS INTO
THE PARKS AND WILDLIFE.
IT DID NOT GO THERE AND SO WE
ARE DAY LIGHTING THAT HERE
BECAUSE FRANKLY THERE'S ONLY TWO
POLICY COMMITTEES LEFT AND WE
THINK IT'S A RIGHT ISSUE FOR ANY
POLICY COMMITTEE AT THIS POINT
SINCE IT DIDN'T GO TO PARKS
WILDLIFE AND I'LL DEFER TO
JENNIFER I'M NOT THANKS.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JENNIFER PAIR AND THE GENERAL
MANAGER FOR THE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS WHICH ARE TWENTY
SEVEN PUBLIC WATER AGENCIES THAT
CONTRACT. FOR STATE WATER
PROJECT WATER -- THERE HAVE BEEN
SOME AMENDMENTS NONE OF THEM SO
FAR HAVE ADDRESSED ARE --
CONCERNS AROUND THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT I WOULD AGREE THE
INTENT OF THE BILL IS SIMPLE AND
I THINK THAT WE SUPPORT THAT
SIMPLE INTENT BUT UNFORTUNATELY.
THE BILL HAS THE RAMIFICATIONS
THE STATE WATER PROJECT -- THAT
ARE PRETTY DETRIMENTAL TO IT AND
AND AND THE FOR THAT REASON WE
ARE REMAIN OPPOSED.
IT IS -- WOULD ESSENTIALLY
FREEZE TEN YEAR OLD BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS IN PLACE.
IT ALSO EXPANDS WHAT IS
CURRENTLY SEIZE THE INTO THE
FEDERAL ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TWO DIFFERENT
TYPES OF REGULATIONS THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT DEFINITIONS OF TAKE.
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT THINGS THAT
THEY REGULATE THEY HAVE
DIFFERENT ABILITY TO LIST
SPECIES AND SO WE ARE TO REMAIN.
CONFUSED AND CONCERNED ABOUT
EXACTLY HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH WILDLIFE WOULD ACTUALLY
TRANSLATE FEDERAL ESA INTO STATE.
SEES -- WITHOUT ACTUALLY
EXPANDING THE INTENT AND AND
STATUE OF SEES THAT SELF.
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS
INVEST MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
ANNUALLY IN SCIENCE TO TRY TO
UNDERSTAND.
HOW THE DELTA WORKS HOW THE
SYSTEM WORKS TO BETTER --
IMPLEMENT OPERATIONS AND
EVERYTHING WE'RE DOING IS MEANT
TO BE SCIENCE BASED DECISION
MAKING.
THAT'S WHAT WE'VE BEEN PROMOTING
THAT'S WHY WE ARE COMMITTED TO A
STANDALONE SEES A PERMIT FOR THE
STATE WATER PROJECT WHICH IS
CURRENTLY ONGOING.
IT'S WHY THE FEDERAL BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS ARE CURRENTLY BEING RE
DONE TO INCORPORATE INFORMATION
THAT'S BEEN DEVELOPED OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
WE'RE ALSO APPLYING THE SAME
SORT OF APPROACH TO THE
VOLUNTARY AGREEMENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY IF SB ONE WERE TO
PASS IN ITS CURRENT FORM THE
STATE WATER PROJECT WOULD HAVE
ZERO FLEXIBILITY TO ACTUALLY
PARTICIPATE IN THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT AND WITHOUT THE STATE
WATER PROJECTS PARTICIPATION.
IT WOULD BE VERY CHALLENGING IF
NOT IMPOSSIBLE FOR THE VOLUNTARY
AGREEMENT IN ITS CURRENT FORM TO
ACTUALLY BE IMPLEMENTED -- SO
THESE ARE THE SPECIFIC REASONS
WHY WE REMAIN OPPOSED ALL TO THE
STATE WATER PROJECT BUT AGAIN I
THINK THERE'S A BROADER
IMPLICATIONS AROUND HOUSE HE
SAID GETS EXPANDED AND AND
CHANGED.
BECAUSE OF THE INTEGRATION OF
FEDERAL ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT.
OF INFORMATION APPLICATION AND
HOW IT REGULATES ON THE FEDERAL
SIDE -- WE WOULD BE WILLING TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION IF THAT
PARALLEL TYPE AMENDMENTS WERE
MADE AS THEY ARE IN THE WATER
AND AIR SECTIONS WHICH ARE
REALLY AT THE FEDERAL.
REGULATION LEVEL VERSES THE
SPECIFIC PERMIT TERM LEVEL WHICH
IS WHERE THE ESA A SECTION
CURRENTLY AS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR ANYONE ELSE WHO
WANTS TO VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT
THE BILL [inaudible]
IF.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS SAID MANNING
ON BEHALF OF WESTERN MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT THE MET MEMBER
AGENCY MY HOBBY WATER AGENCY A
STATE WATER CONTRACTOR AND
WESTERN.
WATSON'S WATER DISTRICT TO CVP
CONTRACTOR.
ALL IN OPPOSITION BECAUSE OF THE
IN THE SPEECHES THAT SECTION.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DOMINIC
TOMORROW HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER EXCHANGE
CONTRACTORS WATER AUTHORITY.
ALSO IN OPPOSITION FOR THE SAME
REASONS THANK YOU.
YOUR SINGLE PICKY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
ALSO OPPOSED TO THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES PROVISIONS.
FEELING EVER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS ALSO IN
OPPOSITION FOR RE OPPOSITION FOR
THE REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
KILL BILL HANG OUT WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WE DO REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE ESSAY
PROVISIONS AS WELL.
ANTONIO FAR WHAT THE SANTA CLARA
VALLEY WATER DISTRICT ALSO IN
OPPOSITION TO THE IS A
PROVISIONS THANK YOU.
SILVIO FOR HIM TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
JULIE HALL WITH THE ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
OPPOSITION.
TOWN JAKE WITH THE CHEMICAL
INDUSTRY COUNCIL CALIFORNIA WITH
PARTICULAR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURES ACT
ELEMENT AND NEED TO FURTHER --
RESOLVE THAT THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE TOOK ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA FRESHFORD ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND GROWERS
ASSOCIATION WESTRAC PROCESSORS
ASSOCIATION AMERICANS DASHIELL
GROWERS.
IN VARIOUS OTHER AG TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CREAMERS OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION AND APPRECIATE THE
MOMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN SO
FAR WE'RE MAIN CONSISTS
CONCERNED WITH THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT PROVISIONS.
KATHY COLE HERE ON BEHALF THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OPPOSED TO
THE S. YES THEY PROVISIONS AS
NOTED BY MS PIERRE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ROBIN BLACK ON BEHALF OF
UNITED WATER.
AND ALSO BY ROOM BETHANY
IRRIGATION DISTRICT AND LIKE
DEPRECIATE THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US SOME HELP WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOU ON
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBER BABRI BUT THREE
GOVERNMENT RELATIONS ON BEHALF
OF DESERT WATER AGENCY ELDORADO
IRRIGATION DISTRICT PALMDALE
WATER DISTRICT ROLLING WATER
DISTRICT.
VALLEY ADD WATER COALITION THE
WANNA VALLEY WATER DISTRICT IN
THE OPPOSITION.
DENNIS I'LL BE ON AB HALF THE
SAN GABRIEL VALLEY WATER AND W.
ET AND THE SENATE LEADER VALLEY
ALLMAN ALLIANCE AND SEVERAL
OTHER AGONIES WE DO WANT TO
THANK THE PRO TEM UNDERSTAFFED
FOR ALL THE WORK THEY PUT INTO
THIS WITH A FOUR TO WORK WITH
HER IN THE FUTURE.
BUT RIGHT NOW WE'RE OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON COOKING US FOR
THE HOUSEHOLD COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION OPPOSED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS TO SECURE INTERACTIVELY
JEWEL COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA.
RESPECTFULLY IN OPPOSITION AS
WELL FOR THE ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT SUCH A ISSUES PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK ON THAT.
AFTERNOON TO HIS OF THE
CALIFORNIA FOOD PRODUCERS IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE REASONS
STATED.
GOOD AFTERNOON KATIE HANSON WITH
THE CALIFORNIA RESTAURANT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE OPPOSED AS
WELL FOR THE REASONS STATED.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN WITH NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WATER ASSOCIATION WE
DO APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN TO DATE WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION OUR CONCERNS ARE WITH
THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT
PROVISIONS THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS KINDRED AYE
JOGO THE QUALQUER GROUP AND WE
HAVE THE KERN COUNTY WATER
AGENCY AND SAN BERNARDINO VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT.
THE STATE STATE WATER
CONTRACTORS AND THE KINGS RIVER
CONSERVATION DISTRICT IN KING'S
RIVER WATER CESSATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BEST A LOSS ON BEHALF OF
THE AGRICULTURAL ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION THE
CALIFORNIA POULTRY FEDERATION
THE INLAND EMPIRE UTILITIES
AGENCY.
AND THE CUCAMONGA VALLEY WATER
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION FOR THE
REASONS PREVIOUSLY STATED.
FRED MADE ON BEHALF OF THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE ALLIANCE.
VENTURE IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU IS ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO VOICE CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL.
OKAY SEEING NUMBER GOING TO
AFFECT THE DíAS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN.
THANK YOU -- SOUNDS LIKE THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF WORK DONE ON THE
BILL -- AND I GUESS MY QUESTION.
TO THE MAT MANNA PRO TEMAS I'VE.
KNOWN YOU FOR A LONG TIME AND NO
NEED TO BE A SCIENCE.
BELIEVING AGRICULTURAL LOVING.
PERSON.
SO I'M WONDERING IF YOU CAN
RESPOND TO SOME OF THE THE
OPPOSITION.
AS IT RELATES TO SPECIFIC
CULTURE AND AND SCIENCE AND THE
EVOLUTION OF SUCH.
I THANK YOU ASSEMBLY WOMAN
EGGMAN AND I I DO LIKE FOOD.
AND WATER -- AYE AYE AYES IN THE
INTEREST OF TIME BECAUSE I THINK
SHE WILL BE BRIEFER THAN I IN
TRYING TO EXPLAIN -- IN
PARTICULAR I THINK IT IS THE
SEIZE THE ISSUES -- AS IT
RELATES TO THE SPECIES AND I
WILL IF YOU DON'T MIND ASK YOU
TO COMMENT.
FROM A MORE TECHNICAL ASPECT
BECAUSE I'M SURE THEY HAVE QUITE
A FEW THINGS TO SAY TO EACH
OTHER.
ABOUT WHERE WE ARE -- IN THAT
PROCESS.
THANK YOU -- KATE POOL AGAIN FOR
ENERGY SEE -- THE INTENT IS
CERTAINLY NOT TO FREE SCIENCE IN
PLACE WE DON'T THINK THAT THAT'S
WHAT THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL
DOES INSTEAD IT SAYS.
THAT ANY -- PERMIT THAT WOULD BE
WRITTEN UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT WOULD BE
AT LEAST AS PROTECTIVE AS THE
BASELINE PERMITS WHICH ARE THE
EXISTING BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS.
ACCORDING TO THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE SO.
IT WOULD EXPLICITLY INCORPORATE --
ANY NEW SIGNS THAT HAS BEEN
DEVELOPED BUT FRANKLY WE KNOW
THAT THESE BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
THAT ARE BEING MODIFIED RIGHT
NOW.
ARE NOT GOING TO ADHERE TO THE
BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE WE'VE
SEEN DRAFTS.
THERE HAVE BEEN INDEPENDENT PEER
REVIEWS BY INDEPENDENT
SCIENTISTS THAT HAVE BEEN PRETTY
SKATING SO WE ARE TRYING TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE HAS THE
ABILITY. TO APPLY THE BEST
SCIENCE AND MAKE SURE THAT THE
SPECIES THAT ARE HERE ARE
PROTECTED.
IT'S IN THE BILL -- WE
SPECIFICALLY ADDED THAT FOR THE
PURPOSES OUTLINED IN TERMS OF
NOT LOCKING IN.
I IS SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
THEN BE STUCK WITH SO ON PAGE
FIFTEEN OF OF THE BILL IF YOU
HAVE A COPY -- LINE SEVENTEEN
AND EIGHTEEN THANK YOU.
JUST JUST TO PICK UP ON WHAT YOU
JUT SAID.
SO YOU'VE ALREADY DECIDED THOUGH
THAT THE NEW BIOLOGICAL OPINION
TO THINK IS FLAWED AND SO.
YOUR ALREADY PROJECTING THAT DID
THEY SHOULDN'T BE ADOPTED
THOUGHT WOULD YOU JUST SAID.
WELL THOSE NEW BIOLOGICAL
OPINIONS HAVE NOT BEEN ISSUED
OUT THERE NOW DO AT THE END OF
AUGUST -- WE HAVE SEEN SOME
DROPS AN INDEPENDENT SCIENTIFIC
PEER REVIEWS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
FLATTERING -- BUT FRANKLY WHAT I
THINK DOESN'T REALLY MATTER WHAT
MATTERS UNDER THE BILL IS WHAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE.
THANKS AND IF THEY THINK THAT
THOSE ARE NOT AS PROTECTIVE AS
THE PRE EXISTING CONDITIONS AND
FRANKLY THE SPECIES ARE WORSE
OFF.
THAN THEY WERE WHEN THOSE
PREVIOUS BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS
WERE ISSUED SO IT SHOULD BE AT
LEAST AS PROTECTIVE IF NOT MORE
SO THAN THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
UNDER THE UNDER THE BILL. TO
WRITE A CEASE A PERMANENT.
WHICH HAS MISSED PIERRE
MENTIONED THEY'RE ALREADY DOING --
THAT WOULD MAINTAIN THOSE
STANDARDS AND IMPROVE THE
MORNING.
HEY AT THE ONE ELSE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM.
SOME MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU AND I KNOW THIS IS
MOVING A LITTLE BIT AND WE'LL
SEE THIS TOMORROW IN JUDICIARY
BUT I HAVE BEEN.
RAISED SOME CONCERNS ABOUT HOW
THE ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEDURE ACT.
IS BEING CONSIDERED HERE AS WE
KNOW.
IT'S THE LEGISLATURE THE PASSES
LAWS AND FOR US TO DELEGATE TO
AN AGENCY THE ABILITY TO DO ITS
RULE MAKING AND THOSE RULES
PROPERLY PROMULGATED HAVE THE
FULL FORCE AND EFFECT OF LAW.
AND PROPERLY PROMULGATED IS THE
ISSUE I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT.
WE ARE ENGAGED IN ANY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW WE WE
HAVE THE BEST POSSIBILITY THAT
ANY ROOM IN IT IS BEING DONE
UNDER THIS.
WILL SURVIVE ANY TEST IN THE
FUTURE BECAUSE I THINK IT WOULD
UNDERMINE ALL OF THE GOOD WORK
HERE IF A RULE GETS PROMULGATED.
TOO QUICKLY.
OR WITHOUT APPROPRIATE PUBLIC
INPUT AND PUBLIC REVIEW AND THEN
THAT WHOLE SYSTEM GETS CALLED
INTO QUESTION BECAUSE WE HAVEN'T
DONE THOUGH THE WORK THAT WE
NEED TO DO.
ADMINISTRATIVE LAYERS OR
PROCEDURALLY SO THAT'S THAT IS A
QUESTION THAT THAT IS RAISED I
THINK WE'RE PROBABLY ON THE SAME
PAGE WITH RESPECT I THINK WITH
THAT WHAT THE AMENDMENTS ARE.
BUT I WANT TO JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THIS IS MAYBE MORE MY
HALF TOMORROW THAN TODAY THAT WE
REMAINING GAUGED.
SO THAT WE HAVE CONFIDENCE IN
THE PROCESS BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA
BE LIVING OR DYING -- ON THE
PROCESS AND I COMPLETELY
UNDERSTAND THAT WE'RE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE FED'S
ROLLING BACK THEIR RULES.
CALIFORNIA'S RELIED ON THOSE
RULES AND AND HAS ONLY FILLED IN
WHERE NECESSARY WHERE THERE HAVE
WHAT WE FEEL THEY'VE BEEN GAPS
IN IN THE FEDERAL.
THAT'S BEEN REALLY SHIP THAT'S
WORK NOW IT'S NOT WORKING
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF THE ROLL
BACKS I THINK WE NEED TO BE
CAREFUL IN HOW QUICKLY WE ACT.
AND THE AREAS THAT WE JUMP INTO.
WELL MAKE SURE THAT AND MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE THOUGHTFUL
ABOUT THAT IN FILLING THE GAPS
AS NECESSARY NOT JUST.
REACTING FOR THE SAKE OF
REACTING BUT THOUGHTFULLY
PUTTING IN PLACE THE RULES THAT
WE NEED TO PUT IN PLACE AND
THESE ARE RULES THAT ARE GOING
TO LAST FOR A LONG TIME.
I MEAN I KNOW THIS SORT OF
SUNSETS AND THERE'S THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT THERE'S COULD WORRY
ABOUT THE CURRENT ADMINISTRATION.
BUT IN MY VIEW IF WE ARE GOING
TO CHANGE THE ENDANGERED SPECIES
ACT FOR THE BETTER AND WE ARE
GOING TO BE LISTING SPECIES I
DON'T SEE THAT WORK ALSO GET.
ROLLED BACK BECAUSE WE WILL BE
DOING THIS WORK UNDER A SET OF
CALIFORNIA VALUES AND THE WAY
THAT WE EXPECT TO BE MANAGING
OUR OUR ENVIRONMENT SO I WAS THE
LOOK AT THIS AS CALIFORNIA
TAKING MORE CONTROL IN A
PRODUCTIVE AN APPROPRIATE WAY.
LONG TERM.
AND SO I WORRY ABOUT THIS
FEELING OF NEEDING TO REACT FOR
THE SAKE OF REACTING AND WE ARE
BETTER OFF SERVE BY REALLY
LOOKING AT WHAT WE HAVE IN PLACE.
MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE.
MEETING OUR STANDARDS WHETHER
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MEETS THE
STANDARDS OR NOT.
AND THAT'S KIND OF HOW I LOOK AT
THIS BILL AND AND I HOPE THAT
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT THAT WILL
IS A CONCEPT THAT WE WILL KEEP
GOING REGARDLESS OF DESTRUCTION
SAYING THERE'S VALUE IN THAT.
SO CENTER YOU'VE YOU'VE TAKEN ON
SOMETHING I NOT SURE IT'S A
SIMPLE BILL MAYBE IF YOU READ IT
LOOKS SIMPLE BUT THE
IMPLICATIONS ARE PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT.
BECAUSE OF THE WAY WE ARE
STEPPING IN. TO A TERRITORY THAT
HAD BEEN PREVIOUSLY MANAGED IN A
WAY WE FELT COMFORTABLE WITH AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND NOW.
LESS SO SHALL I SAY SO I
APPRECIATE YOU TAKING A STAB AT
THIS.
THANK YOU -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
I KNOW THAT -- THIS IS YOUR AREA
OF EXPERTISE AND I'M SURE
TOMORROW.
WHEN WE'RE BEFORE YOUR COMMITTEE
I WOULD SAY -- IF FOR ONE I'VE
NEVER SAID THIS WAS A SIMPLE
BILL AND LIKE ONE OF MY
COLLEAGUES HIS BYLINE IS IT'S A
SIMPLE BILL -- THIS IS NOT A
SIMPLE BILL I ITS IT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AND WE IT I
BELIEVE IT'S WHY WE WORK SO HARD
OVER THE LAST FIVE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS. TO ACTUALLY MAKE A LOT
OF THE CHANGES THAT WE'VE GOTTEN
FROM SOME OF THE FOLKS WHO HAVE
WORKED WITH US ON OPPOSITION YOU
CAN SEE WE'VE ACTUALLY AGREED
UPON A LOT AND WE'VE COME TO
AGREEMENT ON A NUMBER OF THINGS
WE STILL HAVE SOME THINGS WE
DON'T AGREE ON IN.
TERMS OF THE CERTAINLY -- THE
ACT AS IT RELATES TO RAGS I I
AGREE WITH YOU A STATE AGENCY
SHOULDN'T HAVE FULL REIGN AND
FORCED TO MAKE CHANGES WITHOUT A
PROPER REVIEW.
TRANSPARENCY THAT'S WHY WE PUT
INTO THE BILL TO ADOPT THE
BASELINE FEDERAL STANDARD
WITHOUT SUBSTANTIAL MODIFICATION.
IF YOU ARE WITH YOUR ATTORNEY
SAT ON IN AS THE CHAIR OF
JUDICIARY HAVE RECOMMENDATIONS
FOR HOW WE CAN MAKE THIS MORE
CLEAR -- SO THAT IT MEETS THE
INTENT OF WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO
DO THAT IT DOESN'T GIVE OUR
POWER AND AUTHORITY AWAY -- I'M
HAPPY TO ENTERTAIN YOUR
RECOMMENDATION BUT THE INTENT IS
VERY CLEAR AND WE'VE TRIED TO
PUT IT.
IN WRITING.
THANK YOU BETTER PROTECT AND THE
COMING WITH YOUR PROPONENT WHO
SAID THIS IS CIVIL BELL I
THOUGHT TRYING TO OVER SIMPLIFY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE FOR
THIS AREA IS ACTUALLY VERY
COMPLEX.
AND IF WE GET IT WRONG THERE'S A
LOT AT STAKE SO I WOULD NEVER
SCRIBE TO WHAT SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE YOU ALWAYS SAYS.
WHICH WE ALWAYS KNOW IS NEVER
TRUE AS SOON AS HE SAYS THAT BUT
WHEN IT. ONE OF ONE OF THE LIFE
OF COURSE AND CENTER LIKE I DID
NOT MENTION ANY LEGISLATORS NAME
WHEN I SAID THAT. FOR THE RECORD.
YEAH NO CHAIR WILL WE GET A
CHANCE TO RESPOND I KNOW OKAY.
UNLESS YOU ASK THE QUESTION BUT
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHER FOR MARKS
MANY ONE UP HERE.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT YOU KNOW WHEN
YOU TAKE ON A BIG ISUE IT'S
ALWAYS -- YOU GET A LOT OF
SUPPORT IN A LOT OF OPPOSITION
AND IT TAKES A LOT OF
CONVERSATIONS.
AND THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT
CERTAINLY REARED ITS UGLY HEAD
BECAUSE OF THE FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION BUT I THINK IT'S
TIME THAT CALIFORNIA TOOK A LOOK
AT WHAT OUR ROLE IT IS IN ALL OF
THIS AND SO I'M REALLY GLAD THAT
YOU BROUGHT THIS FORWARD.
AND THE AMOUNT OF AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU'VE TAKEN SHOWS THE
AMOUNT OF WORK THAT YOU HAVE
DONE AND ARE WILLING TO DO TO
WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
ADDRESS ANY OF THE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS THAT ARE OUT THERE.
AND I I AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE --
SOME MEMBER STONE THAT CERTAINLY
LOOKING UP THE PROCESS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT IN THE PROCESS BY
WHICH THAT BEST SCIENCE IS TAKEN
INTO ACCOUNT IS GOING TO BE VERY
VERY IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
IT REALLY IS SCIENCE DRIVEN --
AND THAT THERE'S A PROCESS THAT
IS YOU KNOW TRANSPARENT IN
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
THAT WOULD THAT SHOWS.
HOW THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WILL MAKE THE
DETERMINATION ABOUT ANY NEW
BIOLOGICAL OPINION OR ANY
PERMITS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE REFLECTIVE OF SCIENCE -- BUT
I HAVE ALL THE ALL CONFIDENCE
THAT AS YOU CONTINUE THROUGH THE
NEXT COMMITTEES THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATION WITH THE OPPOSITION.
TO REALLY GET THIS TO THE BEST
PLACE THAT CAN BE SO I'M HAPPY
TO SUPPORT THE BILL AND I HOPE
THAT MY COMMITTEE MEMBERS DO AS
WELL I LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING A
PROGRESS.
I'M UNTIL IT GETS BEFORE -- WITH
THAT IF WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY WE'VE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WE HAVE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I'M SORRY DID YOU WANT TO CLOSE
I ALWAYS DO THAT BECAUSE I'M A
NEW CHAIR AND I KEEP FORGETTING.
I I WILL REPEAT MY COMMITMENT TO
WORKING WITH AYE.
THE FOLKS THAT STILL HAVE ISSUES
AND CONCERNS AND HOPEFULLY AS WE
GET THROUGH THE NEXT TO
COMMITTEES WILL BE ABLE TO GET A
EVEN CLOSER THAT AS MY DESIRED
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OKAY PROCOL PLEASE.
ITEM TO SB ONE BY SENATOR ATKINS
THE MOTION IS TO PASS A REFER TO
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN I FRIEDMAN I'VE
FLORA.
FLORA NO CHILD.
SHALL I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN I FONG.
GARCIA.
GARCIA ITEM ON MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I'M MURATSUCHI.
STONE.
SO. NINE SIX TWO NINE TWO THE
BILL IS OUT AND WE'LL HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
I DO HAVE A FEW ANNOUNCEMENTS
BEFORE WE MOVE ON TO OUR NEXT
SENATOR WILL BE SENATOR UMBERG --
WITH SB FOUR FIFTY AND SB FIVE
SEVENTY SIX AND THAT'S A THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES A PROPOSED
CONSENT ITEM FOURTEEN AS BEFORE
SIXTY TWO ITEM SIXTEEN SB.
FIVE OH SEVEN SB SEVENTEEN AS BE
FIVE FIFTEEN ITEM TWENTY THREE
SB. SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE AND THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES BEEN PULLED
FROM TODAY'S HEARING ITEM TWENTY
SB.
SIX TWENTY ONE WITHOUT SENATOR
UMBERG WHENEVER YOU'RE READY THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU OF THAT AND CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- LET'S START WITH SB
FIVE SEVENTY SIX IF THAT'S OKAY
WITH YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN.
THAT'S FINE WITH ME -- IT'S A
SIMPLE BILL.
VERY GOOD VERY DON'T GO THERE
ARE IT'S A COMPLEX BILL -- THE
ISSUE IS CLIMATE CHANGE CLIMATE
CHANGES IS NO LONGER A THEORY
THAT'S IN DISPUTE CLIMATE CHANGE
IS REAL IT'S HERE.
AND IT IS AFFECTING CALIFORNIA --
THE VAST MAJORITY OF OCEAN
ECONOMY SUPPORTING
INFRASTRUCTURE LIVE WITHIN THE
COASTAL ZONE WHICH IS LIKELY TO
BE DISRUPTED AS SEA LEVELS
CONTINUE TO RISE.
UP JUST THIS PAST WEEKEND BUT
YOU OF THOSE OF YOU WHO READ THE
LA TIMES WILL NOTE THAT THERE'S
A SPECIAL SECTION.
ON CLIMATE CHANGE AND HOW IT'S
IMPACTING OF THE COASTAL
ECONOMIES.
MOTION ASKS WITH CATION SEA
LEVEL RISE WARMING OCEAN
TEMPERATURES.
THREATEN TO IRREVOCABLY ALTER
CALIFORNIA'S COASTAL ECO SYSTEM.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS RIGHT NOW OR
NOT COORDINATED IN THEIR
RESPONSE IN WHAT SB FIVE SEVENTY
SIX WOULD REQUIRE.
IS A STATE COASTAL CONSERVANCY
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A COASTAL
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND REDNESS
PROGRAM. TO RECOMMEND BEST
PRACTICES AND STRATEGIES TO
IMPROVE THE CLIMATE CHANGE
RESILIENCY A CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL COMMUNITIES -- WITH ME
HERE TODAY IS LUCAS FREDERICKS
AND NATALIE MAX IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL FROM THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY ENVIRONMENTAL AND G.
CONSULTING.
OKAY ENTITIES.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS I LOOK
AT FACTS ABOUT THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF CENTER UMBERG'S. FIVE
SIXTY SEVEN FIVE SEVENTY SIX WE
WORKED ON THIS BILL AND THIS
ISSUEFOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
ACTUALLY WE WERE THE SPONSORS OF
CENTER LOSE BILL BACK IN TWENTY
TWELVE AT SB.
TEN SIXTY SIX WHICH AUTHORIZED
THE CREATION OF A PROGRAM OF THE
COSTA CONSERVANCY WHICH ALSO
BECAME KNOWN AS THE KIND OF
READY PROGRAM -- THE CLIMATE
READY PROGRAM HS BEEN HELPING
NATURAL RESOURCES AND HUMAN
COMMITTEES ALONG CALIFORNIA'S
COAST THAT SINCE THAT TIME.
AND YOU KNOW THROUGH ITS CLIMATE
READY GRANT ROUNDS THE
CONSERVANCY IS AWARDED NEARLY
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS -- SET
FOR SEPT FIFTY SEVEN PROJECTS
STATEWIDE THERE'S MUCH MORE TO
DO THAT WE CONTINUE TO NEED
NUMEROUS TOOLS ARE TOOL KIT TO
COMBAT THE ADVERSE.
EFFECTS OF A CLIENT CHANGING
CLIMATE THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
WE APPRECIATE CENTER UMBERG
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AN
OFFERING SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX BUT
ALSO -- CERTAINLY THIS THE
CODIFYING OF THE CRIME READY
PROGRAM BECAUSE THE CONSERVANCY
AND ALSO SUPPORT THE CREATION OF
THE SIMILAR PROGRAM AT THE OCEAN
PROTECTION COUNCIL RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
TIME.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NATALIE KNOCKS
ON BEHALF OF OCEAN CONSERVANCY.
FOR OVER FORTY YEARS WE HAVE
WORKED TO CONFRONT THREATS TO
HELP THE OCEANS AND VIBRANT
COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
CLIMATE CHANGE IS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST FACING US TODAY BOTH ON
LAND AND IN THE OCEAN WE MUST
EXPAND OUR EFFORTS TO ADAPT TO
THE CHANGES THAT ARE ALREADY
UPON US THIS IS WHY WE ARE
PLEASED TO SPOKE TO SUPPORT SB
FIVE SEVEN SIX IN COMMITTEE
TODAY.
CONVERTING CLIMATE CHANGE
REQUIRE US TO WORK TOGETHER IN
THE STATE AND WITH INTENTION
INTERNATIONAL PARTNERS AROUND
THE PACIFIC RIM TO IMPROVE DATA
AND INFORMATION SHARING.
MAXIMIZING KNOWLEDGE GENERATION
AND KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER IS
CRUCIAL TO STAY AHEAD OF THE
PROBLEM.
JUST YESTERDAY LIKE SENATOR
UMBERG MENTIONED THE LA TIMES IN
AN ARTICLE ABOUT THE TOWN OF
PACIFICA.
THAT HAD TO SPEND SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS. TO COVER DAMAGES FROM
THE MOST RECENT EL NINO IMPERIAL
BEACH.
FLOODS WHEN HIGH TIDES COME IN.
AT GLEASON BEACH HOUSES FELL
INTO THE OCEAN BECAUSE OF THE
EROSION.
THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL ACT DID
FACTORS DID NOT FACTOR SEA LEVEL
RISE AND IT WAS WRITTEN IN
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX ALL IN ALL
IT WILL TAKE COMMITTED EFFORT TO
COORDINATE AMPLIFY AND
DISSEMINATE THE LATEST
SCIENTIFIC KNOWLEDGE SO THAT IT
CONFORMS STATE ACTION.
THIS BILL WOULD TAKE OUR
LEADERSHIP AND USE IT TO FOCUS
ON CRIME AN ADAPTATION FOR THE
OCEAN COAST AROUND THE PACIFIC
RIM AS CLIMATE CHANGE
ACCELERATES CALIFORNIA MUST
CONTINUE TO BE A CRITICAL VOICE
AN ADAPTATION POLICY APPLIED
RESEARCH AND READING THIS.
THE WORLD HAS A LOT TO LEARN
FROM OUR EFFORTS IN SIMILARLY WE
CAN BENEFIT GREATLY FROM THE
EXPERIENCE OF OTHERS THIS IS WHY
WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT TODAY ON
SB.
FIVE SEVEN SIX IT WILL ENSURE
CALIFORNIA'S REPAIRED FOR WHAT
IS TO COME THANK YOU THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
VOICE SUPPORT FOR THE BILL.
MANY OF THE NEW CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE.
OPERATING GARCIA WITH.
CALIFORNIA'S TRUSTED THE ROADS
LEE GET MAY PENINSULA REGIONAL
BUT SPACES [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CAITLYN CLWYD K. -- CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE KEEPER ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE ABIT ON ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
CARE TO SO ON BEHALF OF HEAL THE
BAY IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BIRD WHICH I'VE BEEN
ASKED REGISTER SUPPORT FOR
SIERRA CLUB IN SUPPORT.
FIRST LIKE IT DOES HERE WE HAVE
A CITIES AND MARK AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT.
OKAY SEEN ON IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
OKAY CINEMA BRING IT BACK TO THE
DíAS ANY COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
RIGHT WITH A MOTION A SECOND I
THINK THIS IS AN EXCELLENT BILL
IF ANYONE HASNT SEEN THE A
REALLY EXCELLENT SUPPLEMENT AND
THE LA TIMES THIS WEEKEND.
ABOUT SEALABLE RISE I HIGHLY
TAKE A LOOK.
RECOMMEND YOU TAKE A LOOK AT NO
IT'LL SHOW YOU THE GRAVITY.
ON THE SERIOUSNESS OF THE
SITUATION THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM NINETEEN SB FIVE SEVENTY
SIX BY SENATOR UMBERG THE MOTION
IS TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA.
SEE OUR LIMON [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI.
STONE.
SO. NINE FIVE ZERO FIVE LEAVE
THE BILL ON CALL.
THE WITH THEM A MOVE ON TO YOUR
NEXT BILL SB.
FOUR FIFTY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS SB -- FOUR FIFTY IS A
BILL THAT SPONSOR [inaudible]
OOPS.
SECOND THE MOTION A SECOND
PLEASE CONTINUE.
WE CAN CONTINUE AS YOU WISH --
WELL I LEARNED A LONG TIME AGO
IF YOU THE TENTATIVE IN YOUR
FAVOR THAT YOU DON'T TALK BEYOND
THAT SO.
ABU BUT LET ME JUST SAY THAT
IT'S SPONSORED BY THE CITY OF
LONG BEACH LONG A LEADER IN IN
DEALING WITH THE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS ALSO WITH ME IS COUNCIL
MEMBER AL AUSTIN.
FROM THE CITY OF LONG BEACH.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY THIS BILL IS A
VERY SMALL MODIFICATION SO FOR
MOTELS FOR EXAMPLE THAT ARE
CURRENTLY HOUSING TRANSIT ON A
DAILY BASIS.
SIMPLY WOULD ALLOW OF THE CITY
OF LONG BEACH OTHER -- NON
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES WHO MIGHT
ACQUIRE THOSE MOTELS THE UP TO
TO ADD A KITCHENETTE WOULD NOT
INCREASE THE SIZE OF THE
FOOTPRINT MORE THAN 10%.
OF IN A PROVIDES A STE A A MORE
STABLE ENVIRONMENT FROM WHICH
YOU CAN APPLY FOR JOBS THAT KIND
OF THING -- IF IF YOU WOULD
ENTERTAIN COUNCILMEMBER --
AUSTIN'S COMMENTS I WOULD BE
GRATEFUL.
NUMBER WELCOME GIVE ANYTHING TO
ACT THANK YOU -- I'D LIKE TO
JUST THANK GOD CHAIR FRIEDMAN
AND THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
FOR ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB --
FIVE FOUR FIFTY THIS BILL
OBVIOUSLY SPONSORED BY --
SENATOR THOMAS BURKE AND THE
CITY OF LONG BEACH -- CURRENTLY
AS YOU KNOW MANY.
FAMILIES ARE EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS ALREADY TEMPORARILY
LIVING IN MOTELS THROUGHOUT
MOTEL VOUCHER -- WIH -- MUCHO
VOUCHER PROGRAMS IN SOME IN
NUISANCE MOTELS ARE AN ARM
BLIGHTED NEIGHBORHOODS -- IN
LONG BEACH IN MANY CITIES TO OUR
OUR STATE.
HOW MANY OF THESE MOTELS ARE
IDEAL OPPORTUNITIES TO CONVERT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE SEQUEL
DELAYS AND COST THE CAN BE UP TO
A MILLION DOLLARS -- CAN MEET
SUCH PROJECTS ON FEASIBLE --
WE'RE ASKING SIMPLY ASKING FOR A
AND AN EXEMPTION -- IT'S A
SIMPLE BILL AS A SPIN REFERENCED
EARLIER -- WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF
OF KEEPING US BEFORE FIFTY VERY
LIMITED TO MOTEL CONVERSIONS FOR
PROJECTS THAT HAVE NO
SIGNIFICANT OR NEGLIGIBLE
IMPACTS.
TO TRAFFIC AIR QUALITY OR OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS HOWEVER I
CANNOT STRESS ENOUGH THE USING
SUBJECTIVE WORDS LIKE
SIGNIFICANT OR NEGLIGIBLE
ACTUALLY OPENS UP THE
CONVERSATION. TO POTENTIAL
LITIGATION -- AN OBJECTIVE
STANDARD AS THE SENATOR
MENTIONED -- OF 10% IS MUCH MORE
CLEARER -- AND IN ORDER FOR IT
SB FOUR FIFTY TO FUNCTION AS A
SEQUEL THAT BECAUSE AT THE THINK
WHAT AND EXEMPTION WE REALLY
NEEDED TO BE A STATUTORY
EXEMPTION IN LAW.
ON THAT MEANS THAT THE LANGUAGE
NEEDS TO BE FULLY EXEMPT FOR
MOTEL CONVERSION PROJECTS
WITHOUT REQUIRING THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION TO DO ANY
ADDITIONAL STUDIES.
THE COMMISSION ALLEGED IN COURT
AND FOR THAT I HOME AND WITH
THAT OF RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU AND YOU HAVE ANOTHER
WITNESS FEAR SIMPLE BILL.
YES BUT IN CHAIR JOHN KENNEDY
WITH RC RC ON BEHALF OF THE
WORLD COUNTIES WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS IT'S A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE TO PROVIDE A SEQUEL
EXEMPTION. FOR TRANSITIONAL IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY OTHER -- ANYONE
ELSE WANTING TO VOICE SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL.
NICOLE ORNAMENT ON BEHALF OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
CHRISLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
ROSS BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF
SACRAMENTO MAYOR DEL STEINBERG
SPORT.
TONY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
APARTMENT ASSOCIATION YOUR
SUPPORT.
SYLVIA FOR ON BEHALF THE CIVIL
JUSTICE A STATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL WISHING
TO SPEAK.
MANY OPPONENTS ANYONE WANTING TO
VOICE ANY CONCERNS.
YUP I SEE [inaudible]
ONE NUMBER.
HOW WE MISSED THE SOONER YOU
MISS SUPPORT GO AHEAD?
GO AHEAD CITY OF SANTA MONICA
AND SUPPORT POLITICS PERSONAL.
THANK YOU WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DíAS ANYONE'S ANY COMMENTS
MISTER STONE.
I DO THIS IS TO ME IT'S NOT THAT
SIMPLE AND I TYPICALLY DON'T
SUPPORT SINGLE EXEMPTIONS OR ALL
THESE CHANGES TO IT BECAUSE IT
WAS SORT OF EASY TO POINT OUT IS
A PROBLEM WHEN IT'S OFTEN NOT.
IN FACT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
ANALYSIS I'M NOT EVEN SURE THIS
IS NECESSARY YET IF WE PUT.
YET ANOTHER SEQUEL EXAMS ON THE
BOOKS THAT'S GOING TO LEAD TO
MORE AND MORE AND MORE WHEN
REALLY IT'S ABOUT.
CONNECTING WITH YOUR COMMUNITY
DOING THEWORK UP FRONT AND
HAVING THE PUBLIC INVOLVED IN
LAND USE DECISIONS AND BY
PROVIDING SEQUEL EXCEPTION WE
TAKE THE PUBLIC OUT SO I'M SORRY
I JUST CANNOT SUPPORT BILL TODAY
[inaudible]
HIS NAME.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
WAVE A ROLL CALL.
SO I'M SORRY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
LIMIT LET ME JUST GENOCIDE IS A
LARGE NUMBER STONE'S CONCERNS --
I TAKE YOUR POINT THE CAMEL'S
NOSE POINT UNDER THE TENT -- I'M
NOT SUPPORT OF OF ADDITIONAL
EXEMPTIONS THIS IS REALLY SMALL.
IT REQUIRES THAT SO FOR EXAMPLE --
FOR TYPICAL MOTEL ROOM WHICH IS
FOUR HUNDRED SQUARE FEET WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FORTY SQUARE FEET
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE LIMIT
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T EXPAND IT MORE
THAN 10%.
AND SO IT IS A CONSEQUENCE OF OF
FOR EXAMPLE -- ALLOWING SECRET
CHALLENGES TO BE MOUNTED FOR
WHATEVER REASON -- YOU'RE GOING
TO IMPEDE THE THE CITIES THAT
ARE VERY MUCH IN SUPPORT OF THIS
RELATIVELY SMALL MEASURE TO
ADDRESS THE HOMELESSNESS ISSUE --
PROVIDING A STABLE PLACE FOR
THEM TO FOR EXAMPLE EVEN RECEIVE
MAIL.
WILL -- GREATLY ASSIST THEIR
ABILITY TO FOR EXAMPLE GET A JOB
SO HAVING SAID THAT THAT'S MY
CLOTHES MANAGER EITHER TONIGHT
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM THIRTEEN US BEFORE FIFTY BY
SENATOR UMBERG THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GARCIA [inaudible]
LIMóN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
I MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI.
STONE [inaudible]
STONE NO [inaudible] FOR ONE
WHAT ONE LEAVE THE LONG CALL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
[inaudible]
SENATOR CAFIERO.
YOU ARE RIGHT ON TIME.
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE GONNA
PRESENT ON SB.
TWENTY FIVE YES.
IF I COULD HAVE JUST A SECOND I
WANT TO CHECK AND SEE
[inaudible]
FOR YES. FIVE THAT'S RIGHT.
SO -- MADAM CHAIR IF IT'S OKAY
WITH YOU IF WE COULD TAKE UP
SEVEN FORTY FOUR FIRST YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- FIRST LET ME
START BY THANKING THE COMMITTEE
FOR THEIR HARD WORK ON THIS BILL
AND AND I APPRECIATE THE THOUGHT
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD.
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS A B. AND SEE THAT ARE
LISTED ON PAGE SEVEN OF THE
ANALYSIS.
AND ALSO THAT WE DID NEGOTIATE
WITH THE COMMITTEE A COUPLE OF
ADDITIONAL ITEMS IF YOU'D LIKE I
CAN ARTICULATE THOSE.
AND IF THERE'S ANY ISSUE WE CAN.
YOU KNOW SOLVE IT -- INSTEAD OF
A SUNSET PROVISION ADDING A
SECTION IT STATES THAT THE
EXPEDITED REVIEW PROCESS IN THE
CHAPTER SHALL REMAIN IN EFFECT
UNTIL THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
FUNDS.
OUR FULLY ALLOCATED AND
DISTRIBUTED BY EACH CD.
AND NUMBER TWO ADDING A TWO DAY
NOTICE OF APPROVAL FILING
REQUIREMENT AND A NEW
SUBDIVISION THAT CLARIFIES THAT
IF AN AGENCY FAILS TO COMPLY
WITH ITS DUTY TO FILE IN TWO
DAYS.
THEN THE THIRTY DAYS FOR ANY
ACTION PROCEEDINGS.
START ON THE DATE OF THE FILING
YES OKAY GREAT -- AS WE ALL KNOW
CALIFORNIA FACES A DUAL CRISIS
OF HOMELESSNESS AND LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
THE RESULTING BURDENS FALL
PARTICULARLY HARD ON PEOPLE
LIVING WITH MENTAL ILLNESS
NEARLY A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
THOUSAND PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS IN
CALIFORNIA ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT
AND ABOUT A THIRD OF THOSE ARE
ESTIMATED TO BE LIVING.
WITH A MENTAL ILLNESS IN
MONTEREY COUNTY ARE BY ANY
ACCOUNT FOUND HOMELESSNESS GREW
BY 23% BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN IN TOTAL TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND THIRTY SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS.
IT'S THE HIGHEST IN TEN YEARS WE
KNOW THAT HAVING PEOPLE WITH
SERIOUS HEALTH CONDITIONS LIVING
AND SHELTERED RECYCLING IN AND
OUT OF HOSPITALS AND
INCARCERATION IS COSTLY.
AND THAT THE RESULTS -- IT
RESULT IN NEEDLESS SUFFERING FOR
THE HOMELESS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT LAST FALL
CALIFORNIA VOTERS OVERWHELMINGLY
APPROVED PROPOSITION.
TWO THE NO PLACE LIKE HOME
INITIATIVE WHICH AUTHORIZES THE
STATE ISSUED TWO BILLION DOLLARS
IN BONDS TO CREATE TWENTY
THOUSAND UNITS OF PERMANENT.
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR HOMELESS
MENTALLY ILL INDIVIDUALS.
RESEARCH SHOWS SUCH HOUSING
KEEPS PEOPLE INSIDE REDUCES
ILLNESS AND SUFFERING AND LOWERS
PUBLIC COSTS.
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR HELPS
FULFILL THE INTENT OF THE VOTERS
BY CLARIFYING AND STREAMLINING
THE LOCAL APPROVAL PROCESS FOR
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND
ASSOCIATED SERVICES.
LIKE THOSE THAT NO PLACE LIKE
HOME BONDS ARE FUNDING.
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR UTILIZES THE
STREAMLINING APPROVAL PROCESS
FOR SUPPORT HOUSING PROJECTS
ENVISIONED IN LAST YEAR'S.
AB TWENTY ONE SIXTY TWO AND A
PLACES PROCESS TO NO PLACE LIKE
HOME PROPOSITION TWO SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
THE BILL EXPANDS THE DEFINITION
OF SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
AND INCLUDES THAT.
THAT.
IT MAY BE A USE BY RIGHT IN
ZONES WERE MULTI FAMILY AND
MAKES USE ARE PERMITTED.
CALIFORNIA VOTERS MADE IT CLEAR
THAT THEY WANT PEOPLE WHO HAVE
MENTAL HEALTH DISORDERS AND ARE
HOMELESS TO BE SHELTERED ND
CARE.
FOR NO PLACE LIKE HOME GOT MORE
VOTES THAN ANY OTHER MEASURE ON
THE NOVEMBER BALLOT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE ON SB.
SEVEN FORTY FOUR THANK YOU YOU
HAVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT I DO.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M MAJOR ANDREAS
WITH THE STEINBERG INSTITUTE AND
WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS OF SB.
SEVEN FOUR FOUR AND A CENTER
COVER YET OR I JUST MENTIONED --
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF PROPOSITION
TWO AND ITS PASSAGE IT'S OVER
WILL BE SUPPORT FROM THE VOTERS.
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO HAVE THIS
BILL HAVE WORKED SO CLOSELY WITH
THE COMMITTEE IN IMPROVING --
AWAY OF DELIVERING THOSE FUNDS
QUICKLY TO CREATE THE
APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF HOUSING
THAT WE SO DESPERATELY NEED SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND WE ALSO
I'M JOINED BY -- TINA THOMAS.
THE STEINBERG IS A TWO BOARD
MEMBER IS HERE ALSO TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS IF NEEDED.
GOOD AFTERNOON TEA TO THOMAS
THOMAS LAW GROUP HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND I'M HERE REALLY
JUST ANSWER QUESTIONS BUT I DID
WANNA THANK YOU LAWRENCE FOR
WORKING WITH US OVER THE FOURTH
OF JULY WEEKEND IT WAS VERY.
MUCH APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL.
ERIC HARRIS WITH DISABILITY
RIGHTS CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TONY BLAIR WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
PARDON ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT AS
WELL THANKS.
AND AT THE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTY OF ALAMEDA AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL OR
WISHING TO VOICE ANY CONCERNS TO
THE BILL.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE CORD YES PERSON FROM
THE JUST A COUNCIL IN LIGHT OF
THE AMENDMENTS WE THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR THE FINE WORK IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF.
OUR CONCERNS WERE ONLY FOCUS ON
THE COURT IMPACTS OF THE
EXPEDITED JUST REVIEW CONSISTENT
WITH ALL OF THESE -- EXPEDITED
SEQUELS SORT THAT PROVISIONS
REMOVED FROM THE BILL WE
WOULDN'T HAVE ANY -- IS NO
LONGER WITHIN OUR PURVIEW THANKS.
THANK YOU.
ANYBODY ELSE.
AARON RUBBER GONE WE HAVE FOR
THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION ALIGNING OUR
COMMENTS WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND IF THE EXPEDITED
REVIEW WAS REMOVED WOULD BE
NEUTRAL ON THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOING BACK NOW TO THE
DYESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION.
WE DO NOT YET HAVE EMOTIONAL
THINK SOME OF THE BILL OKAY.
AND A SECOND YEAH.
AND THEN -- I I I SUPPORT THIS
YOU KNOW ONE OF THE FRUSTRATIONS
IN CALIFORNIA IS WE HAVE ENOUGH --
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY CRISIS
CERTAINLY HOMELESSNESS CRISIS
AND CERTAINLY NOT ALWAYS BUT
STRONG CONNECTION BETWEEN
HOMELESSNESS -- MENTAL ILLNESS
AND ADDICTION SEE IT RIGHT HERE
IN OUR STREETS AND ONE OF THE
FRUSTRATING THINGS THAT --
VOTERS HAVE SEEN IS THAT WHETHER
IT'S IN LOS ANGELES PASSING A
BOND MEASURE OR THIS MEASURE ON
THE BALLOT.
THAT WE'VE STEPPED UP AND PUT
MINE THE BUDGET WE VOTED ON LAST
WEEK WE PUT UNDER THE MILLION
DOLLARS TO ADDRESS HOMELESSNESS
AND WE HAVE PROJECTS THAT ARE.
LANGUISHING IN THEY'LL BE READY
IN TWO YEARS THREE YEARS FIVE
YEARS AND PEOPLE SEE TODAY.
YOU KNOW THERE'S A CRISIS IT'S A
MORAL CRISIS WE LOOK AT IT SO --
I AM IN SUPPORT THIS I I THINK
IT'S A REASONABLE APPROACH I DO
WANT TO ASK JUST CLARIFY SO.
THIS TAKES THAT THIS FOCUSES ON
THE BY RIGHT ISSUE AND MAKES IT --
MINISTERIAL AS OPPOSED TO HAVING
TO GO THROUGH.
LOVE THEM AND BODIES PLANNING
COMMISSIONS AND COUNCILS SO THE
THE WHOLE JUDICIAL REVIEW PIECES
TOTALLY SEPARATE FROM THE BILL
NOW SO IT'S JUST THIS.
THE SAID IRAQ YEAH.
SO THE HEAD OF THOSE TWO THINGS
PLAY TOGETHER HOW WILL THAT WORK
WITHOUT HAVING THE OTHER
[inaudible]
AB -- FIRST OF ALL WE EXPECT TO
HAVE VERY LITTLE LITIGATION
RELATED.
TO APPROVALS UNDER THIS SECTION
BECAUSE IT'S GOING TO BE BY
RIGHT.
AND WE BELIEVE THAT THEY'LL BE
VERY LITTLE LITIGATION BUT TO
THE EXTENT THAT THERE IS THERE'S
AN EXPEDITED NOTICE READ --
PROVISION AND THEN LITIGATION
HAS TO BE FILED EXPEDITIOUSLY.
THE RECORDS IN THESE CASES THESE
CASES PRETTY QUICKLY THROUGH THE
COURTS.
SO IT'S JUST NOT A GUARANTEE
THEY'LL BE COMPLETED BY THE
COURTS WHICH IS TAKEN OUT
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MANAGER.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE WELL I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON HOW TO
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS THAT WE HAD
HEARD ABOUT THE BILL I THINK
IT'S STILL A REALLY.
A POWERFUL PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WILL HELP YOU GET THESE
VERY NEEDED -- PROJECTS - YOU
KNOW EXPEDITED AND AND YOU KNOW
IT BILTMORE QUICKLY SO THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OKAY THANK YOU YOU
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU I THINK
I NEED A LITTLE SIGN HERE THAT
SAYS LET THEM?
DO THEIR CLOTHES.
THAT GOT INTO SOME KIND OF WEIRD
HABIT OKAY.
WITH THAT LET'S HAVE A ROLL CALL
SB TWENTY TWO I MEAN I DON'T
TWENTY TWO SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR
BY CABALLERO THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN IPHONE [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY HI
MCCARTY I'M OUT TO TREAT.
STONE.
STONE I FOUR ONE I MEAN.
FOR ZERO OKAY WERE FOUR ZERO
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
NOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PRESENTING SB TWENTY FIVE IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING WE'RE GONNA BE
MAKING THIS INTO YOUR BILL BUT
WE'RE GOING TO BE HAPPY TO HEAR
YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
THE CHAIR -- FOR TO BE ABLE TO
PRESENT THE BILL DESPITE THE
FACT THAT IT IS GOING TO BE MADE
IT TO YOUR BILL -- THE CHAIR DID
AGREE WITH ME THAT -- AND OTHERS
TO HOLD HEARINGS AND TO BRING IN
THE STAKEHOLDERS. TO DISCUSS THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF THE SECRET
IMPACTS IN THE SOLUTION AND AND
I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS.
SO I THE REASON I WANTED TO
SPEAK TODAY IS THAT I I AM.
THERE'S A THERE'S THIS MORAL
IMPERATIVE AND I AND I REALLY
FEEL LIKE -- THERE ARE SOME
THINGS THAT THE COME WAIT TILL
TOMORROW AND SOME JUST CAN'T.
AND AS IT HAS BEEN ARTICULATED
WE ALL KNOW THAT WE HAVE AN
INCREDIBLE HOUSING SHORTAGE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
DEPENDING ON WHAT REPORT YOU'RE
READING.
IT'S ANYWHERE BUT BETWEEN A
HUNDRED AT BETWEEN ONE POINT
FIVE MILLION TO THREE MILLION
HOUSING UNITS SHORT SO WE COULD
BUILD THEM.
LIKE THIS TOMORROW WE'D HAVE
FAMILIES AND INDIVIDUALS IT
WOULD MOVE INTO THURMOND AND
DESPERATELY NEED THAT -- THAT
HOUSING AVAILABILITY AND IT IT
MANIFESTS ITSELF NOT ONLY IN
URBAN CENTERS BUT ALSO IN RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN MY OWN COMMUNITY
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING
IN GARAGES THAT HAVE KIDS THAT
ARE SLEEPING IN ADDICTS WHICH IS.
TREMENDOUSLY AND SAFE -- WE HAVE
PEOPLE THAT ARE LIVING IN SHEDS
THEY'RE LIVING IN THE CARS AND
SO THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE THAT
I'VE HEARD OVER AND OVER AGAIN
IS THERE A NEED -- FOR FOR
HOUSING FOR WORKING FAMILIES AND
THEY NEED TO BE AFFORDABLE AND
IN THE MEANTIME WE'RE SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS EVERY COUNTY
AND CITY TO CLEAN UP TRASH AND
TO SANITIZE.
AREA WERE AREAS WHERE PEOPLE --
THEIR NEEDS ARE NOT BEING MET
AND WHERE THEY'RE LIVING OUTSIDE
AND PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE BEING
DESTROYED BY IN THE PROCESS SO
TWO YEARS AGO I I RAN A BILL --
THAT.
BUT THAT WAS SEEKING TO TO SOLVE
THIS ISSUE ONE OF THE GOOD
THINGS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DID TWO YEARS AGO I
SAY.
WHEN THEY PASSED THEIR -- THEIR
THEIR BUDGET BILL THEY CREATED
WHAT ARE CALLED OPPORTUNITIES ON
TWITTER OPPORTUNITIES FOR STATES
TO BE ABLE TO TAKE.
UP PUBLIC DOLLARS AND HELP
IMPROVE THEIR POOREST
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE EIGHT HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE OPPORTUNITY ZONES THAT HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED AND THEY
DESPERATELY NEED REVITALIZATION
WHICH MEANS THEY NEED HOUSING
AND THEY NEED JOBS.
AND WHEN I DID MY ASSEMBLY BILL --
THIRTY THIRTY IT LOOKED AT THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE SIX TRILLION
DOLLARS IN PUBLIC IN A PRIVATE
FUNDS TO BE ABLE TO INVEST IN
THESE COMMUNITIES AND AND THOSE
ARE CAPITAL GAINS -- FUNDS TO BE
ABLE TO BUILD WORKFORCE HOUSING
CREATE GOOD JOBS AND THAT BILL
CREATED A SEQUEL EXEMPTION AND
WE MAKE WE GOT IT THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE I PASSED -- I PASSED
IT THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY WITH
FIFTY SIX VOTE AND IT ENDED UP
BEING HELD UP IN THE SENATE IN
APPROPRIATIONS -- AND AND AND
PART OF THE CHALLENGE WHEN I
CAME BACK IN THE SENATE THIS
YEAR'S I TOOK A LOOK AT THAT AND
I SAID YOU KNOW -- IT MADE
PEOPLE UNCOMFORTABLE AND IT WAS
A LITTLE BIT DIFFICULT IT WAS A
HEAVY LIFT BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE
WERE ASKED -- TO AGREED THAT WE
WOULD WAIVE SEEK WELL IN ORDER
TO BE ABLE TO GET THERE AND SO
THIS YEAR WHAT I DID IS I TOOK A
MUCH SOFTER APPROACH AND I SAID
YOU KNOW -- THAT THAT THE CRISIS
HASN'T GOTTEN ANY BETTER WE'RE
IN MUCH MORE DESPERATE.
NEED OF HOUSING THAN WE WERE TWO
YEARS AGO AND SO THE APPROACH.
THAT I TOOK WAS TO WORK VERY
DILIGENTLY WITH THE SENATE
COMMITTEES THAT WE WENT THROUGH
AND WE WE SB TWENTY FIVE
REQUIRES THE HIGHEST IN IN
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS PROJECTS
MUST BE CONSISTENT WITH GENERAL
PLANS AND ZONING CODES.
IT REQUIRES LEAD GOLD
CERTIFICATION WAS ZERO NET
EMISSIONS ZERO NET GHG.
IT PROTECTS AGAINST
GENTRIFICATION AND DISPLACEMENT
75% OF THE TOTAL SQUARE FOOTAGE
HAS TO BE DEDICATED TOWARDS
HOUSING AND A MINIMUM OF 40% OF
THOSE UNITS HAVE TO BE
AFFORDABLE.
AND IT REQUIRES A SKILLED AND
TRAIN WORK WORK FORCE AND
PREVAILING WAGE AND THERE'S NO
SECRET EXEMPTION.
PERIOD YOU HAVE TO BUILD AND AND
GO THROUGH THE WHOLE PROCESS TO
DETERMINE -- WHETHER YOU HAVE TO
DO A SECRET DOCUMENT OR NOT
DEPENDING ON ON YOUR GENERAL
PLANTS IN YOUR ZONING CODES.
IT JUST DOES ONE THING AND THAT
ONE THING IS CREATE -- A
EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW
PROCESS THAT HAS TO BE DONE
WITHIN TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DAYS IF IT'S ECONOMICALLY FOR IS
IT IF IT'S FEASIBLE TO DO THAT.
DISTRESSED AS I SIT HERE TODAY
IS THAT -- WE WORKED REALLY HARD
AT TRYING TO CRAFT A SOLUTION
THAT WAS GOING TO BE ABLE TO
GIVE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO GO OUT TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE THAT ARE
SAYING CAM CALIFORNIA ISN'T
DOING ANYTHING. TO BUILD A
HOUSING THAT WE DESPERATELY NEED
CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO BE ABLE TO
STEP UP AND TO TELL -- IT PEOPLE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE HEAR YOU
WE UNDERSTAND WHAT THE NEED IS
AND WE'RE WILLING TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
AND IF WE CAN GIVE.
STADIUMS AND ARENAS.
A AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THEIR
COMPLICATED PROJECTS REVIEWED
WITHIN TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
DAYS AND CERTAINLY WE CAN TAKE --
A THESE MIXED USE AND HOUSING
PROJECTS AND AND GIVE THEM THE
SAME KIND OF KIND OF RELIEF.
IT IN IN TERMS OF A JUDICIAL
JUDICIAL REVIEW AND ON THE ONE
THAT HAND EYE HERE -- SEEK WAYS
IN A PROBLEM IN IN THAT'S REALLY
NOT IT IS THE SEQUEL EDUCATION
ISN'T WHAT'S CAUSING THE PROBLEM
WELL IF IT'S NOT CAUSING THE
PROBLEM.
THEN WE CERTAINLY WON'T SEE -- A
LOT OF SECRET CASES FILED -- IT
IN ITS THE CERTAINTY OF
CONSTRUCTION IT'S PROVIDING AN
OPPORTUNITY TO KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO GET A
PROJECT STARTED.
FROM THE BEGINNING OF THE
PROJECT TO THE END WITHIN A
CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME SO WHY IS
THIS ALL IMPORTANT -- I CRAFTED
SB TWENTY FIVE SO THAT THE
CITIES IN THE COUNTY THAT NEED
BILL HOUSING -- BITS AFFORDABLE
TO THE WORKING FAMILIES CAN GET
THEIR HANDS ON THE SIX TRILLION
DOLLARS OF CAPITAL GAINS TAX
IT'S AVAILABLE FOR PRIVATE
INVESTMENT.
SO THAT WE CAN IMPROVE THE
STREETS AND THE SEWERS AND THE
ELECTRICAL IN SOME OF OUR MOST
CHALLENGING NEIGHBORHOODS SO
THAT WE CAN BUILD HOUSING PARKS
AND RECREATION CENTERS.
IMPROVE LIVING CONDITION IN OUR
POOREST NEIGHBORHOODS AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY SO WE COULD START
CHAU STRUGGLING CALIFORNIANS.
THAT ARE FACING RISING RENTS AND
THAT OVERCROWDING IN APARTMENTS
IN GARAGES IN ATTICS.
CHILDREN AND SENIORS WHO ARE
HOMELESS THAT THEIR NUMBER ONE
CONCERN THAT HAS BEEN RAISED IT
IS SOMETHING THAT WERE -- TAKING
SERIOUSLY AND THAT WE UNDERSTAND
THE NEED TO BUILD AS QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE AND TO DO IT IN A WAY
THAT PROTECTS OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
AND THAT -- THAT THAT REALLY
DOESN'T -- DOESN'T TRAMPLE ON ON
ANYONE'S RIGHTS OR ON ON THE
SEEK SEEK WELL BECAUSE YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THAT WHOLE PROCESS
IN THE FIRST PLACE SO -- WHAT
WHAT SB TWENTY FIVE IS?
IS FOCUSED ON IS CREATING
SOLUTIONS BY USING THE SAME
TOOLS THAT WE'VE USED IN THE
PAST AND SO NOT EVERYTHING CAN
WAIT TILL TOMORROW.
DID I MENTION THAT THERE SIX
TRILLION DOLLARS IN CAPITAL
GAINS TAX -- PRIVATE INVESTMENT
THAT WOULD HELP US TO HOUSE ARE
WORKING FAMILIES WE OWE IT TO
THEM AND THE TAX CREDIT ENDS IN
SIX YEARS AND AS YOU NOW IF YOU
START TO DEVELOP A PROJECT RIGHT
NOW.
AND BELIEVE THAT YOU CAN START
CONSTRUCTION WITHIN SIX YEARS --
I'VE GOT A BROKE AT BRIDGE IN
BROOKLYN THAT I CAN SELL YOU --
THE REASON THIS IS SO
TREMENDOUSLY IMPORTANT IS WE'RE
ASKING PEOPLE TO INVEST MONEY IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE NEED TO BE
COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER STATES SO
I UNDERSTAND WE'RE GOING TO COME
BACK NEXT YEAR AND HAVE THE SAME
CONVERSATION IN JANUARY -- BUT I
AM I AM I AM BEGGING YOU -- TO
TO SERIOUSLY LOOK AT THIS ISSUE
AND TO SAY -- IS IT A BURDEN ON
OUR COURT SYSTEM IS IT A BURDEN
ON ON ANYONE TO HAVE AN
EXPEDITED REVIEW IF WE CAN GET --
THE RESOURCES IN AND AND MY
ANSWER IS IS -- UNEQUIVOCALLY NO
I THINK THE COURTS ARE CAPABLE
OF HANDLING HOW AT HANDLING
THESE KINDS OF ISSUES AND QUITE
FRANKLY WE THIS LEGISLATURE ALL
THE TIME SETS PRIORITIES FROM
THE FOR IT FOR THE COURT -- AND
IF IT REQUIRES MORE RESOURCES WE
ALSO CONTROL THE POCKET BOOK AND
SO WE HAVE THE ABILITY TO DO
THAT'S WHAT SO WHEN I THINK THE
CHAIR FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
VENT A LITTLE BIT TODAY -- YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND MY MY
EXASPERATION AT AND HAVING TO GO
BACK AND TELL CONSTITUENTS IN MY
COMMUNITY THAT -- THAT I'M
WORKING REALLY HARD BUT THAT WE
JUST CAN'T SEEM TO GET ANYTHING
DONE -- QUICKLY AND AND FRANKLY
I THINK THIS WAS IN EASIER PILL
TO SWALLOW THAN AT AB THIRTY
THIRTY BUT BANK AYE NOPE --
OTHERS WOULD WOULD DISAGREE SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY PRESENT MY BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU YOU HAVE A WITNESS
WITH YOU I DO TO SPEAK TWO
MINUTES PLEASE SHARE HOLLY FOR
MANY ON BEHALF OF HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY CALIFORNIA I ALWAYS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL -- AND IT'S
AND I'M REALLY LOOKING FOR TO AN
OPTIMISTIC MADAM CHAIR THAT WE
CAN HAVE A GROUP AS A ROUND
TABLE DISCUSSION HOPEFULLY
BETWEEN NOW AND AND JANUARY.
OF THE FOLKS THAT OF ALL GIVEN
FEEDBACK THROUGH THE COMMITTEE
PROCESS BUT I THINK REALLY
EVERYBODY IN THE SAME ROOM TO
DISCUSS.
YOU KNOW THE CONCERNS A LOT OF
US HAVE THAT SEQUENCE BECOME A
TOOL IN A DETERRENT -- TO
PROJECTS BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF
LITIGATION VERSES ITS INTENDED
PURPOSE WHICH IS TO PROTECT THE
ENVIRONMENT IN WAYS THAT WE CAN
WITHOUT CREATING NEW EXEMPTIONS
WITHOUT NEW WAVERS FROM C. CLUB
MADE TO MAKE THAT TOOL.
LESS OF A DETERRENT AND
SOMETHING THAT REALLY CAN HELP
KEEP THESE PROJECTS PROGRESS IN
A TIMELY FASHION SO AGAIN WE'RE
REALLY OPTIMISTIC TO WORK WITH
YOU MADAM CHAIR.
I'M OVER THE INTERIM AND
HOPEFULLY WE CAN COME UP WITH A
VIABLE SOLUTION TO MAYBE ONE
BILL INSTEAD OF SIX OR SEVEN
BILLS -- THAT REALLY CAN GET TO
THE ROOT OF THE PROBLEMS THAT I
HAVE A LOT OF DEVELOPMENTS
HABITAT AND OTHERS HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE OF THE
LITIGATION THAT HAS SURROUNDED
SEEK OVER THE LAST DECADE THANK
YOU WELL THANK YOU AND I'M A BIG
FAN OF HABITAT I COME FROM A
CITY.
THAT HAS MORE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY PROJECTS AND THE REST
OF THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY
COMBINED I AM CURIOUS HOW MANY
PROJECTS HABITAT HAS BUILT THAT
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE MAY HAD A
DIRECT IMPACT ON HOW MANY
PROJECTS HAVE YOU HAD THAT HAD
LITIGATION THAT TOOK MORE THAN
TWO AND SEVENTY DAYS -- TO BE
HEARD.
AND WE'VE ONLY HAD ONE THAT HAS
BEEN SUBJECTED TO LITIGATION BUT
WE HAVE HAD SEVERAL THAT HAVE
BEEN DETERRED FROM MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE PROJECT BECAUSE
OF THE POTENTIAL.
LITIGATION THAT COULD COME AT IT
AS BECAUSE OF THE LOCATION OF
BECAUSE OF THE SURROUNDING
NEIGHBORHOOD.
AND SO HAVING ONE OF THE
STREAMLINING WOULD HAVE BEEN
ENOUGH FOR YOU TO GO FORWARD
EVEN WITH THE THREAT OF
LITIGATION THIS PROJECT WOULD
HAVE MOVED FORWARD IF IT IF IT
IF IT HAD A HAD THE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DAY -- THE GUARANTEE OF
BEING HEARD IN THAT AMOUNT OF
TIME WITH HAT IT MADE THE
DIFFERENCE I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY WAY TO TELL THE ONE IN
REDWOOD CITY SPECIFICALLY WAS IT
SETTLED IN SIXTEEN MONTHS -- IN
A LOT OF THAT WAS IT THE
PRESSURE -- ON TO THE LEAD AGAIN
AND THAT BUT THAT SAME POTENTIAL
LITIGATION ACROSS THE STREET
FROM ANOTHER NON HABITAT
DEVELOPMENT THE TURF THAT
PROJECT FOR MOVING FORWARD TO
THE I THINK IT'S REALLY HARD TO
TELL BECAUSE EVERY CIRCUMSTANCES
YOU KNOW WAS VERY DIFFERENT.
DEPENDING ON THE NEIGHBORHOOD
AND BECAME A DEPENDING ON THE
PROJECT AND HABITAT IS A BRAND
THAT NOT EVERYONE LIKES TO CO.
SO HABITAT THOUGH THEY FOR THE
YOU KNOW HAVE RECENTLY BEEN SUED.
A LOT OF OUR PROJECTS HAVE NOT
BEEN SUBJECT TO THE LITIGATION
THE PAST AND A LOT OF THEM HAVE
BEEN SMALLER BUT NOW.
BECAUSE OF THE DEMAND FOR
HOUSING A LOT OF OUR PROJECTS
ARE NOW HIGHER DENSITY PROJECTS
THAN TRADITIONALLY HABITAT I
THINK IN YOUR DISTRICT HAVE BEEN
ONE HAVE FAMILY ONE HOME AT A
TIME.
BUT WE HAVE SOME OF OUR URBAN
AFFILIATES THAT ARE NOW STARTING
TO BUILD UP TO A HUNDRED AND AN
A PLUS I'M UNITS TOGETHER SO I
DON'T THINK THAT NEW MODEL OF
HABITAT HAS NECESSARILY BEEN
TESTED BECAUSE IT'S NEW AND IT'S
EVOLVING.
OKAY THANK YOU.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS ACTUALLY
WALKER WITH NASA MEN ON BEHALF
OF THE MODERATE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT.
RICHARD HARMON ON BEHALF OF THE
CITIES OF TULARE MERCED HE WORD
AND THE COUNTY OF MARIPOSA.
TONY WITH THE A CALIFORNIA
PROMISE OCEAN HERE SPORTS WILL.
IN A SECOND THOUGHTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND SUPPORT.
SILVIO FOR HIM TO HAVE THE CIVIL
JUSTICE CESSATION CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT.
GABRIELLE MORALIS WITH WAS FIELD
AND SUPPORT.
SCOTT WHAT SHOULD BE AT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL'S DECISION OF LIKE
COWORKERS.
WESTERN STATES COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS
MY NAME IS TIFFANY YANG OF THE
CALIFORNIA BY RELIGIOUS ALLIANCE
OR SAY HOW -- WELL WE REALLY
APPRECIATE OUR CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE ABOUT
THE BILL YOU MUST RESPECTFULLY
CONTINUE TO REMAIN OPPOSED
UNLESS AMEND AT THIS TIME.
CENTER ALRP ARE RAISING A NUMBER
CONCERNS WHICH WE HAVE DETAILS
AND A LIST OF PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS AUTHORS OFFICE WE
OBVIOUSLY SUPPORT HOUSING AND IT
WILL DEVELOPMENT BUT WANT TO
MAKE SURE IT'S DONE THE RIGHT
WAY.
FIRST OF YOU KNOW.
THIS BILL WOULD APPLY NOT ONLY
TO THE AYE OURS BUT ALSO TO NAG
JACKSON MITIGATED NEGATIVE
DECLARATIONS.
AND EXEMPTS PROJECTS THIS IS
BECAUSE YOU KNOW THERE'S A
REALIZATION THAT MOST THESE
HOUSING PROJECTS ARE NOT ONLY
SUBJECT TO YARDS BUT TO OTHER
KINDS OF VIRAL REVIEW.
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT
REDUCING PUBLIC PARTICIPATION
FOR PROJECT THAT REALLY DO LESS
OF A REVIEW AND HAVE LESS PUBLIC
PROCESS.
SECOND WE HAVE CONCERNS OF THIS
BILL WOULD APPLY TO A WIDE
VARIETY PROJECTS NOT JUST
HOUSING.
AS YOU MIGHT KNOW -- THIS BILL
APPLY TO PROJECTS WHAT ABOUT
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AS WAS
MENTIONED.
AND OTHER THINGS LIKE ENHANCE
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
DISTRICTS AND OTHER TEN OTHER
TYPES OF FUNDING SOURCES.
SO AS A RESULT WE ARE REALLY
CONCERNED THESE KINDS OF
PROJECTS COULD BE -- NOT
COMMUNITY SERVING AND THEY MAY
EVEN CAUSE UNINTENTIONAL
ENVIRONMENTAL OR OTHER KINDS OF
HARMS A REALLY EXCELLENT
DISPLACEMENT THESE KINDS OF
COMMUNITIES SO -- YOU KNOW FOR
US IT'S REALLY MAKE BIG THAT WE
MAKE SURE THAT HISTORICALLY
DISADVANTAGED COMMITTEES HAVE
THE KINDS OF PROTECTIONS AND
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED -- AND
WE'RE NOT QUITE SURE THIS BILL
AS IT STANDS RIGHT NOW WILL
REALLY GET TO THE HEART OF THOSE
CONSIDERATIONS.
LASTLY REALLY WANT TO YOU KNOW
MENTIONED THE TWO HUNDRED
SEVENTY DAY AGE EXPECT YOU TO
SHOW VIEW ISSUE -- WE RECOGNIZE
THAT YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY.
THE HOUSING DEVELOPMENTS REALLY
IMPORTANT OUR STATE BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS REALLY
GONNA PUT SIEGEL CASES -- IN
FRONT OF OTHER CIVIL CASES WE
ALREADY KNOW THAT SECRET HE'S
ALREADY RECEIVE PARTING COURT.
SO WE THINK THAT THIS WOULD NOT
NESTLE BE FAIR ALSO WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT IF SOMEONE WANTS
TO CHALLENGE A PROJECT THEY CAN
DO SO IN OTHER MEANS BESIDES A
CIVIL LAWSUIT SO. FOR A NUMBER
OF CONCERNS -- WE REALLY WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK TALK TO THE
AUTHORS OFFICE ABOUT THIS.
BUT WE CAN DETERMINE OPPOSE THIS
BILL AND HOPE TO CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
VOICE THEIR OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME
IS CHELSEA TO WITH THE CENTER ON
RACE POVERTY ENVIRONMENT WE
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
CENTERS OFFICE IN.
AMONG NUMEROUS CONCERNS OF WE
REALLY CONCERNED THAT THE BILL
REMAINS EXPANSIVE IN SCOPE
MEANING THAT COULD ALLOW LARGE
INDUSTRIAL COMMERCIAL PROJECT.
IN THERE FOR HARMAN
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH OF LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WE DON'T SEE
THE NEED TO TRADE MEANINGFUL
PURPOSE PARTICIPATION SPECIALLY
BY DJ COMMUNITIES WHEN.
OTHERWISE DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE
A VOICE -- TO WE DON'T
NECESSARILY SEE TRADING THAT IN
ORDER TO PROVIDE CERTAINTY FOR
DEVELOPERS MUST RESPECTFULLY IT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
BRENT AND ALSO SEE A CALIFORNIA
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
BRIAN A WIKI CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY ALSO
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THANK YOU.
JOHNSON JOHNSON PHYSICIANS FOR
SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES AND WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE THANK YOU.
CORD YES WAS ON BEHALF THE JUST
A COUNCIL WERE CONCERNED ABOUT
THE COURT IMPACTS.
HI MY NAME IS SYDNEY FONG AND
I'M REGISTERING A RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION FROM ASIAN PACIFIC
ENVIRONMENTAL NETWORK THANKS.
IN ALASKA'S I'M REGISTERING
OPPOSITION FOR COMMUNITIES FOR A
BETTER ENVIRONMENT AND ONLINE
OUR COMMENTS TO THE TO THE THE
LEAD WITNESS WHO -- INDICATOR IN
OUR SUMMER CONTENTS IN
OPPOSITION FOR THE BILL THANK.
ERIN RUBBER GONE WE HAVE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA JUDGES ASSOCIATION
AGAIN IN RETROSPECT OPPOSITION
TO THE EXPEDITED JUDICIAL REVIEW
THANK.
THANK YOU BRING IT BACK UP TO
THE DíAS ONE MEMBER PRESENT
WOULD YOU LIKE.
TO COMMENT ABSOLUTELY MADAM
CHAIR PERSON -- THE CENTER I
JUST WANNA THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- AND
IT'S IT'S KIND OF SAD TO SEE IT
BECOME A TO YOUR BILL -- I SEE A
LOT A NEW BE ISM HAPPENING.
A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
SEE THESE THINGS HAPPEN -- I SAW
A HABITAT PROJECTS AND ACTUALLY
NUMEROUS HABITAT PROJECTS IN MY
CITIES.
GET BLOCKED.
BY PRETTY MUCH EVERY COURT MEANS
NECESSARY BECAUSE OF NAY BE ISM --
I THINK LOOKING AT THE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AND GETTING
THE LOCAL CONTROL INVOLVES
REALLY HELPS -- IT'S SAD TO SEE
THIS HAPPEN BECAUSE AS YOU
STATED EARLIER.
YOU KNOW WE WE CAN JUST LOOK.
A FOOT YOU BLOCKS FROM HERE AND
SEE WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO WITHIN
A MATTER OF YEARS.
WITH THE STADIUM AND EVERYTHING
ELSE AND YET WE SEE THIS WHEN IT
COMES TO HOUSING AND WE SEE THIS
WHEN IT COMES THE INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND YET WE SEE THE HOUSING AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN OUR STATE
COMPLETELY FALLING APART
[inaudible]
AND THE SAME CRITICS THAT WANT
TO BRING EVERYBODY.
INTO CALIFORNIA AND MAKE
CALIFORNIA SANCTUARY AND
EVERYTHING ELSE ARE THE SAME
PEOPLE BLOCKING THE ABILITY.
TO REBUILD OUR INFRASTRUCTURE
AND HAVE CALIFORNIA.
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY TO BE.
THE SHINY.
CITY ON THE HILL.
THAT COULD BE AND THAT IT
DESERVES TO BE -- DELIC FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU ON THIS NEXT
YEAR.
PLEASE USE ME AS AN ALLY -- I
WANT TO SEE SOMETHING GET DONE I
WANT TO SEE CALIFORNIA BE WHAT
CALIFORNIA COULD BE.
CAN I WANT TO SHARE
INFRASTRUCTURE COME BACK.
IN THIS BLOCKING OF ANYTHING TO
DO TO SPEED UP THE PROCESS.
THIS IS SICKENING TO ME BECAUSE
I HAVE A DISADVANTAGE AREA I
HAVE POOR COMMUNITIES SOME OF
THE POOREST IN THE ENTIRE STATE.
SOME WHO STILL DON'T EVEN HAVE
WATER.
AND YET.
ANYTHING WE DO.
UNDER THIS DOWN HERE IN
SACRAMENTO TO TRY TO MOVE THE
BALL TO SPEED THINGS UP GETS
BLOCKED.
OVER ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
I WANT TO SEE JUSTICE FOR OUR
PEOPLE.
WHO ARE STOP WITHOUT
[inaudible] FOR CALIFORNIANS.
THAT DON'T HAVE WATER WHO DON'T
HAVE HOMES WHO DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT ARE NECESSARY FOR
THEM.
AND IT'S REALLY EASY FOR PEOPLE
SAID THEIR IVORY TOWERS.
THE LECTURE US ABOUT
ENVIRONMENTAL CONCERNS AND
COMMUNITIES THAT THEY DON'T LIVE
IN.
SO THANK YOU AND I LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU.
THANKS VERY MUCH.
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO COMMENT.
SO I WANT -- SAY THAT I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
PASSION I SOMEONE WHO DOES
REPRESENT A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES
OWNS IN HER DISTRICT CERTAINLY
HAVE SEEN THEM UP CLOSE -- AND
FEEL THAT I UNDERSTAND WHAT
HAPPENS WITHIN THEM AS WELL AS
THE IMPACT OF OF THE LOT THE
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
LACK OF GOOD JOBS IN THOSE.
AREAS -- AND I'M ALSO IN A
DISTRICT THAT'S VERY HEAVILY
IMPACTED BY. TO RECALL THE
SEQUEL WARS ARE USING SEQUEL AS
A TOOL ARE REPRESENTING EAST
HOLLYWOOD WHICH IS BOTH AN
OPPORTUNITIES OWN AT AN AREA
THAT AS BEEN SUBJECT TO CIVIL
LAWSUITS OVER.
NOT ONLY ITS OWN NEIGHBORHOOD
PLAN BUT OVER A MULTITUDE OF
PROJECTS -- GOING FROM MARKET
RATE HOUSING -- TO COMMERCIAL
PROJECTS SO I UNDERSTAND WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND I
UNDERSTAND THE RATIONALE BEHIND
IT AND I THINK THAT EVERYBODY UP
HERE.
HAS SYMPATHY WITH TRYING TO
BUILD AFFORDABLE HOUSING TRYING
TO ATTRACT JOBS.
I DON'T THINK THAT IT'S THE CASE
OF THE LEGISLATURE IS DONE
NOTHING WHEN IT COMES TO HOUSING
A WERE ALL ABOUT TO VOTE ON IT
WE ALL VOTED LAST WEEK ON
MILLION HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS GOING TO AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND WE'VE SEEN A MULTITUDE OF
HOUSING BILLS I MYSELF HAVE
SEVERAL HOUSING BILLS.
WE'VE HAD A OF PROBABLY AS MANY
HOUSING BILLS IS ALMOST ANY
OTHER TOPIC I'M IN THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS -- BUT THE REASON THAT I
ASK FOR THIS BILL TO ME MADE A
TO YOUR BILLS BECAUSE I THINK
THAT THERE ARE A LOT OF
ASSUMPTIONS THAT GO INTO THE
BILL THAT I'M NOT SURE WE'RE
READY.
TO REALLY MAKE SO THOSE SORT OF
IN TRYING TO INTO LAW ONE IS
THAT ITS SEQUEL THAT'S BLOCKING
THESE KINDS OF PROJECTS IN
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS -- IN OUR
LOWER INCOME CENSUS TRACKS THAT
ANYTIME A PROJECTS -- PROPOSE
WHETHER IT'S A CLEAN JOBS
PROJECT OR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
THAT IT'S IMMEDIATELY THE
SUBJECT OF A SEQUEL LAWSUIT.
IS CERTAINLY NOT SOMETHING THAT
I'VE SEEN OR SOMETHING THAT I
THINK THE DATA SHOWS THAT THAT'S
THE CASE IN THE MAJORITY OF
PROJECTS.
ALSO A KIND OF DOUBLING DOWN ON
THE TAX INCENTIVES FOR THE
OPPORTUNITIES OWNS AND THINKING
THAT THIS WILL HELP US COMPETE
AGAINST OTHER STATES I'M ALSO
NOT SURE THAT THAT'S REALLY THE
CASE GIVEN THAT OTHER STATES.
HAVE FOR INSTANCE WE KERN FIRE
MENTAL LAWS THEY HAVE CHEAPER
LAND THEY HAVE ALL KINDS OF
THINGS THAT ARE ALSO WORKING
AGAINST CALIFORNIA IN SOME CASES
WHEN IT COMES TO THOSE
INVESTMENTS.
NOT TO MENTION A CHEAPER COST OF
LIVING FOR EMPLOYEES OF
COMPANIES THERE'S A WHOLE SLATE
OF THINGS THAT FIGURE INTO A
COMPANIES DECISION OF WHETHER
GOING TO MOVE TO TEXAS.
I MOVED TO CALIFORNIA AND UNTIL
WE'VE HEARD DIRECTLY FROM SOME
OF THOSE BUSINESSES FOR INSTANCE
AT THAT.
A TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAY
SEQUEL -- STREAMLINING IS GOING
TO REALLY HELP THAT SCALE I
THINK IT'S HARD TO REALLY MAKE
THAT ARGUMENT THAT IT'S GOING TO
MAKE A DIFFERENCE -- THE BILL IS
NOT JUST ABOUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IT'S ALSO ABOUT -- OTHER
TYPES OF BUSINESSES -- AND YOU
KNOW FROM WHAT I'VE SEEN FROM
SEQUEL LAWSUITS YEAH BUT TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS YOU KNOW
THAT MAYBE SOMETHING BUT A LOT
OF TIMES EVEN IF YOU HAVE THE
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY DAYS AND AS
SOMEONE MENTION.
SEQUEL ALREADY HAS PRIORITY IN A
LOT OF JURISDICTIONS IN LOS
ANGELES THERE ARE SEE FOR JUDGES
AND THAT'S ALL THE HERE IN THOSE
CASES DO CAN TEND TO BE HER
QUICKLY.
BUT WHEN WE HAD A PROJECT IN MY
DISTRICT THAT WAS HELD UP FOR
FOR FIVE YEARS AND OF IN ITS
BUILDING IT WASN'T BECAUSE OF
THE LACK OF STREAMLINING.
IT WAS BECAUSE THE CASE WAS
HEARD QUICKLY BUT THE JUDGE SAID
THAT THEY HAD BEEN IN CORRECTING
THE WAY THE APPROVALS HADN'T
GIVEN AN ISSUE TO STAY AND THIS
BILL WOULDN'T HELP IN THAT KIND
OF SITUATION.
SO THERE'S ALL KINDS OF BARRIERS
HAVING TO DO WITH SEEK WITH IT'S
NOT ABOUT THE STREAMLINING.
AND MY OFFER TO YOU WHICH STILL
STANCES LET'S.
LOOK AT SEEK WELL LET'S HAVE
HEARINGS AND LOOK AT THOSE
BARRIERS AND WHAT IS IT THAT'S
CAUSING.
THOSE KINDS OF HOLD UPS IS IT A
FAILURE TO GET GENERAL PLANS
UPDATED.
IS IT THAT JUDGES ARE STOPPING
PROJECTS ONE REALLY THEY COULD
PROCEED WHILE THEY CONTINUE TO
FIX THOSE DOCUMENTS.
AND YOU KNOW SEEK WELL AS YOU
KNOW SEQUEL IS A TOOL FOR
DECISION MAKERS IT'S NOT A
DOCUMENT THAT TELLS A DECISION
MAKER THAT THEY HAVE TO APPROVE
A PROJECT OR NOT APPROVE IT IT'S
JUST SUPPOSED TO GIVE
INFORMATION.
AND IT NEEDS TO BE AN ACCURATE
DOCUMENT.
SO THAT THE DECISION MAKERS CAN
MAKE THE DECISION ANSWER THAT
THE COMMUNITIES CAN WAY AND I
THINK WHAT YOU'VE HEARD.
IS SOME DISQUIET FROM SOME
COMMUNITY MEMBERS IN THESE AREAS.
THAT THEY FEEL THAT AS LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES THEY
SHOULDN'T BE GIVEN SORT OF LESS
TIME TO WEIGH IN OR DO YOU TO
HAVE THAT PROCESS THAT THEY WANT.
THE SAME AMOUNT OF PROCESS THAT
OTHER COMMUNITIES GET SO I THINK
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON HERE.
BUT I TOTALLY UNDERSTAND.
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO AND I
THINK NO ONE COULD ARGUE WITH
YOUR PASSION FOR BRINGING GOOD
JOBS AND MORE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
INTO THESE AREAS I THINK WE ALL
WANT TO DO THAT I?
I THINK THAT.
THIS AGREEMENT THAT YOU AND I
ARE HAVING IS WHETHER THIS IS
GOING TO REALLY ACCOMPLISH THAT
BUT I WOULD LOVE TO HEAR MORE
FROM THE DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY
ABOUT WHERE THOSE HANG UPS ARE.
WHEN THEY HAVE PROJECTS THAT ARE
PROPOSED AND OF SEEK WAS A
PROBLEM?
WHAT IS IT?
THAT IS CAUSING JUDGES. TO AGREE
WITH LITIGANTS IN SOME CASES AND
SAY THAT THE SECRET DOCUMENTS
WERE AN ADEQUATE OR THAT
SOMETHING KIND OF ONE SIDE WAYS
IN THE PROCESS -- OR IF IF IT'S
TAKING LONGER THAN TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY DAYS JUST TO GET INTO THE
COURT SYSTEM WHAT KIND OF
RESOURCES DO WE NEED TO GIVE OUR
COURT SYSTEM. TO HAVE CASES
DISPENSE WITH MORE QUICKLY
WITHOUT [inaudible]
RINGING SOME.
CASES TO THE FRONT OF THE LINE
OVER OTHERS -- YOU KNOW THAT'S
WHAT I THINK THAT WE NEED TO
REALLY HAVE THE DISCUSSION ABOUT --
SO WITH THAT YOU KNOW I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING THE
CONVERSATION WITH YOU YOU KNOW
I'VE ALSO WORKED ON SEAQUEST.
AND SOME OF MY LEGISLATION I
THINK THAT YOU AND I HAVE A LOT
OF THE SAME GOALS -- SO I
APPRECIATE YOU KNOW YOU'RE
COMING INVENTING.
ARE YOU'RE ALWAYS WELCOME TO
VENT IN FRONT OF THE COMMITTEE --
I THINK THAT'S HOW WE GET
PROGRESS AND YOU KNOW WE DO HAVE
THAT PUBLIC AIRING OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND I I APPRECIATE IT -- THE
KINDS OF THINGS THAT YOU'VE
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT WE OBVIOUSLY
DISAGREE ON ON ON THE PARAMETERS
OF OF KIND OF WHAT'S GOING ON
BUT BUT I DID COMMIT.
TO HAVING FURTHER DISCUSSIONS --
FRANKLY -- THE CHALLENGE THAT I
SEE IS THAT -- AS YOU'LL SEE
THIS IS SB TWENTY FIVE I FILED
IT IN DECEMBER IT'S BEEN IN
PRINT SINCE DECEMBER.
AND YET I JUST GOT.
PROPOSED LANGUAGE.
PROBABLY WITHIN THE LAST WEEK I
DON'T REMEMBER WITH THE DATE OF
THE LETTER IS -- AND AND PART OF
THE CHALLENGE IS THAT WHAT I'VE
HEARD IS FROM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITY IS WE HAVE A
PHILOSOPHICAL DISAGREEMENT AND
FRANKLY I CAN'T DEAL WITH
PHILOSOPHICAL DISAGREEMENTS IN A
BILL.
I'M EITHER EITHER WE'RE GOING TO
TRY TO RESOLVE WHAT IS A LONG
LASTING PROBLEM IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND DISAGREE ON ON THE THE WAY
TO GET THERE OR OR WE SIT DOWN
AND WE WE WORK ON LANGUAGE IT
ACTUALLY GET TO US THERE.
IS TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAYS
A MAGIC NUMBER NO BUT IT'S WHERE
YOU START AND THEN YOU NEGOTIATE
AND SO I I'VE ALWAYS I'M GONNA
GO SHEET OR THAT'S WHAT I DO AND
SO I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH YOU TO SEE.
IF IT'S THE WRONG APPROACH THIS
FIGURE OUT WITH THE RIGHT
APPROACHES BUT I CAN'T IT'S
IMPOSSIBLE IN LEGISLATION TO
DEAL WITH PHILOSOPHICAL
DIFFERENCES YOU CAN'T GET THERE
FROM THERE AND SO.
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
YOU WE I'M I MAY DO THAT PROMISE --
OBVIOUSLY NOT HAPPY WITH.
THIS BE IS THIS BEING A TO YOUR
BILL BUT BUT I I DO BELIEVE THAT
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS CAN GET TO
THE BOTTOM OF SOME OF THIS.
AND IN THE END SOME OF THE DATA
IS GOING TO BE VERY DIFFICULT TO
TO GET BECAUSE THE THREAT OF
LITIGATION ENDS UP -- CHASING
OFF PEOPLE THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
MAKE INVESTMENTS IT'S THE
MEETINGS I'VE HELD THE ENTIRE
YEAR I'VE HEARD THAT MESSAGE
WILL GET THEM TO COME AND HAVE A
CONVERSATION WITH THAT WITH YOU
BUT IF YOU'RE LOOKING AT HOW
MANY CASES HAVE BEEN FILED AND
HOW LONG DID THEY TAKE.
AND WHAT WAS THE GRANT IF YOU'RE
YOU'RE NOT GOING TO GET THE DATA
THAT YOU NEED -- IT IT IT IT.
IT'S MUCH BIGGER THAN THAT ND
IT'S IT'S I I WANTED I'D I WANT
TO JUST SAY THAT.
THE IDEA THAT I WOULD WANT TO
TRAMPLE.
ON THE RIGHT OF THE MINORITY
COMMUNITY PEOPLE OF COLOR COLOR
I FIND REALLY OFFENSIVE THAT'S
NOT WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CREATING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THEM TO
PARTICIPATE. TO GO THROUGH THE
REGULAR PROCESSES THAT THAT ARE
SET UP AND THEN TO HAVE AN
EXPEDITED REVIEW SO THAT WE CAN
GET TO TO CONCLUSION.
AND HOPEFULLY HAVE SOME
CERTAINTY SO IN ANY CASE WE DID
AGREE WITH WE'RE GOING TO WORK
TOGETHER I HIKE BIKE COMMIT THAT
I WILL -- IN GOOD FAITH AND WILL
BRING ALL THE PARTIES TOGETHER
SO WE CAN HAVE A REAL HONEST
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT'S GOING
ON AND MAYBE WE CAN MAKE SOME
CHANGES THAT'LL THAT'LL.
THAT'LL SATISFY YOU THAT WE'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE TO RESOLVE OUR
DIFFERENCES SO I THINK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY BE HERE TODAY I
REALLY DO APPRECIATE THAT
OPPORTUNITY WELL THANK YOU
SENATOR AND WE MAKE IT WE WILL
KEEP WORKING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY I SEE SENATOR DODD WITH SP
ONE NINETY AND TWO FORTY SEVEN I
AM GOING TO HAVE TO PASS THE
GOBBLING GO VOTING
TRANSPORTATION BUT YOU'RE IN
GOOD HANDS WITH VICE CHAIR.
FOR THE WHOLE.
ONE NINETEEN WELL I CAN ALREADY.
MISTER MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY THANKING THE
CHAIR TO STAFF FOR THE GREAT
ANALYSIS AND I WILL BE TAKING
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS --
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION THE BILL
I RESPECTFULLY I TRIED VOTE I'VE
GOT -- TO WITH ME TODAY -- IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURES BOB
ROEMER SENIOR SENIOR ENGINEER IN
TECHNICAL DIRECTOR FROM CBS.
THANK YOU SENATOR FIRST WITNESS
IN TWO MINUTES.
THANK YOU ARE MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS ON BOB ROEMER SENIOR
ENGINEER WITH THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION SPONSORS OF
THE BILL OF THE OF BILLS
RESPONDING TO THE FIRE STORMS --
THIS ONE CAN BE CHARACTERIZED AS
THE EDUCATION IMPLEMENTATION
BILL IT'S IT'S ALSO -- VERY
CLOSELY COMPLEMENTARY -- TO THE
CHAIR WOMAN'S -- BILL AB.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN IT'S GOING TO
REQUIRE THE FARM MARSHALL TO
UPDATE -- THE BULLY PRADA CAM
BOOK -- CALIFORNIA FARMERS WILL
BE REQUIRED UPDATE THE GUIDANCE
DOCUMENTS FOR DEFENSIBLE SPACE --
AND WILL BE REQUIRED -- TO FOR
NEW HOME BUYERS TO RECEIVE --
THE EXECUTIVE SUMMARY BUILDERS
WILL BE REQUIRED TO HAVE THAT
OUT -- SO WITH THAT THAT
CONCLUDES MY TESTIMONY WAS HAVE
QUESTIONS THE VERY MUCH.
IT'S GOING TO BE HALF OF THE
CALVARY COACH UTILITY EMPLOYEES
WE'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN ALL THESE
FIERY SHE'S WE THINK THIS IS A
SMALL BUT IMPORTANT PIECE IN
READER JAVA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON YELEY GOVERNOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION
OF REALTORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI JULIE MOUNT ASKEY BALL AND
THE HALF OF THE CALIFORNIA FIRE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION THE FIRE
DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
ROD BREWER FOR SERVING
CALIFORNIA'S IN HERE IN SUPPORT.
NICK WE NEVER UNDERSTANDING OF
GAS AND ELECTRIC IN SUPPORT.
JOHN KENNEDY WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AT RALLY IN BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
AND SUPPORT.
YOUR SINGLE BAQIR THE CALIFORNIA
FORESTRY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VRY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE A NON BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE A QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEE ENOUGH OF THE COMMITTEE WHO
GOT A MOTION A SECOND ITEMS
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL -- I'M
SORRY SIR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE I
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I TO MAY SB ONE NINETY BY
SENATOR DODD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN FLORA FLORA I'D
CHAU.
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG.
YEAH.
GARCIA ISLA MON.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
BROUGHT TO TREAT STONE
[inaudible] THREE ZERO BELIEVE
THAT BILL ON CALL WAY FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK NEXT UP IS SB.
TWO FORTY SEVEN YES SIR -- MR
MEMBERS LET ME BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENT
SUGGESTED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AS WE ALL KNOW EXTREME WEATHER
IT'S INCREASE THE NUMBER OF
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES AND THE
LENGTH OF THE WILDFIRE SEASON.
ADEQUATE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
IS CRITICAL TO REDUCING THE RISK
OF TREES AND BRUSH -- CONTACTING
ELECTRICAL LINES OF EQUIPMENT.
PART OF CAL FIRES MISSION IS TO
PREVENT FIRES CAL PARTS FIRE
PREVENTION PROGRAM INCLUDES
WILDLAND PRE FIRE ENGINEERING
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT FIRE
PLANNING.
EDUCATION AND LAW ENFORCEMENT.
UNDER CURRENT LAW INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES MUST PROVIDE THE CPUC
WITH VEGETATION MAYOR FOR PLAN
AS PART OF THE I OWE YOU WHILE
FAR MITIGATION PLAN FURTHER
UNDER CURRENT LAW.
THE CPC MUST CONSULT WITH CAL
FIRE WHEN REVIEWING IT IN
APPROVING EACH WALL FIRE
MITIGATION PLAN.
SB TWO FORTY SEVEN WOULD SIMPLY
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA CAL FIRE
SKEWS ME TO AUDIT EACH
ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS.
DIGITECH DIGIT TATIAN THE
MANAGEMENT WORK TO ENSURE THAT
THE UTILITY HAS SATISFACTORILY.
CARRY THE VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
PLAN WORKS SET FORTH IN ITS
WHILE PART MITIGATION PLAN.
RECENTLY JUDGE ELSE OF OVERSEE
P. GENIES PROBATION IT SAID
BROOKE CASE SAID P. JEANNIE
HASN'T CUT THE RIGHT TREES.
IN MANAGING VEGETATIONS IN THE
NEAR ITS POWER LIGHTS IN
RESPONSE P. JEANNIE SAID MY
QUOTE THERE'S A LOT OF TREES OUT
THERE WE DON'T HAVE EYES ON ALL
OF THEM.
MISTER CHAIRMAN -- IN MEMBERS
I'D SUBMIT LET'S GIVE THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES THE EYES THEY
NEED TO ADEQUATELY BUT MANAGED
EDUCATION AND CUT THE RIGHT
TREATS I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
OPPOSITION RESPECT WE THAT'S FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
X. CENTER FIRST WITNESS TWO
MINUTES PLEASE.
MARK JOSEPH FOR THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA TILL THE EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL WILL REDUCE THE CHANCE
OF A FUTURE WILDFIRE BECAUSE
UTILITY FAILED TO TRIM THE TREE.
RIGHT NOW THE THE UTILITY
DECIDES WHAT TREE TRIMMING IS
NEEDED IT PERFORMS THE WORK AND
THAT IT OUGHT ITS ITS OWN WORK
pCONTRACTORS.
AFTER A FIRE CAL FIRE COMES
ALONG AN INVESTIGATION DECIDES
WHAT CAUSED THE FIRE AND
SOMETIMES THESE DECIDE THAT IT
THE FIRE WAS CAUSED BECAUSE
SOMEONE FAILED TO TRIM A TREE.
THAT'S NICE TO KNOW AFTER THE
FACT IT WOULD BE MUCH BETTER TO
KNOW WHAT BEFORE THE FACTS
BEFORE THE FIRE.
THIS BILL WOULD HAVE CAL FIRE
AUDIT THE UTILITIES WORK RIGHT
AWAY BEFORE ANY FIRE AND TELL
THE UTILITY IF IT'S MISSED
ANYTHING.
THEN UTILITY HAS A CHANCE TO FIX.
THE MISTAKE RIGHT AWAY.
THEN CAL FIRE REPORTS THE
RESULTS OF ITS AUDIT TO THE PC.
THIS A GREAT A REALLY POWERFUL
INCENTIVE THE UTILITY TO FIX
EVERY EVERY VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT PROBLEM THE
CALIFORNIA IDENTIFIES BECAUSE
THEY DON'T.
THERE'S A PAPER TRAIL THE
CALIFORNIA TOLD IN THOSE A TREE
THEY SUPPOSED TO TRIMMING THE
INTERNET.
WHEN I THINK THAT'S GONNA HAPPEN
WE THINK UTILITY WILL JUMP AND
EVERY PROBLEM THE CALIFORNIA
IDENTIFIES?
IN THE CALIFORNIA AUDITING THE
WORK BEFORE.
THE FIRE IS A MUCH BETTER SYSTEM
THAN SELF AUDITING.
THIS DOES NOT INCREASE ANY
EXPENSE FOR CALIFORNIA --
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE
INAPPROPRIATE BURST BY THE
UTILITY FOR THE WORK IT DOES IT
WOULD GREATLY IMPROVE THE
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT PROCESS
AND RESULT IN FEWER FIRES CAUSED
BY MISTAKES AND VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THAT.
THIS YEAR MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
GOT WET YOUR BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA'S DISSOCIATION
ELECTRICAL WORKERS -- WE
CERTAINLY SUPPORT THE FIRST PART
OF THE BILL THAT WAS JUST
OUTLINED BY MISTER JOSEPH THE
SECOND PART OF THE BILLS EQUALLY
IMPORTANT -- PGD IN JUST THE
LAST EIGHTEEN MONTHS HAS GONE
FROM.
A WORK FORCE WORKING FOR
CONTRACTORS DO VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT WITH ABOUT A THOUSAND
WORKERS TO CLOSE TO FOUR
THOUSAND WORKERS -- WE REPRESENT
ALL THESE MEMBERS IT'S A IT'S A
VERYTRANSITORY WORKFORCE IT'S A
IMMIGRANT WORK FORCE AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING IS.
WE'RE GETTING IN A SITUATION
WHERE THEIR SECOND AND THIRD AND
FOURTH TIER SUBCONTRACTORS.
IN THESE CONTRACTORS MANY OF
WHICH ARE COMING FROM OUT OF
STATE.
THEY SHOW UP TWENTY TRUCKS
UNKNOWN PLEASE.
AND THE NEXT DAY THEY SHOW UP
WITH TWO HUNDRED EMPLOYEES WHICH
IS FINE.
BUT THEY'RE NOT INVESTING IN ANY
TRAINING AND WHAT'S HAPPENING IS
THE NUMBER OF SERIOUS ACCIDENTS
AND DEATHS.
ARE ARE ARE OFF THE CHARTS. TWO
IS HAPPENING IS LOW LEVEL --
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT
TECHNICIANS -- ARE GOING OUT IN
THE FIELD AND GIVING CHAINSAWS
IN BEING ASKED TO DO WORK THAT
SHOULD REQUIRE.
A A A LINE CLEARANCE TREE
TRIMMER WHICH IS A HIGHER LEVEL
OF EMPLOYMENT AND HAS SOME
TRAINING.
JUST ABOUT A MONTH AND A HALF
AGO WE HAD AN EMPLOYEE THAT WAS
NOT TRAINED POULTRY OVER ON
THEMSELVES THINKING THEY COULD
OUT RUN THE TREE.
SO IN A TWO YEAR PERIOD WE HAD
SEVENTY FIVE SERIOUS ACCIDENTS.
WITH FIFTY FOUR HOSPITALIZATIONS
ELEVEN DEATHS WE THINK THAT THE
THE NUMBER OF OF ACCIDENTS AND
DEATHS JUST OVER THE LAST
SIXTEEN MONTHS FAR EXCEED THAT.
WITH THIS BILL DOES IS IT
DIRECTS THE P. YOU SEE WORKING
AT THE UTILITIES TO DEVELOP A
CERTIFICATION PROGRAM. TO
REQUIRE THAT THESE WORKERS BE
TRAINED TO A CERTAIN
CERTIFICATION -- CIVIL SO THAT
WE CAN AVOID THESE UNFORTUNATE
ACCIDENTS AND DEATHS THE
UTILITIES ARE ON BOARD WITH ITS
WEIRD VIRGIN AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
YES -- MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE I
B. W. LOCAL TWELVE FORTY FOUNDER
STERN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY IS THERE ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY SING ON WILL COME BACK TO
THE DíAS.
WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD -- I
THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
SAFETY CERTIFICATION I WOULD --
I ALSO HOPE THAT THIS ENCOURAGES
THE UTILITIES TO YOU TO DEVELOP
IN STATE LABOR -- IS SUPPOSED TO
BRING PEOPLE IN FROM OUT OF
STATE -- AND I ALSO HOPE THAT
YOU INCREASE THE TRAINING ABOUT
JUST GOOD HORTICULTURE I KNOW
THAT A LOT OF THIS IS UNDER AN
ARBORIST SUPERVISION BUT WE GET
A LOT OF COMPLAINTS ABOUT TREES
THAT HAVE BEEN SUB.
THE TRIMMING SUBCONTRACTED OUT
FROM UTILITIES AND JUST THE
CONTRACTORS DOING A REALLY
ABYSMAL JOB -- IN TRIMMING AND
CREATING DANGEROUS SITUATIONS OF
TREES THAT ARE OFF BALANCE IT
OPEN TOPPED OFF -- MY OFFICE
PROBABLY GETS MORE COMPLAINTS.
ABOUT THAT RIGHT NOW THAT JUST
ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE SO I HOPE
THAT YOU TAKE THAT SERIOUSLY.
THAT YOU KNOW -- THERE ARE.
WAYS TO TRIM THAT MAINTAIN
SAFETY BUT ALSO KEEPS THE PLANTS --
INTEGRITY INTACT AND DOESN'T
DAMAGE FROM IN THE SAME WAY SO I
HOPE THAT YOU'LL.
HERE THAT THAT THAT UTILITIES
HERE THAT AS WELL -- WITHOUT TO
WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY WE'VE A MOTION AND A SECOND
DO YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
LAST PRIVATE.
OKAY WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM ELEVEN SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
BY SENATOR DODD THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
PHONE.
FONG AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LOW MOAN.
AT THIS.
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
BROUGHT TO G. [inaudible]
STONE. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
BELIEVE THE BILL I THINK YOU.
THIRTY TWO ONE NINE A MISTER
GLORIA.
MR OUT MISTER ALLEN THERE YOU
ARE.
SORRY I DIDN'T TO EUROPE NEXT IF
YOU ARE READY [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MENTAL
PRESIDENT AND YOU'RE HERE WITH
US AND HE FIFTY FOUR YES SB --
FIFTY FOUR I WANT TO THINK THAT
MY CO AUTHORS ON THIS MEASURING
AND INCLUDING THE CHAIR.
I AM VERY HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENT TO THE ANALYSIS -- IN
A MEMBERS IT'S BEEN SO CLEAR I
THINK TO ALL OF US THAT WE HAVE
A PLASTICS POLLUTION CRISIS ON
OUR HANDS.
WE SEE THE PICTURES OF OCEAN
POLLUTION AND OF DEAD MARINE
LIFE FOR THE STOMACH FULL OF
PLASTIC WASHING ON OUR SHORES --
BUT SO THAT THAT'S THAT'S ONE
WHOLE ISSUE BUT I I WILL SAY
THAT IN ADDITION AND OF OF ALSO
GRAVE IMPORTANCE IS THE EXTENT
TO WHICH OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
AND ARE RECYCLERS ARE ARE
FEELING THE PROBLEM VERY ACUTELY.
AND I THINK MOST MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE KNOW ABOUT CHINA'S
NATIONAL SORT POLICY THE
DECISION THAT WAS THEN FOLLOWED
BY OTHER NATION ASIAN NATIONS.
TO NO LONGER ACCEPT A RECYCLING.
AND THIS IS BECAUSE THE BOTTOM
TO FALL OUT OF OUR RECYCLING
MARKETS AND IT'S COSTING CITIES
AND COUNTIES MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
CHINA.
I HAD BEEN ACCEPTING ABOUT 40%
OF OUR RECYCLED MATERIAL FROM
UNITED STATES IN CALIFORNIA SHE
WAS A 56%. 76% OF ALL OF OUR
RECYCLED MATERIAL WAS GOING OFF
TO CHINA -- AND IN FACT IF YOU
LOOK AT PLASTICS NUMBERS --
THREE THREE SEVEN ME THOSE KINDS
OF PLASTICS WERE FETCHING ABOUT
TWENTY DOLLARS PER TIME.
IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN NOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE.
PAYING ARE PAYING.
ROUGHLY TEN DOLLARS A TIME TO
DISPOSE OF THREE THREE SEVEN
PLASTICS -- MORE MORE OFTEN THAT
MEANS THE MATERIALS JUST SIMPLY
BEING LANDFILLS BECAUSE IT
DOESN'T.
I PAY FOR ITSELF SO WE ARE ALL
DILIGENTLY SORTING OUR
RECYCLABLES INTO BLUE BINS --
BUT UNFORTUNATELY NOW THE
MATERIAL IS LESS LIKELY TO BE
PROCESS RECYCLING TODAY THAN IT
WAS SEVERAL YEARS AGO.
AND ON TOP OF THE DISPOSAL COSTS
EVERY YEAR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
SPENDING ABOUT HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS.
A YEAR IN ONGOING EFFORTS JUST
TO CLEAN UP AND PREVENT LITTER
IN STREETS AND STORM DRAINS.
PARKS AND WATERWAYS SO IT'S
BECOMING A WHOLE NEW TAX.
THAT IS MONEY THAT COULD BE
GOING TO LAW ENFORCEMENT -- TO
IMAGE SERVICES FOR SENIORS GIVEN
BACK TO TAXPAYERS HELP THE
SCHOOLS WHATEVER.
WHATEVER MAY BE.
NOT SO.
YOU KNOW WE'RE NOW AT AT AT AND
AND A CRISIS POINT -- IN AND
WHAT WE GOT TO TAKE BOLD ACTION
TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS THIS BILL
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT STEP -- IN
THAT DIRECTION THIS COMMITTEE
HAS PASSED THE COMPANION
LEGISLATION IN THE PAST IT WAS
AB -- TEN EIGHTY IT'S GONNA TAKE
A SUITE OF TOOLS SUCH AS MINIMUM
CYCLE CONTENT STANDARDS EXTENDED
PRODUCER RESPONSIBILITY TO
BOLSTER.
THE RECYCLING MARKETS IN OUR
STATE MAY COLLECTION RECYCLED
RECYCLING PROFITABLE AGAIN --
WHILE ENSURING MANUFACTURERS
HAVE A STEADY CLEAN SUPPLY OF
MATERIAL -- THERE'S A LONG
OFFRAMP ASSOCIATED -- TILL
TWENTY THIRTY BEFORE IT'S FULLY
IMPLEMENTED IN THAT WILL
CERTAINLY ALLOW FOR A LOT OF
LEAD TIME TO ALLOW MANUFACTURES
EITHER SWITCH.
TO MORE SUSTAINABLE MATERIALS OR
BY USING WERE RECYCLED CONTENT
THEIR PACKAGING ENSURE THAT THE
MATERIAL THAT THEY WANT TO USE.
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
BILL -- I KNOW THAT EVEN WHILE
WE'VE -- SIGNIFICANTLY NARROWED
THE SCOPE OF THE BILL TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE
OPPOSITION -- WE STILL HAVE SOME
WORK TO DO WE'VE BEEN HAVING A
SERIES OF VERY PRODUCTIVE
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS WE PLAN TO
CONTINUE OVER THE BREAK I WAS AT
THE FIRST.
ONE IN MY OFFICE JUST LAST WEEK
AND AND AND WE'RE GONNA BE WE'RE
BREAKING UP VARIOUS ASPECTS OF
THE BILL TO FOCUS ON ON ON
DIFFERENT AREAS OF IT TO THE WE
CAN MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE HEARING
REALLY ROBUSTLY FROM.
FROM -- FROM THE OPPOSITION FROM
INDUSTRY FROM AND IF FROM
ADVOCACY GROUPS ALSO FROM OUR
FOLKS WHO WORK ON WASTE
MANAGEMENT OUR CITIES -- BUT
MEMBERS ANCHORED YOU GET ON THE
PHONE TALK TO ONE OF YOUR LOCAL
CITY MANAGERS WHEN YOUR LOCAL
MAYORS.
JUST TO TALK ABOUT THE
CHALLENGES THAT ARE LOCAL CITIES
ARE FACING WEBER NOW WITH REGARD
TO THIS WASTE MANAGEMENT CRISIS
THIS BILL IS GOING.
TO HELP THEM TREMENDOUSLY IS WHY
WE HAVE SUCH STRONG SUPPORT FROM
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
I AM AND I'VE GOT.
FOLKS FROM FROM BOTH THOSE
ACTORS WHO ARE HERE TO TESTIFY
ON BEHALF OF THE BILL.
OKAY WITH THIS PLACE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
THEIR COFFEE ON BEHALF LEAGUE
CALIFORNIA CITIES -- I DO
WONDERS TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
LAID OUT BY SENDER ALAN GIVE YOU
JUST A FEW EXAMPLES OF SOME OF
THE CITIES THAT ARE -- AND WHAT
THEY'RE FACING SO FOR EXAMPLE IN
THE CITY OF FULSOME -- THE
CITY'S PRE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN WHICH IS PRE -- CHINA
NATIONAL SORTS IMPLEMENTATION
THEIR AVERAGE ANNUAL REVENUE
FROM REPRESENTS RECYCLING WAS
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND SIXTY
FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS NOW
THEY'RE EXPECTING TO PAY EXCUSE
ME PAY APPROXIMATE THREE TO
EIGHTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR.
AND JUST FOR CONTEXT EARNS TIRE
SOLID WASTE BUDGET IN FISCAL
YEAR SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN WAS JUST
ONE POINT TWO FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS -- ANOTHER EXAMPLE WOULD
BE FROM CULVER CITY IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY -- BEFORE CHINA
IMPLEMENTED THE NATIONAL SORT
POLICY CULVER CITY WAS NETTING
AROUND FOURTEEN EIGHTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR FROM ITS
RECYCLING PROGRAM.
AND NOW THAT REVENUE HAS ALL BUT
DISAPPEARED.
WITHOUT THESE MARKETS THESE
RECYCLED MATERIALS ARE NOW
PILING UP WITH NO PLACE TO GO.
SB FIFTY FOUR WILL HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS MANAGE THE AMOUNT OF
WASTE GENERATED FOR SEVERAL
REASONS.
THE REQUIRED CORPORATE ENTITIES
TO ACHIEVE A 75% REDUCTION OF
WASTE GENERATED FROM SINGLE USE
PACKAGING PRIORITY ST USE
PLASTIC PRODUCTS BY.
TWENTY THIRTY AND WILL REQUIRE
THAT THESE PRODUCTS BE RECYCLE
OR COMPOSTABLE BY THAT TIME AS
WELL.
MY SOURCE REDUCING THE AMOUNT OF
WASTE GENERATED ON THE FRONT END
WILL BETTER HELP CITIES MANAGE
THE VOLUME AND TYPES OF
MATERIALS DISPOSED OF ON THE
BACK AND CITIES HAVE DEDICATED
SIGNIFICANT TIME AND RESOURCES
TO DEVELOP.
AND IMPLEMENT THE RECYCLING
PROGRAMS I WANT TO ENSURE THAT
CITY RECYCLING PROGRAMS CONTINUE
TO BE SUCCESSFUL.
SB FIFTY FOUR WILL HELP CITY
STRENGTH IN THE RECYCLING
PROGRAMS THROUGH DEVELOPING
MARKETS FOR CYCLE MATERIALS IN
CALIFORNIA AND CREATING MORE
HIGH QUALITY RECYCLED MATERIALS
WITH LESS CONTAMINATION.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS HAVE LONG BEEN
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENSURING THAT
CALIFORNIA CHIEF IT'S RECYCLING
WASTE MANAGEMENT GOALS.
THIS BILL WOULD HELP REDUCE
WASTE AT ITS SOURCE BEFORE IT
GETS TO LOCAL LANDFILLS AND
RECYCLING CENTERS OR WORSE OUR
BEACHES AND OTHER BEAUTIFUL
NATURAL ENVIRONMENTS.
SB FIFTY FOUR WILL HELP LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS RECYCLE MORE
MATERIALS FOR LESS AWAY IN
LANDFILLS AND ADVANCED TOWARDS
BEING STATEWIDE SOLD WASTE
RECYCLING GOALS WITHOUT I HEARD
YOUR SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU BUT THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- MY NAME'S
ERIC PASSION WITH RECOLOGY A
1100% EMPLOYEE OWNED RESOURCE
RECOVERY COMPANY WE MANAGE
RECYCLING COMPOSTING AND SOLID
WASTE COLLECTION PROCESSING AND
DISPOSAL SERVICES IN OVER A
HUNDRED URBAN SUBURBAN AND RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN CALIFORNIA.
WE OPERATE IN IN STATE NETWORK
OF A MATERIAL RECOVERY
FACILITIES ARE MURPHY AND FOR
COMPOST SITES.
PROJECTED RECOLOGY IS CAPTURED
PLASTIC PACKAGING MATERIALS
THROUGH A RECYCLING PROGRAMS AND
STATE MARKET MUCH OF THAT
MATERIAL FREE USE PRINCIPALLY
THROUGHOUT SOUTHEAST ASIA.
AND FOR MANY RIGID PLASTIC
CONTAINERS WERE STILL SUCCESSFUL
IN FINDING MARKETS BOTH DOMESTIC
AND GLOBAL. FOR THESE MATERIALS
TO BE REAR MANUFACTURED INTO NEW
PRODUCTS.
HOWEVER INTERNATIONAL POLICY
REFORMS MOST NOTABLY CHINA'S
NATIONAL SORT PROGRAM WHICH SET
STRINGENT QUALITY STANDARDS FOR
FIBER COMMODITIES AND OUTRIGHT
BAN MAKES PLASTIC IMPORTS HAVE
CLOSED NEARLY ALL IN MARKETS FOR
MOST OF THE FILM PLASTIC SINGLE
USE PACKAGING PRODUCTS.
IN RESPONSE TO THESE REFORMS ARE
COMPANY INVESTED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN OUR SAN FRANCISCO
MURPH WITH FOUR STAY THE OUR
OPTICAL SORTERS NEW COMPARES THE
BEST IN CLASS FILM PLASTIC
RECOVERY SYSTEM THAT CAN PRODUCE
BILLS THAT MEET THE HIGHEST.
MARKET STANDARDS.
WE CAN MAKE A FILM PLASTIC BELL
AT LESS THAN 2% CONTAMINATION
BUT WE CAN'T FIND A HOME FOR IT
AND IT'S NOT FOR LACK OF TRYING.
WE HAVE FOLLOWED THE WORK OF
INNOVATIVE COMPANIES THAT HAVE
ATTEMPTED TO REVERSE EGINEER%
THE PLASTICS MANUFACTURING.
PROCESS AND RECLAIM THE
PETROLEUM PRODUCTS AT WHICH ME
THESE MATERIALS HAVE BEEN
CREATED FROM UNFORTUNATELY NONE
OF THESE EFFORTS A PROVEN
SCALABLE.
WE EVEN TRY TO UNLOCK THE
SECRETS OURSELVES FOR FIVE YEARS
REAR RECOLOGY EMPLOYED A
CHEMICAL ENGINEER WITH TWENTY
FIVE YEARS OF PLASTIC
MANUFACTURING EXPERIENCE.
IS GIVEN THE MISSION TO FIND
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO WITH A
SINGLE USE PLASTIC WASTE HIS
WORK NET MEDI NO PRACTICAL
RESULTS.
WE'VE MET WITH MANUFACTURERS
MANY OF WHOM ARE REPRESENTED IN
THIS ROOM TODAY AND ASK THEM TO
HELP US LOCATE A PROCESSING
PLANT WHERE WE CAN TAKE THESE
CLEAN BILLS OF SINGLE USE
PLASTIC MATERIAL AND TURN THEM
INTO SOMETHING NEW.
NO SE WAS IDENTIFIED.
SIMPLE FACT IS THERE'S JUST TOO
MUCH PLASTIC INTO MANY DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PLASTICS THAT ARE BEING
PRODUCED A FROM A SINGLE USE
STANDPOINT.
THERE IS A FEW IF ANY VIABLE AND
MARKETS FOR THE MATERIAL.
WHICH MAKES CLOSING THIS LOOP
NEARLY UNATTAINABLE SO ON BEHALF
FOR ECOLOGY WE SUPPORT SB FIFTY
FOUR WHICH HAS A PROMISE TO HELP
DRIVE THE INDUSTRY TOWARDS.
THE NEED TO CHANGE BY REQUIRING
PLASTIC IN SINGLE USE MATERIAL
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO BE
RECYCLE OR COMPOST WILL BY.
TWENTY THIRTY BECAUSE HE'S
EMPLOYEE OWNERS ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED BY THE EFFECTS AND
PROLIFIC PROLIFERATION OF SINGLE
USE PLASTIC WASTING WERE
COMMITTING HELPING CALIFORNIA
BECOME A LEADER ON THIS FRONT.
WE USE -- RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU NOW WE'RE FINISHED
HEARING TESTIMONY SO ANYBODY WHO
WISHES TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT
JUST NAME AND THE ORGANIZATION
YOU'RE REPRESENTING THANK YOU.
CAPTION A CLASS OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE A STRONG SUPPORT.
JUST MILAN FOR THE LOCAL
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH DIRECTORS
IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GENEVIEVE AVEDON ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION ALSO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SO ELEVEN SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY INSTRUCTS PART.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THREE SUBMITS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
CARE TO SO ON BEHALF OF HEAL THE
BAY IN SUPPORT.
CHECK HELD REPUBLIC SERVICES IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THAT RIGHT THERE IN READING
ASSOCIATES REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PROFESSIONAL SCIENTISTS IN
SUPPORT -- ROUTE THREE SAYS WELL
BREAKER AND BARBER GARDNER
ANTENA GAL YOUR FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN STRONG SUPPORT.
STAY BAKER WITH THEIR
NECESSITIES FOR THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM IN SUPPORT.
OR FRONT TEND TO HAVE A
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL NORTHERN DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
PRESS A CLOSE HERE WE HAVE THE
CITY OF SANTA MONICA CITY OF LOS
ANGELES THE OF BEVERLY HILLS
STOP WASTE CALIFORNIA PRODUCT
STEWARDSHIP COUNCIL AND NATIONAL
STRIPS OF ACTION COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
BLAKE JOHNSON HIM STATIONS HERE
ON BEHALF TEACHERS IF YOU WANNA
HEAR IN SHOCK SUPPORT.
ALISON BROWN ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION AND THREE
FIFTY RIVERSIDE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
DAN PORTER ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
ALLEY SO BEULAH WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN SANTA CRUZ COUNTY
IN SUPPORT.
BRIANNA WATKINS WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
WE GET A CROWDED WITH THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT ALSO
REGISTERED SUPPORT FOR US.
TO PRINT AND ALSO ZERO OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT ALSO READ.
SUPPORT FOR AUDUBON SOCIETY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LOCAL HANDS WITH COPPER STUDENTS
AND SUPPORT.
JAKE ACOSTA FROM UCSB IN SUPPORT.
KELLY NEXT ON BEHALF OF OCEAN
CONSERVANCY IN FRONT OF THE LA
RIVER AND SUPPORT.
ADRIAN SASSER WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
DOES HE BERNIE -- WITH OVER MY
CALIFORNIANS.
FOR CLICK CALLAHAN WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
COMMUNIQUES THAT THE AMERICANS A
SALEABLE BUSINESS COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
AND I THINK IN THOUSAND BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
I'M OF OUR SMART TO THE
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA IN SANTA
BARBARA AND SUPPORT.
HE WENT CHEN WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
MONTANA STRAINS ISTER WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIANS SANTA
BARBARA IN SUPPORT.
TED BASCOMB FROM SANTA BARBARA
STRONG SUPPORT.
SOLOMON BEERS ARE L. ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA STRONG SUPPORT.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT.
JOSH TO EIGHTY ERIC WITH
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIANS STRONG
SUPPORT.
JACK **** FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
VALERIE NEW IN WITH ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN BERKELEY IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
CLASS BAKI BIRTH IN BERMAN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
AUSTIN SHARON -- UCSB STUDENTS
STRONG SUPPORT.
MICHELLE **** ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIAN CALL FOR STUDENTS IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
CAROL WE'D SUSTAINABLE RUSS MORE
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC WE
ACTUALLY HAVE A SUPPORT OF
AMENDED POSITION WE NEED TO SEE
A COUPLE TWEAKS TO FORTY TWO OH
FOUR TO EIGHTY THREE APPRECIATE
WORKING WITH YOUR STAFF TO
IDENTIFY THAT.
AND REDUCE COSTS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THAT ARE BEARING THE
BURDEN OF SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE THANK YOU.
CAITLYN CLEVELAND BEHALF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEPER
ALLIANCE IN SUPPORT.
KATIE NAP -- DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN -- WIKI CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
TEST BUT NOW ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA LOS ANGELES IN
SUPPORT.
G. ON THE CITY TODAY FOR THE
CITY OF ALAMEDA AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
EMILY RASH EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CAL PARK IN SUPPORT
MAKE COLLINS INTERNET CULPRIT IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
OPERATING A C. WITH RIPPING
WASTE IN SUPPORT.
EXCUSE ME MERRY AND FRODO WITH
THREE FIFTY BAY AREA BERKELEY
HOP IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
THE FACT IS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TOUCH
HIM JUST LIKE WITH THE AMERICAN
CHEMISTRY COUNCIL -- WE ARE A
SAY -- MY INDUSTRY IN MY
ORGANIZATION MEMBER COMPANIES
HAVE ESTABLISHED.
A SOME VERY AMBITIOUS RECYCLING
GOALS FOR PLASTIC PACKAGING VERY
SIMILAR-- TO THE TWENTY THIRTY
OBJECTIVE OUTLINED IN AND SENATE
BILL FIFTY FOUR SO I DON'T THINK
THIS IS IT AN ISSUE OF WHETHER
OR NOT -- WE ARE IN ALIGNMENT
WITH WHAT THE OVERALL OBJECTIVE
IS OF A CENTER ALLEN'S BILL BUT
WE DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
SOME OF THE CURRENT PROVISIONS
THE BILL THAT WE BELIEVE.
I NEED TO BE WORKED ON AS WE
HAVE THESE CONVERSATIONS DURING
THE THE SUMMER BREAK A COUPLE
THOSE I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT ONE IS
THE BILLS.
EXTREME AND ARGUE DELEGATION OF
AUTHORITY THE COW OR CYCLE TO
DEVELOP IMPLEMENTING REGULATIONS
WITHOUT ANY SORT OF OVERSIGHT BY
THE LEGISLATURE OR A OR ANY
GUIDELINES THE WAY THAT WE READ
THE BILL NOW -- CAL RECYCLE IS
FREE TO DEVELOP ANY SORT OF
REGULATION -- TO ACHIEVE THE
OVERALL OBJECTIVE -- THAT.
WOULD CUT COULD SUBSTANTIALLY
HAVE SOME SIGNIFICANT IMPACTS ON
THE CONSUMER PRODUCTS INDUSTRY.
THE SECOND PROVISION I WANT TO
HIGHLIGHT IS THIS -- A CONDITION
OF SALE LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
RIGHT NOW THERE'S SOME IN ARM
RECYCLING -- PERCENTAGES THAT
MUST BE MET -- OTHERWISE YOUR
PACKAGE IS PROHIBITED FROM BEING
SOLD IN THE STATE -- I PROVIDED
EXAMPLE OF IS THE FIRST FIRST --
HURDLE IS A 20% RATE BY TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR IF OF A PACKAGE
REACHES 19% BY TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR THERE IS NO FLEXIBILITY IN
OUR VIEW AND HOW THIS WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED WE THINK THERE OUGHT
TO BE SOME SORT OF FLEXIBILITY
ACCOUNT RECYCLE -- AROUND THESE
INTERIM RATES -- TO ALLOW FOR
MARKET CONDITIONS MARKET
REALITIES INFRASTRUCTURE
REQUIREMENTS BUT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE'RE GONNA
BE TALKING ABOUT WE HAVE PUT.
TOGETHER A SET OF SUBSTANTIVE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE PROVIDE TO
CENTER AROUND AS WELL AS SELLING
ADVOCATES ALSO STAFF. TO
CONSIDER DURING -- THE INTERN
DISCUSSIONS THAT US AROUND
REFERENCE EARLIER -- THESE
PROVIDE SOME DIRECTION A COW OR
CYCLE OF PROVIDE WHAT WE BELIEVE
TO BE A BASELINE OF INFORMATION
TO HELP INFORM WHAT WOULD BE
SOME REALISTIC -- RECYCLING
GOALS -- TO TO TO ACHIEVE DURING
THIS INTERIM PERIOD BEFORE --
THE TWENTY THIRTY MANDATE.
WE'VE ALSO ESTABLISHED A WHAT WE
BELIEVE TO BE A FAIRLY
PROGRESSIVE A PROVISION THAT
WOULD FORCE CERTAIN PACKAGING
PRODUCERS -- IT WOULD IN THE A
CC MEMBERSHIP AN INDUSTRY
SPONSORED -- ADVANCE RECYCLING
FEE TO HELP FUND SOME OF THE
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WE BELIEVE -- COULD BE NECESSARY
NOT FOR JUST OF CYCLING BUT ALSO
FOR THIS OTHER PERIL A PROVISION
IN THE BILL DEALING WITH MARINE
DEBRIS.
AND OTHER LITTERED ITEMS SO WE
THINK IT'S A A PROPOSAL THAT IS
WORTHY OF CONSIDERATION WE LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING THE
CONVERSATIONS DURING THE SUMMER --
TO HOPEFULLY REACH A POINT WHERE --
WE CAN WE CAN FIND SOME
RESOLUTION TO SOME OF THESE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES BUT WE DO
CURRENTLY -- HAVE SOME CONCERNS
WITH THE BILL'S DRAFTED AND ARE
OPPOSED TO LOOK FOR THE
CONVERSATIONS A SUMMER THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
JOHN HERE IT ON BEHALF OF THE
GROCERY MANUFACTURERS IN THE
CONSUMER PACKAGED GOODS
PRODUCERS -- AS MISHA SIX STATED --
WE GENERALLY SUPPORT THE INTENT
OR WE DO SUPPORT THE INTENT SB
FIFTY FOUR AS IT ALIGNS WITH --
C. P. G.'S UNIFIED GOALS OF
ENHANCING PACKAGE SUSTAINABILITY --
ANDAND AS AS WE DISCUSSED AND
AND LYING TO THE AUTHOR BOTH
AUTHORS -- TWENTY FIVE OF THE
LARGE CBG COMPANIES ALREADY
COMMITTED.
TO MAKING MORE RECYCLABLE --
COMPOSTABLE PACKAGING IN 80% OF
THEM OF ALREADY -- SET THAT
TWENTY THIRTY DEADLINE IN
WRITING -- AND MADE THAT
COMMITMENT TOWARDS THAT -- WITH
THAT SAID WE STILL DO HAVE SOME
SIGNIFICANT CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL -- MOST NOTABLY THE BILL
CREATES A SYSTEM -- SPECIFICALLY
THE CONDITION OF SALE WHERE THE
MANUFACTURE THE CBG COMPANIES
WILL.
BEAR ALL THE RESPONSIBILITY OF
THE PRODUCT -- WITHOUT THE
ABILITY IMPROVE THE SYSTEM OR
PROMOTE -- FOR COST EFFECTIVE
SOLUTIONS WITHIN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE -- WE CAN DESIGN
FOR RECYCLABILITY WE CAN DESIGN
FOR COMPOSED ABILITY AND AS I
MENTIONED WE'VE MADE THOSE
COMMITMENTS TO THAT -- BUT WE
CAN NOT DESIGNED FOR THE MORE
HUNDRED AND MORE THAN FOUR
HUNDRED EIGHTY JURISDICTIONS --
AND THE INDIVIDUAL REQUIREMENTS
THAT THEY HAVE WITHIN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA SO THAT IS
PROBLEMATIC. TO THE CG COMPANIES --
TO MAKE THIS WORK LONG TERM --
WE NEED TO TIGHTEN UP THE
DEFINITIONS EXPLORE THE OFF
RAMPS INVEST -- AND INVESTIGATE
THE NEEDS OF OF THE WASTE AND
AND THE AND THE RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN THE STATE --
I NOR STAKEHOLDER PROCESS THAT
THE SENATOR AND AND AND THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN HAVE COMMITTED --
TO WILL HELP US GET THERE --
THEY DID THIS PROCESS IN THE
TIME LINES IT'S GOING TO BE FAST
WERE WERE BRINGING THE SOLUTIONS
AND AND OUR IDEAS TO THE TABLE
WE MADE SPECIFIC.
AMENDMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS FOR A
MOMENT SAYS MISTER JACKSON HAS
AS WELL.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO GO FROM
ASPIRATIONAL THE ACTUAL WE NEED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE
TIME TO GET THIS RIGHT WE'RE
COMMITTED TO MAKING.
AND GETTING IT RIGHT CBG IS AS
PUT THOSE NUMBERS OUT THERE WE
STAND BY THOSE -- BUT WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT WERE A PRINTER
EXTREMELY TIGHT TIME FRAME HERE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
DON KHAKI MCCUE CAP CAN
ASSOCIATE SOMEHOW THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS AND TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION ASSUMES HE WOULD
ECHO THE COMMENTS MADE AN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THEN I SAW THE ONLY BE HALF THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION OF
THIS POINT WE WE OPPOSE AT THIS
TIME.
RIDLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE --
LINER COMMENTS WERE IN
OPPOSITION BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHORS THANKS.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS COMMITTEE
JOE ACKERMAN WE HAVE TO PLASTICS
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION.
WE ARE IN LINE WITH THE CENTERS
GOALS AND GOALS FOR THE BILL.
AND WE'RE HOPING TO WORK AND
MAKE SOME PROGRESS IN THE
WORKING GROUP'S THIS SUMMER.
THE COOKING YOUR IS THAT WE HAVE
THE HOUSE ON COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS
ASSOCIATION LOOK FOR TO THE
STAKEHOLDER -- PROCESS BUT
OPPOSE US AMENDED I THINK IT.
TOM JACOB CHEMICAL -- INDUSTRY
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA -- OPPOSED --
FOR THE REASONS STATED BUT
HOPEFUL THAT WE WILL -- RE TO
RECONCILE POINT THANK YOU.
KATIE HANDS WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RESTAURANT ASSOCIATION RIPOSTE
AS WELL.
HIS OF THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
FOOD PRODUCERS IN OPPOSITION BUT
LOOK FORWARD TO CONVERSATIONS
THE SUMMER THANK YOU.
ROB ROSS ON BEHALF OF AND A HALF
MEN FROM AMERICA AND WERE OPPOSE
THE BILL BUT LOOK FORWARD.
TO SINCERE AND HOPEFUL
[inaudible]
DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO
TESTIFY.
OKAY I'LL BRING IT BACK UP TO
THE DíAS FOR COMMENTS.
SOME MEMBER EGGMAN [inaudible]
WELL.
SO THIS IS THE SECOND TIME I'VE
HEARD THIS THE BILL -- IN THE
PREVIOUS AUTHOR WITH A A LOT OF
CONVERSATION ABOUT HOW.
MEETINGS ARE GOING TO HAPPEN IN
NEGOTIATIONS WERE GOING TO
HAPPEN IN -- AND NOW WE'RE BACK
HERE WITH THIS.
PART TWO AND NOTHING'S HAPPENED
YET SEEMS LIKE.
SEEMS LIKE THERE'S LIKE THIS I
MEAN I HEAR A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK
ABOUT LOOKING FORTY MEETINGS IN
THE OVER THE BREAK.
SO THAT'S GREAT -- BUT STILL
LIKE NOT A LOT HAS HAPPENED SO
FAR OR JUST BARELY HAVE STARTED --
SO I'M JUST WONDERING FOR THE
SAKE OF MY MY COMFORT.
CAN YOU WALK US THROUGH KIND OF
THE THE TIME LINE AS YOU SEE FOR
THE THE SCOPING PLAN OF THIS.
AND AS WERE SCOPING OUT WHAT IN
IS IT AT ANY POINT WILL THE RULE
MAKING GOING TO AFFECT BEFORE
THE SCOPING IS EVEN DONE.
OR HOW HOW YOU.
WHAT'S THE TIMELINE FOR THAT.
OKAY WELL FIRST OF ALL.
A LOT A LOT HAS HAPPENED I MEAN
THERE'S A LOT OF WORK IT'S IT'S
BEEN GOING AND AND AND THE BILL
IS.
CHANGED QUITE A BIT SINCE SINCE
YOU SAW IT LAST -- ONE OF THE
MAJOR NARROWING DOWN THAT TOOK
PLACE WAS FOCUSING ON THE TOP
TEN MOST -- POLLUTING PRODUCTS
AND THAT'S REALLY BEEN WHERE
WHERE THE THE CORE FOCUS OF THE
OF THE BILL AND AND THE AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS GOING TO BE --
BUT THE THE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE TAKEN ON THE TO GET OFF
THIS PART OF GETTING OFF THE
FLOOR -- INVOLVES PUSHING BACK
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
SCOPING PLAN BY A YEAR.
AND THE BILL SAYS THAT THE PLAN
HAS TO BE DONE BEFORE THE
REGULATIONS -- COME INTO PLAY SO
HOT SO.
YES THERE IS A THERE THERE THERE
THERE'S EVEN IF JUST BEFORE
TWENTY IF THAT'S POST TWENTY
THIRTY IF IF THE SCOPING IS NOT
COMPLETE.
LET'S GO BE HAS TO BE DONE BY
TWENTY BY THE J. FIRST.
BILL AND AND AND AND THE
REGULATIONS WOULD GO INTO EFFECT.
HOW HOW LONG BEFORE THE SCOPING
IS COMPLETE?
AND THE REGULATIONS WOULD GOING
TO AFFECT.
THE BILL AS BEST BUY THAT TO
THIS RESTAURANT OKAY SO SO I
MEAN THEORETICALLY THIS COULD BE
CONFINED SET SOMETHING TO BE IN
THAT SINGLE USE AND BE NO TIME
BETWEEN THEN.
AND WHEN THE REGULATIONS WOULD
GO INTO EFFECT THAT WOULD START
[inaudible]
REGULATING.
WELL REMEMBER THE YOU KNOW THAT
THE WHOLE SCOPING PROCESS IS.
IN IS DELINEATED IN THE BILL IS
GOING TO BE THE PRODUCT OF A
WILL INVOLVE EVERYBODY INVOLVED
INCLUDING MANUFACTURES AND FOLKS
ON THE RETAIL SIDE [inaudible]
AND SO THERE WILL BE IT I I'VE
NOT DONE NOTHING IS GONNA COME
OUT IT AT PEOPLE OUT BY SURPRISE
RIGHT THIS IS GOING TO BE.
A A LONG AND DRAWN OUT PROCESS
OF NEGOTIATION AND DISCUSSION --
AND SO I DON'T THINK I MEAN I IS
YOUR IS YOUR CORE CONCERNED
[inaudible]
PEOPLE.
KIND OF GETTING THINGS STARTED
DEMONIC SPECTER LEE OR WELL I
GUESS MY CONCERN IS THE SAME AS
WHAT WE'VE HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION RIGHT THAT THERE IS
NO CON DELINEATION OF WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE SCOPING AT THE SAME
TIME WE'RE DECIDING WHAT'S AND
WOOD SIDING WITH TOWERS SIDING
WITH THE THE CONTENT.
I WILL BE -- AND THEN AND THEN
RULE MAKING GOES INTO EFFECT SO
I'M JUST WONDERING WHAT THE LEAD
UP TIME IF ANY.
THAT YOU FEEL LIKE IT'S
REASONABLE FOR THAT DOES THE
DOES THINGS TO COME TOGETHER.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE WE
ARE?
TWENTY NINETEEN THIS WOULD.
PRISON WE PASSED BY THE END OF
THE SESSION RIGHT IF IF IF
EVERYTHING GOES BECAUSE WELL --
AND THEN.
USE COPING IS IT.
DOESN'T GET EMPTIED IT DOESN'T
GET FINISHED UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR SO IT'S QUITE A BIT OF TIME.
I TO TO MAKE THAT PROCESS
WORKING NOW HAVE ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS TAKE PLACE AND SO
THERE'S YOU KNOW.
I I UNDERSTAND ARE ALWAYS GOING
TO BE SOME FOLKS WHO WANT TO
MAKE IT LONGER BUT I I BET
THAT'S NOT A THAT'S NOT AN
INSIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF TIME --
TO TO TO REALLY PUT TOGETHER
ROBUST PROCESS.
OKAY TODAY MY TWENTY FOUR DO
THINK IT TO TELL.
TWENTY THIRTY YES YES I MEAN AT
TWENTY THIRTY WOULD BE THE KIND
OF THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE OF
THE 75%.
PRODUCTION THAT'S RIGHT YEAH IS
YOUR IS YOUR CORE CONCERN IS IT
THIS IS THIS IS TOO TIGHT TIME
FRAME -- WELL I GUESS MY CONCERN
IS THAT WERE WE ARE NOT I GUESS
WE'RE NOT FURTHER ALONG IN THE
IN THE PROCESS I MEAN I'VE HEARD
FROM.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH A LOT OF
CONCERNS AND THE SAME CONCERNS
AND I THINK THAT MANY OF US
EXPRESSED WHEN WE SAW.
THE THE OTHER AUTHORS VERSION OF
THE BILL AND A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT WE'LL GET THERE WE'LL GET
THERE WILL GET THEIR WHAT'S IN
WHAT'S OUT.
AND SO NOW WE'VE WE'VE TAKEN IT
DOWN TO THE THE TOP -- TEN AND
THEN I GUESS MIKE DIDN'T ONE OF
THE CONCERNS I CONTINUE TO HEAR
AND I THINK WE ALL HERE THEN.
IS THAT THEN THE DETERMINATION
IS LEFT UP TO CAL RECYCLE AT THE
VERY END SO WHAT POINT DOES IT
COME BACK TO US.
WE'VE GOT OVERSIGHT OVER THE
WORK THEY DO AT ANY POINT WE CAN.
CHANGE THE LAW FOR AND HAPPY
WITH ANYTHING IS HAPPENING WITH
AGGRESSIVE LIMITATION -- THE
DOUBLE CHECK POINTS WHAT COMES
BACK TO US EXCEPT THAT WE WOULD
HAVE TO DO A WHOLE NOTHER Là IF
WE DIDN'T LIKE THE WAY.
IT WE COULD CERTAINLY WE CAN
CERTAINLY IF YOU WANT TO TALK
SHOP ABOUT TRYING TO PUT SOME --
REPORTING BACK LANGUAGE OR OR
YOU KNOW -- I THINK THE YEAH
OKAY SO THE COMMITMENTS YES
RIGHT OKAY SO THE COMMITMENTS TO
REQUIRE REPORTING -- WE GET IF
YOU WANT TO LOOK AT THE LANGUAGE
AND MAKE SURE THAT.
HERE WE ARE IF YOU LOOK AT PAGE
EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS -- IF YOU
WANNA TALK SHOP ABOUT.
STRUGGLING WERE SOMEHOW -- WEEK
WE'RE CERTAINLY OPEN THAT
CONVERSATION -- FEET THAT'S I I
I HEAR WHAT YOU'RE SAYING I MEAN
YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THERE'S THAT WE'RE KEEPING AN
EYE ON ON THE IMPLEMENTATION ON
THE PROCESS -- AND THERE'S MORE
EYES ON IT JUST AND CAL RECYCLE
NOT THAT WE DON'T THINK THEY DO
A GREAT JOB THERE BUT IT IS.
WE'RE TAKING A YOU KNOW I'M AND
WE ALL AGREE THERE'S TOO MUCH.
PLASTIC RIGHT I'VE GOT A THE KID
WHO JUST FINISHED FIFTH GRADE SO
WHAT WE ALL GOT THE REPORT ON
PLASTIC AND AM AND WHAT IT DOES.
AND CERTAINLY MY HOUSE WE TRY TO
USE AS LITTLE AS WE CAN.
BUT WE ALSO KNOW THAT THERE'S
INDUSTRIES OUT THERE THEN THAT'S
THAT THAT THAT IS THE PRODUCT
THAT PEOPLE ARE USING RIGHT NOW
SO AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
WHOLESALE CHANGES.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
LIKE WHAT WHAT ARE THE PRIORITY
SINGLE USE ONCE HOW TO DO THAT
WHAT IS COMPOSED OF ALL IN WHAT
IS NOT WHAT IS THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT ARE ALL THESE THINGS GOING
TO BE.
AND THEN SHOULD REALLY BE THE
MANUFACTURERS JOB AND I LIKE
BLACK MANY ANYBODY WHO WORKS IN
THIS AREA.
WHO GOES OUT AND SEEM MARCIN
GORTAT GONE OUT AND TALKED --
CITY COUNCIL TWO THOUSAND SIX
WERE TALKING AT SOME POINT CHINA
IS NOT GOING TO WANT TO TRASH
RIGHT RIGHT WE SHOULD BE GETTING
READY A LONG TIME BEFORE AND WE
DIDN'T AND NOW WE'RE HERE NOW.
AND SO I'M GUESSING AS WE AS
WE'RE GONNA SHE STOOD UP THE
STARTING GUN AS WE'RE DOING THIS.
THAT WERE ALSO MAKING SURE THAT
THEIR TIMELINES IN PLACE AND
PROTECTIONS AND GUARD RAILS IN
PLACE THAT WE DO IT IN A WAY
THAT WE DON'T HAVE TO COME BACK
AND TRY TO REDO.
UNDO WHAT WE'VE DONE AND WE DO
SOMETHING ELSE.
THOSE ARE THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS
AND I THINK THERE'S A REASONABLE
CONCERNS -- FOR ANYBODY WHO'S A
LEGISLATOR INSTEAD OF CALIFORNIA
AND ANYTIME.
I MEAN HOW MANY TIMES DO WE HEAR
ABOUT THE A. R. B. BOARD AND AND
EVERY AGENCY THAT WE GIVE A
AUTHORITY.
TO WE OFTEN TIMES AND COMING
BACK AND SAYING WHO'S MAKING
DECISIONS IS IT AN AGENCY WAS
SOMEBODY APPOINTED OR IS ELECTED
PEOPLE THAT WE SEND THEIR TO
REPRESENT US.
I'D GET IT BUT I GUESS BUT WE
KNOW WHAT WHAT THE LEGISLATURE
ENDS UP DOING OFTENTIMES IS IS.
CAN A PIECEMEAL APPROACH WE DO
ONE OFF BILLS OR BANNING ONE
PARTICULAR PLASTIC ITEM -- WERE
WERE WERE BEEN GAUGING IN ONE
LITTLE PIECE OF THIS BROAD PIE I
THINK WHAT WE WANT TO DO HERE.
WAS ACTUALLY MORE HOLISTIC MORE
MORE -- YEAH MORE REALISTIC IN
THE IN THIS APPROACH WE'VE GOT A
GOT A BIG PROBLEM ON OUR HANDS
AND YOU KNOW I WAS THE TO THE
ASSEMBLY SUPPORT OF OF THE STRAW
BALE BUT IN THE END OF THE DAY
THE PROBLEM ISN'T JUST STRAWS
RIGHT I MEAN IT IT YOU.
KNOW WE GET WE PASS THAT BILL OR
NOT PASSED A BILL AND NOT REALLY
HI IF IT'S NOT IN FOR ITS
UNFORTUNATE NOT GONNA MOVE THE
ENVELOPE IN A IN A REALLY
SERIOUS WAY -- AND BY THE WAY I
WILL SAY THAT WE'RE NOT DOING
AWAY WITH PLASTICS WITH THIS
BILL WE'RE WE'RE JUST PUSHING
THESE PRODUCTS.
TOWARD A MORE SUSTAINABLE PLACE
AND NOT THAT'S THAT'LL DEALING
WITH THIS BILL IS ALL ABOUT IT'S
IT'S NOT ACTUALLY ABOUT.
U. DRAMATICALLY CHANGING EVEN
CONSUMER BEHAVIOR IT'S JUST THAT
THAT WE KNOW THERE ARE BETTER
PRODUCTS OUT THERE IS ACTUALLY
ALREADY BEING SOLD IN A LOT OF
PLACES -- BUT THEN THE MARKET A
LITTLE BIT OF A NUDGE TO PUSH.
OUR TOWARD MORE SUSTAINABLE MORE
RECYCLABLE MORE -- REUSABLE
COMPOSTABLE ALTERNATIVES NO
THOSE ARE A LITTLE KNOWLEDGE
THIS IS THE NEXT IS A LITTLE
MUCH.
IT IS A LITTLE NUDGE ADVOCATE
COULD CUT BECAUSE WHAT I BECAUSE
IF YOU IF YOU HERE.
I'M EVEN THE BILL FIRST CAME OUT --
YOU KNOW -- INDUSTRY IS IS
ALREADY MOVING VERY DIRECTLY IN
THIS DIRECTION -- AND VERY
PURPOSEFULLY I ACTUALLY THINK IT
WILL BENEFIT AN ADVANTAGE A LOT
OF HOME GROWN CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS WHO HAVE ALREADY
MADE A LOT OF PROGRESS IN THIS
AREA OVER.
MANUFACTURES FROM OTHER PARTS OF
THE WORLD WHO MAY BE LESS
SUSTAINABLE IN THEIR BUSINESS
PRACTICES I THINK THAT'S WHY --
YEAH THERE'S OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED
ABOUT ANY ATTEMPT BY THE
LEGISLATURE TO STEP IN AND
REGULATE A CERTAIN ASPECT OF THE
WAY THAT WE MANUFACTURE THINGS
BUT I DO THINK.
THAT THAT THE THE SAVVY FOLKS ON
THE BUSINESS SIDE -- WHO HAVE
BEEN ENGAGING VERY ROBUSTLY WITH
US AND IN THIS DISCUSSION
UNDERSTAND THEY'RE ACTUALLY SOME
REAL BUSINESS OPPORTUNITIES HERE?
FOR SUSTAINABLY ORIENTED --
CALIFORNIA BUSINESSES SOMETHING
WITH WITH WHAT HAPPENED WITH
SOLAR RIGHT I MEAN THERE WAS A
MOMENT AT WHICH SOLAR WAS SO
EXPENSIVE IN THERE THAT NOBODY
COULD IMAGINE.
THAT WOULD BE THE PLACE NOW I
WAS JUST AT MY FRIEND'S HOUSE.
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT IN PLACE
SOLAR PANELS ON THEIR HOUSE AND
THEY'VE ACTUALLY PENCIL OUT
ABOUT HOW IT'S GOING TO SAVE THE
MONEY -- YOU KNOW WITHIN ABOUT
FIVE SIX YEARS.
AND THAT THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
UNTHINKABLE TWENTY YEARS AGO
RIGHT TO BE TWENTY YEARS AGO.
EVERYBODY YOU KNOW WHAT IT WAS
JUST SOMETHING THAT WAS DONE BY
PEOPLE WHO HAD A LOT OF MONEY TO
BURN AND WANTED TO MAKE A POINT --
NOW WE'VE ACTUALLY YOU THROUGH A
KIND A COMBINATION OF MARKET
FORCES AND GOVERNMENTAL REGULAR
YOU KNOW GOVERNMENTAL NAY JING
HEY WE'VE GOT NO PLACE WHERE
SOULS ACTUALLY NOW STARTING TO
BECOME.
AFFORDABLE FOR PEOPLE I THINK
SIMILARLY -- WE'RE WHAT WE'RE
DOING HERE IS YOU KNOW IF YOU
VIRGIN PLASTIC IS JUST SO CHEAP
IT'S SO CHEAP.
THERE ARE THERE ALTERNATIVES
THAT ARE THAT ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
BETTER FOR THE ENVIRONMENT THAT
ARE JUST A LITTLE BIT MORE.
BUT BUT COMPANIES JUST DON'T
HAVE THE INCENTIVE TO MOVE
TOWARD THOSE PRODUCTS.
I AM ACTUALLY IF WE CAN HELP TO
TO PUSH.
WE CAN WE CAN WE TO PUSH PEOPLE
THOSE DIRECTIONS WE CAN TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF ECONOMIES OF SCALE
DROP THE PRICES AND ACTUALLY.
GIVEN THE FACT THAT PEOPLE ALL
OVER THE WORLD KNOW THEY NEED TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS AS WELL.
I A IS MORE ENTITIES MORE
JURISDICTIONS ADOPT THIS SORT OF
MODEL WILL HELP TO DRIVE DOWN
PRICES -- OVERALL I SAID OVER
AND OVER AGAIN I WOULD CONSIDER
THIS EFFORT TO BE A FAILURE.
IF WE PASS A GREAT BILL HERE IN
CALIFORNIA BUT WE DO SO -- IN A
WAY THAT IMPACTS OUR ECONOMY
SUCH THAT OTHER JURISDICTIONS
OUT WON'T WANT TO ADOPT SIMILAR
MODELS I THINK AT THE HEART OF
THIS.
IS SHOWING THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
THE PROGRESS THAT WE'VE MADE
BOTH IN TERMS OF DOING THE RIGHT
BY ENVIRONMENT AND ALSO GROWING
ECONOMICALLY.
AND DOING RIGHT BY CONSUMERS
ONLY WITH THE WITHOUT TRY FACT
AND PLACE WILL BE ABLE TO TRULY
SELL THIS MODEL TO OTHER STATES
AND OTHER NATIONS.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO HERE I MEAN ULTIMATELY
CALIFORNIA IT IS AN IMPORTANT
PLACE AND I LOVE TO DO THE RIGHT
THING ENVIRONMENTALLY HERE BUT
THIS IS ALL ABOUT TRYING TO
SCALE THIS MODEL GLOBALLY. TO
REALLY MAKE A A REAL DIFFERENCE
GRAHAM AND I THINK WE ALL AGREE
WITH THAT AND I THINK THAT'S WHY
IS IMPORTANT TO GET IT RIGHT.
BECAUSE I'LL I WILL ALSO SAY.
I'M GOING TO THE SMALL CABIN OFF
THE GRID RIGHT NOW WITH SOLAR IT
DOESN'T WORK.
RIGHT AND I CAN'T GET ANYBODY UP
THERE TO FIX IT BECAUSE IT'S TOO
FAR OFF THE GRID AND SO FOR
EVERYTHING THAT WE SAY THE ME
GREAT EVERYBODY'S GONNA DO IT.
THERE ARE PROBLEMS INHERENT IN
IT AND I GUESS THAT'S WHAT I SIT
HERE AND STRUGGLE WITH.
THE PROBLEMS THAT ARE HERE AND
THAT AND THAT THE MANUFACTURERS
HAVE TO BE RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
RESALE PRODUCT OF THAT
RECYCLABILITY.
BECAUSE THOSE ARE TWO SEPARATE
MARKET YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
RIGHT WHO MAKES IT AND WHAT AND
BECAUSE THEY'RE THEY'RE LOOKING
FOR MARKETS ALL OVER THE WORLD
ON THIS ALL THE TIME. TO THAT
HAVE THOSE TWO THINGS TIED
TOGETHER.
I ALSO THINK IT'S PROBLEMATIC SO
I I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK ON THIS
I THINK THERE'S A LOT OF THOSE
WORKING IN THIS SPACE WE NEED TO
CONTINUE THE WORK.
BUT I REALLY BELIEVE THAT YOU
NEED TO HAVE A WE GOT IT RIGHT
AND I THINK IT ADVOCATING TO AN
OUTSIDE AGENCY IS ALWAYS MORE
PROBLEMATIC WITHOUT REAL CHECKS
AND BALANCES WITH US WITHOUT
TIMELINES IT CLEARLY DELINEATE
WHEN THIS IS COPING PLAN WHEN
ARE THEY GOING TO HAVE THE
INFORMATION.
ON THAT AND THEN WHEN IT TO THE
REGULATIONS GOING TO AFFECT AND
THEN.
ON ON THE AND MARKET ISSUES SO
THOSE ARE MY CONCERNS.
THE SUMMER GARCIA.
THANK YOU SO I HAVE.
THOSE ARE THE COMMENTS AND AND
THEN I HAVE A SET OF QUESTIONS --
I DO RECOGNIZE THE AMENDMENTS WE
YOU TOOK YOUR AND I ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WAS ALWAYS TOOK. TO GET
THE ORIGINAL TEN EIGHTY OFF THE
FLOOR AND THOSE AMENDMENTS ARE
REFLECTED.
IN IN THIS BILL SO I DO
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT INCLUDES --
THE TOP TEN PIECE AND EXTENDING --
THEY'LL THE DEADLINE.
FOR THE SCOPING PLAN SO I DO
WANT TO GET CREDIT FOR THAT BUT
I WILL SAY THAT IT'S BEEN A
MONTH SINCE THEN THEN THERE WERE.
A LOT OF QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ASKED.
AND AND I CAN'T SAY I ASKED THEM
OF YOU BECAUSE YOU ARE THE
PERSON ON THE FLOOR BUT WERE
ASKED OF YOUR PARTNER.
BY ME ABOUT THIS WILL BE PLAN
ABOUT CALORIE CYCLE AND PROMISES
MADE THAT WE WOULD FIGURE OUT
THE SENSES BEFORE THIS BILL CAME
BEFORE ME AGAIN AND I SAID OKAY
I'M GONNA SEE.
SB FIFTY FOUR NATURAL RESOURCES
I SAID ON THAT COMMITTEE SAID
CAN YOU MAKE SURE SOME OF THOSE
ANSWERS ARE.
ARE ANSWERED BEFORE I COME SEE
ME THERE AND NOT WHEN IT COMES
TO THE FLOOR.
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND SO YOU
WEREN'T PRIVY TO THAT
CONVERSATION THAT'S A
CONVERSATION I HAD WILL DOUBLE
TIES WITH.
YOUR WITH YOUR JOIN NOT THERE I
MISS MISS GONZALEZ ABOUT THIS
BILL -- INTO THAT'S FOR SOME OF
MY FRUSTRATION STEMS FROM -- AND
SO I I I WANT TO MAKE THAT
COMMENT BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY I HAVE COSTLY TOLL FOLKS
THIS BILL IS GOING.
TO KEEP MOVING AND I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE WE HAVE THE BEST
POSSIBLE LEGISLATION -- ALONG
THE WAY AND SO I DO HAVE
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS BASED AYE
WAIT WHERE YOUR BILL IS THAT
RIGHT NOW.
AND SO MY FIRST QUESTION IS
ABOUT CAL RECYCLE AND WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'RE HERE. TO TALK ABOUT
THE BILL.
AND SO WE ARE WE ARE GIVING A
LOT OF POWER TO COVER CYCLE AND
I'M FINE WITH THAT AGENCY I
DON'T HAVE TOO MANY COMPLAINTS
ABOUT THEM -- BUT MY QUESTION IS
ARE THE ENGAGE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ENGAGE IN THAT IN
THAT THEY WERE GIVING THE
ADMINISTRATION CAL RECYCLE BY
DEFAULT.
ALL THIS POWER TO FIGURE FIGURE
OUT A NEED TO SENSE HOW.
IN SO WHERE ARE THEY IN THE
PROCESS WHERE THEY'RE NOT HERE.
IT'S BEEN YEAH THIS IS.
WHEN YOU TALK TO THEIR THEIR
PEOPLE INDUSTRIES VERY EXCITED
ABOUT THIS AND I THINK THEY --
THEY SEE HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS
AS A YOU KNOW AS AS AN APPROACH
THAT'S GONNA HELP TO ADDRESS AN
ENORMOUS PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE --
IT DOES AS YOU KNOW [inaudible]
MINISTRATIONS -- OF TODAY AND
PAST HAVE ALWAYS BEEN -- LEARY
ESPECIALLY PEOPLE WITHIN THE
KIND OF THE GRAND BUREAUCRACY
HAVE BEEN LEERY TO WEIGH IN.
HI TO FORCEFULLY ON BILLS I WILL
SAY THAT -- I PERSONALLY
ENCOURAGE COLLEAGUES AND I
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO DO THE SAME
SOME MEMBER -- TO TO TO TO TALK
TO AND I CAN FACILITATE THE CALL
TO YOU CAN OBVIOUSLY ME AND
CALLED.
ARE THE HEAD OF THE KELLY PA --
OR OTHERS -- PERSONALLY AND TALK
ABOUT BOTH YOUR CONCERNS YOUR
YOUR YOUR HOPES YOUR FEARS YOUR
AMBITIONS YOUR DREAMS FOR THIS
BILL AND THE PLAN IN PLACE HERE.
I WANT THEM TO HEAR DIRECTLY
FROM MY COLLEAGUES LIKE YOU.
ABOUT HOW SERIOUSLY ND HOW HOW
THOUGHTFUL YOU'RE TAKING THIS
DECISION.
HI HOW YOU SHARE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
ABOUT THE THE EXTENT TO WHICH
WERE GIVING A THIRTY TWO CALIBER
CYCLE IN THIS BILL.
AND THEY REALLY NEED YOU NEED TO
HEAR FROM THE LEADERSHIP THAT
THEY'RE TAKING OWNERSHIP THAT
THEY ARE THEY THEY THEY THEY
HEAR THE SORTS OF CONCERNS THAT
ARE THAT ARE BEING VOICED BY
MEMBERS THE LEGISLATURE.
AND THEY'RE THEY'RE GOING TO
TAKE THEM SERIOUSLY AND THAT AND
THAT THAT THEY THAT THEY THEY
MAKE COMMITMENTS TO YOU -- THAT
THE THE THE SORTS OF THE SORT OF
IMPLEMENTATION YOU LIKE TO SEE
WILL BE WILL BE WILL BE
RESPECTED -- BY THEM WHEN IT
WHEN IT WHEN IT COMES TIME TO TO
TO ROLLING OUT THIS PROCESS I
THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT I
I REALLY ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS I'M
CERTAINLY HAVING THEM -- WITH
WITH WITH FOLKS OVER THERE --
BUT I I ENCOURAGE YOU TO DO THE
SAME BECAUSE I I REALLY DO THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT YOUR UPS RIGHT THIS
GIVES.
THIS IS IT THIS IS A THIS IS A
THIS IS THIS IS.
RELYING ON THEM.
A GREAT DEAL AND WE NEED TO WE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE HEARING FROM YOU AND
OTHERS.
AND TAKING OWNERSHIP.
BUT THIS IS NOT MY BILL AND SO
KIND OF LIKE ASKING ME TO HELP
YOU DO YOUR HOMEWORK -- AND FILL
MY PART OF DOING MY PART IS IN
THIS COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW AS I
SEE THE BILLING GIVING INPUT TO
THINGS THAT I WOULD.
LIKE TO SEE AND HAVING A BILL
CONTINUE TO MOVE ABOUT CARRY
CYCLE IN THEM AND MINISTRATION
AGREEING TO BE PART OF THIS
PROCESS NOW.
MAKES ME REALLY WARY I'M GONNA
VOTE FOR YOUR BILL TODAY BECAUSE
THE DISCUSSION YOU'RE TRYING TO
HAVE THIS IMPORTANT.
AND I DON'T WANT TO SAY THAT I
DON'T WANT TO MINIMIZE ITS
IMPORTANCE BUT I HAVE LOTS OF
OTHER PRIORITIES THAT I'M
WORKING ON MY OWN ALREADY WHY
I'M CALLING CAL EPA.
ON A REGULAR BASIS ABOUT THINGS
LIKE P. FOSS EXIDE ARSENIC AND
ALL THE OTHER GREAT TOXICS BUT I
MY BACKYARD.
SO I DON'T WANT TO MINIMIZE THE
WORK THAT YOU DO HERE BECAUSE IT
IS IMPORTANT TO HAVE
CONSTITUENTS IN MY BACKYARD THAT
ARE TRACKING THIS AND IT'S
IMPORTANT TO THEM.
SO I DON'T WANT TO TAKE THAT
COMMENT AS LIKE YOU KNOW
MINIMIZING YOUR WORK HERE.
BUT I I WILL SAY THAT I THINK
THAT THAT'S SOMETHING HE THAT
KEEPS JUST BOTHERING ME IN THE
BACK OF MY HEAD -- AS I LOOK AT
THE BILL I ALSO HAVE QUESTIONS
WERE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT
SOME OF THE LANGUAGE IN HERE WE
HAVE LANGUAGE THAT ALLOWS CARRY
CYCLE TO INCREASE THE RATE
BEYOND 75%.
YEAH AND I ASK MYSELF THE
QUESTION OF WHY ARE WE ALLOWING
THAT TO DECREASE IT IF IT'S IF
IT'S DEEMED CELL IN THE PROCESS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THEM
ALL THIS POWER.
WHY ARE WE NOT GIVEN THE POWER
IN BOTH DIRECTIONS UP OR DOWN --
FOR FOR THAT FOR THAT RATE -- IN
SOMETHING FOR YOU TO CONSIDER AS
WE TALK ABOUT GIVING THEM POWER
BUT GIVING THEM ENOUGH POWERS AT
THE FLEXIBLE I WILL SAY MY
EXPERIENCE IT'S COVEY CYCLE.
IS THAT IT WILL LIVE I DON'T
EVEN EXACTLY TELL ME THAT A
LEGISLATION I DON'T DO IT -- AND
SO THEY HAVE IN SEVEN YEARS I
MADE IT VERY CLEAR TO ME LIKE
YOU HAVE TO GIVE ME VERY
SPECIFIC AUTHORITY AND SO I
THINK THAT IT WE'RE GOING TO
GIVE THEM AUTHORITY INCLUDING
WITH THE SCHOOL BEHIND AND HOW
WE MOVE.
WE HAVE TO GIVEN THE FLEXIBILITY
NOT JUST MOVE THE NUMBER UP BUT
IF NEED BE MOVE IT DOWN AND I
KNOW THAT THAT'S WHAT WE WANT TO
BE AND WE DON'T WANT TO CONSIDER
THAT.
YOU WANT TO BE AMBITIOUS AND
WANT TO BE POSITIVE AND HOPEFUL
BUT I THINK WE HAVE TO ALLOW FOR
BOTH THE UP AND THE DOWN IN YOUR
LAN WHICH ALLOWS FOR THE UP.
I THINK WE NEED TO INCLUDE THE
DOWN IN THERE AS AS THIS MOVE
FORWARD IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
YOU'VE CONSIDERED AT ALL YET I I
I WOULD CERTAINLY CONSIDER THAT
I I AGREE -- THE KEY THING HERE
IS FLEXIBILITY HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT THAT EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
I MEAN OBVIOUSLY HI.
YEAH WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THIS
IS MEANINGFUL -- I WILL SAY THAT
THE BILL.
YOU KNOW DOES ULTIMATELY.
THERE'S LANGUAGE IN THE BILL
THAT JUST TALKS ABOUT HOW YOU
FOR ANY PACKAGE YOUR PRODUCT
IDENTIFIES PRESENTING.
THOSE UNIQUE CHALLENGES AS SORT
OF UNIQUE CHALLENGES.
ARE THE DEPARTMENT SHALL DEVELOP
A PLAN TO PHASE OUT PHASE THE
PACKAGING OUR PRODUCTS INTO THE
REGULATIONS I MEAN THERE'S
THERE'S THERE'S VARIOUS AREAS
WHERE THERE'S FLEXIBILITY BUILT
IN BUT IF YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT.
ABOUT ABOUT SOME SORT OF
WHATEVER SPECIFIC LINGUISTIC Là
MY CHAIR YEAH ABOUT IF I COULD I
THANK RAMP UP THE NUMBER Y.
CONTAINMENT THAT DOWN AS A AS AN
IMPLEMENT FERMENTATION AGENCY.
I GUESS IF IF IT WERE ON BASED
ON SOMETHING.
REAL I WOULD.
B. THEN THEN THAT THINK OF
ENTIRELY APPROPRIATE IF IT'S A
MATTER OF OF THEM.
BEING LAZY OR YOU KNOW JUST BE
YOU CAN HAVING A DISREGARD FOR
FOR FOR OUR GOALS THEN I I GUESS
I'D BE MORE.
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THAT BUT I
GUESS IF WE COULD FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO WRITE.
THAT RAMP DOWN LANGUAGE -- YOU
KNOW IN IN THE RIGHT WAY AND I'M
HAPPY TO THINK IT TO THEIR
OFFICE ON THAT I I'D BE ABLE TO
ABSOLUTELY BUT I THINK YOU WE
FEEL THAT CAL WE WE TRUST KILEY
CYCLE ENOUGH TO GIVE THE MOST
AUTHORITY TO FIGURE OUT ALL
THESE NEW SAYS THAT.
WE'RE NOT SURE ABOUT THE ON THE
ROAD -- SO LET'S AS THE
LEGISLATURE THEN WE HAVE TO BE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE PROCESS
EITHER WAY NOT JUST ONE WAY I
FEEL THAT THIS IN JENNY WITH TO
SEE WE TRUST YOU OR TRUST TRUST
THEM THEIR THEIR DECENT.
AS AN AGENCY SO I WOULD JUST SAY
THAT WHEN WE YOU KNOW IT.
A TO ME IT JUST FEELS LIKE A BY
TRUSTEE THAT I'M INTERESTED THEY
GONNA TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY AND
YOU'RE ONLY GOING TO USE THIS
OPTION.
AS A LAST RESORT MAYBE YOU LAST
RESORT BUT AS LONG AS WE AS I
WAS AWARDED THE DIRECTION THE
RIGHT WAY.
YEAH I THINK SO SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THAT WOULD BE
IMPORTANT FOR ME AS THIS MOVES
FORWARD I DON'T SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS I WON'T GET TO
SEE THAT THEREBUT TO SOMETHING
I HOPE YOU FIGURE OUT BEFORE.
APPROPRIATIONS.
TAKES THIS BILL UP I ALSO HAVE --
WHAT ELSE IS THE BIG I I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU ADDRESS SOME
OF THE FOOD SAFETY CONCERNS THAT
ARE -- THAT HAVE BEEN THROWN OUT
THERE BY THE OPPOSITION AND SO I
THINK YOU FOR THAT -- AND JUST
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FOOD SAFETY THAT
WE'RE ALSO TALKING ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL FOR FOOD WASTE AND
THAT WE'RE NOT CREATING MORE
FOOD WASTE AS A CONSEQUENCE.
ALONG THE WAY -- AND FOR LACK OF
A BETTER EXAMPLE OF OF THE FOOD
WASTE I THIS IS MAYBE NOT THE
BEST EXAMPLE HERE BUT IT'S IT'S
IT'S SOMETHING I ENCOUNTER
REGULARLY S. I'M EATING.
AND BUYING ORGANICS AND THE
SHELF LIFE THAT THEY HAVE AND I
LIVE BY MYSELF IN SACRAMENTO AND
I FIND MYSELF AT THE END OF THE
WEEK LIKE.
ARE COMING BACK ON MONDAY WITH
MY FOOD NOT BEING GOOD ANYMORE
RIGHT AND SO I WANT THE ORGANIC
STUFF BUT IT'S CREATED THIS TWO
WAYS FOR ME ON A REGULAR BASIS
BUT I HAVE. TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
DO BETTER ABOUT SO FOR LACK OF A
BETTER EXAMPLE BUT IT'S A
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES TO A
VERY GOOD DEAL I THINK WE NEED
TO BE.
TALKING ABOUT THAT AS WE
CONTINUE TO ADDRESS THE FOOD
SAFETY PIECES THAT YOU'VE
STARTED TO ADDRESS AND STOP I DO
WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND GIVE YOU
CREDIT. FOR THAT AND THEN THE
LAST THING AS I WAS READING THIS
THIS BILL -- WAS THE PART ON
ENFORCEMENT WITHIN CLEAR TO ME
THAT THERE WAS ANY SORT OF
ENFORCEMENT OR TEETH.
IN AND THIS BILL RIGHT NOW AND I
GET THAT THAT MIGHT BE THAT THAT
WHILE THEY'RE STILL OPPOSITION
AND WE HAVEN'T FIGURED OUT OTHER
IMPORTANT PIECES THAT MIGHT BE
THE HARDEST ONE TO FIGURE OUT.
BUT I I DO THINK THAT WE NEED
SOME SORT OF ENFORCEMENT
MECHANISM -- AND IN THIS BILL AT
SOME POINT.
HOT AND SO THOSE ARE IS THE TERM
I AM HOPING SOME VERY SPECIFIC --
SMALL AND BIG THINGS THAT I'M
LOOKING AT IN THIS BILL AS IT
MOVES FORWARD ON INSTEAD OF JUST
TELLING YOU FIGURE IT OUT THIS
ARE ITEMS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE FIGURE IT OUT BEFORE.
THE NEXT LIFE OF OF THIS BILL
WHICH IS NOT TODAY I UNDERSTAND
THAT -- THE LAST THING IS I
WANTED AYE I HAD HEARD FROM THE
OPPOSITION ABOUT THE ADVANCE
RECYCLE FEE PROPOSAL.
ON AND I WILL SAY THAT WHEN
SOMEONE COMES TO TELL ME THAT WE
WANT TO GIVE YOU MONEY TO GET
SOMETHING GOING AND WE HAVE TO
FIGURE OUT HOW TO GET THIS
MARKET GOING BECAUSE IT'S I
DON'T UNDER I DON'T WANT THINGS
TO BE RECYCLABLE.
BUT THEN NO ONE WANTS TO USED TO
RECYCLE CONTENT SO -- WHAT'S
YOUR OPINION ABOUT THIS ADVANCE
RECYCLE FEE PROPOSAL AND WHY YOU
AREN'T -- AREN'T IT ON THE
SUPPORT OF IT BECAUSE I'VE AND
NOT SOMETHING THAT THE CHEMISTRY
COUNCIL BROUGHT UP.
CORRECT.
ABOUT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
YEAH.
YEAH -- WE'RE THIS IS PART OF
OUR DISCUSSIONS THIS SUMMER -- I
THINK WE NEED TO WE NEED.
TO I FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPLICATIONS HOW IT IN A PLACE
WITH ALL THE OTHER THINGS ARE
TRYING TO DO WITH THE BILL --
BUT YEAH IT'S ON THE TABLE AND
AND WE'RE WE'RE GONNA TALK ABOUT
AND LOOKING AT I MEAN THE
REALITY IS THAT DEVELOPING THIS
MARKET'S GONNA COST MONEY RIGHT
AND WE SEE -- AFTER I'M NOT AND
I'M NOT ASKING ABOUT A STORAGE
OF COUNSEL BECAUSE THAT'S THE
WAY TO COME UP WITH MONEY TO AND
THEY HAVEN'T ALL BEEN WORKING AT
THE STATE VERY WELL EITHER SO --
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY THESE
THINGS BECAUSE MONEY WHETHER
IT'S FROM A FEE.
THAT PEOPLE VOLUNTARILY YOU KNOW
PROVIDER FEE WE IMPOSE OR AT THE
END OF THE DAY FOR THE GENERAL
FUND WHERE WE HAVE GOALS ON
ORGANICS OUT THERE WERE HAVING
TO PUT ADDITIONAL MONIES.
IN FROM OUR GENERAL FUND FROM
CAP AND TRADE TO GET THAT MARKET
GOING WE KNOW THAT THE MARKET'S
GOING TO TAKE SOME REAL MONEY TO
DEVELOP.
AND SO WHEN I HEAR SOMEONE
WANTING TO OFFER AS A HUNDRED
MILLION AND WHEN THEY OFF WHEN
THEY SAID I WAS LIKE WELL MAYBE
WE NEED MORE THAN THAT MAYBE
THAT'S NOT ENOUGH THAT IF YOU'RE
GOING TO OFFER ME CAN YOU OFFER
ME MORE.
BUT I WILL SAY THAT.
IT'S RARE THAT WE HAVE FOLKS
COMING OFFERS MANY LIKE THAT TO
PAY FOR SOMETHING THAT WE KNOW
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO FIGURE OUT A
WAY TO HELP PAY FOR THIS.
YES I DO HOPE WE WE HAVE THAT
DISCUSSION ABOUT THE MONEY
WHETHER IT'S THIS IS SOMETHING
UP WITH THE SOME POINT.
IT IF WE DON'T HAVE THEM PAY FOR
THE TAXPAYERS WILL BE PAYING FOR
IT TO MAKE SURE THIS IS
SUCCESSFUL AND I THINK WE NEED
TO START HAVING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS NOW NOT LATER YEAH.
YEAH I I I HAVE SO YOU'RE.
SO I LOOK FORWARD I HOPE THAT --
YOU DIDN'T GET TO HAVE THIS
DISCUSSION WITH ME ON THE FLOOR
BUT YOU'RE HAVING THOSE
DISCUSSIONS OF ME NOW SO I HOPE
BETWEEN NOW AND THE NEXT MONTH
OF THIS GOING THROUGH A PROCESS
OF SPEND.
YOU HAVE SOME OF THOSE ANSWERS
FOR ME EVEN THOUGH I DON'T SIT
ON THAT.
COMMITTEE BECAUSE AND I WILL BE
LIKE THE I AGREE TEACHER THAT'S
LIKE LIKE GIVING YOU AN
EXTENSION AND WHY HAVEN'T YOU
DONE YOUR HOMEWORK.
I THANK YOU AND AND JUST JUST TO
SAY ON ON THE ISSUE OF TALKING
MINISTRATION I I'M CERTAINLY I
AM TALKING THE MINISTRATION AND
HAVE DONE -- I I ONLY WAS BRING
THAT UP -- BECAUSE YEAH. TO THE
EXTENT THAT I I WANT THEM TO
HEAR FROM MEMBERS -- TO TO
REALLY.
I DO THINK IT STRENGTHENS OUR
ARE KIND OF COLLECTIVE POWER
WITH THESE IF YOU WERE TRYING.
BUT I I I TOTALLY I WAS GOT A
LOT GOING ON AND AND WANTED THEM
TO CONTINUE I WILL CONTINUE TO
PASS THESE CONVERSATIONS ON TO
THEM AND MANY OF THEM AND IF
THEY DON'T HAVE TIME THIS YEAR
THIS IS BECOME A TIER BILLS THAT
THEY DO HAVE TECH. TO COME TO
THE TABLE YOU NEED ON TO THAT
QUESTION BUT I THINK OF FAIR
QUESTION FOR ME TO PUT OUT THERE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER MCCARTY.
THANK YOU A MANAGER JUST A QUICK
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS DROWNED.
THERE ARE TWO BILLS OF COURSE IT
IS IS THAT THOUGHT TO CONTINUE
PUSHING THEM.
TOGETHER OR IS THERE A NARROWING
PROCESS AT SOME POINT.
RIGHT NOW THEY'RE THEY'RE
IDENTICAL BILLS AND WILL.
AND THEY ARE WORK RIGHT DENTICLE
THEY ARE YEAH CAM AND WE'RE
WE'RE GONNA.
RIGHT AWAY RECONCILED AT THE END
OF THE DAY WE'RE JUST IN CLOSE
WE'RE CLOSE TOUCH WITH.
ASSEMBLY SIDE AND SENATE SIDE WE
ARE ARE STAFFERS HAVE BEEN KEY
MEETINGS AND WORKING REALLY
CLOSELY TOGETHER AND HI IT'S A
IT'S A TRULY A JOINT EFFORT.
THANK YOU I I'M I'M A CO AUTHOR
THIS DOESN'T NO SURPRISE THAT I
SUPPORT THIS TODAY WHAT WE HAD A
HEARING LAST FALL IT WAS THAT
THAT THE INFORMATIONAL HEARING.
THAT THE CHAIR WOMAN AND I
SELECT COMMITTEE ON ON WASTE --
TALKED ABOUT THIS IN THE IN THE
BAY AREA AND JUSTICE IMPACT ON
PLASTICS IS IS DINO DUMB
FOUNDING TO TO THE AVERAGE.
CONSUMER AND ESPECIALLY AS
SUMMER EGGMAN TALKED ABOUT -- I
HEARD YOU TALK ABOUT THE FOR A
FEW MONTHS AGO A FEW WEEKS AGO.
IF YOU GO TO ANY SCHOOL PROJECT
NOW THE KIDS ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE ENVIRONMENT THIS IS THE
TOPIC THEY BRING UP AND YOU KNOW
EVERYONE HAS EXAMPLE THAT'S WHEN
THE SHOW YOU THIS DROWNED.
I WENT TO THAT TO THE BEACH OVER
THE HOLIDAY BREAK AND WITHIN
FIFTEEN SECONDS I WENT DOWN
THERE AND I PICKED UP THIS
HANDFUL OF MATERIALS OF PLASTICS
AND JUST TO TURN AROUND AND TELL
PEOPLE AND KIDS IN.
THIS IS RIGHT IN THIS THIS CAN'T
BE GOOD YEAH RIGHT THIS CAN'T BE
GOOD.
AND AND EVEN THE INDUSTRY HAS
MENTIONED THAT.
WERE ON THE SAME PAGE AND WANT
TO REDUCE THE AMOUNT.
OF SINGLE USED TO SCARBOROUGH
PLASTICS AND OF COURSE THERE THE
IN USE INNING UP AND WATER WAYS
WHICH COST CITIES IN
JURISDICTIONS A CLEAN UP THE
CREEK SO WE HAVE ANNUAL CLICK
CREEK.
CLEANUP HERE DURING -- DURING
THE SPRING AND THE PROJECT ISN'T
TO GO IT.
AND PULL INVASIVE SPOT WEED
SPECIES IT'S THE POORLY POLL
PLASTIC OUT OF THE CREEK OF LIKE
YOU KNOW WHAT A USE OF TIME --
SO WE WE GET THAT NEED FOR THIS
ABSOLUTELY AND I JUST WANTED TO
MAKE MAYBE IF YOU COULD DO TWO
THINGS -- ONE UNDER THE PROSPECT
THAT THERE IS SOME POTENTIAL
HOPE THIS SUMMER TALK ABOUT.
YOUR INVASION OF THIS.
TASK FORCE ENTITY -- MAYBE START
WITH THAT.
THE VISION THE VISION AT THE
SCOPING PROCESS EQUAL YOU SAID
OVER THE NEXT -- THE NEXT COUPLE
YES SO SO WHAT REALISTICALLY DO
YOU DO YOU THINK.
COULD BE ADDRESSED IN SOMEBODY'S
SO WHAT WE HAVE BEGIN -- ISSUES.
OUT THERE SO SO WE'VE WHAT WE'VE
DONE -- WE HAD A BIG MEETING IN
MY OFFICE -- WITH WITH ALSO THE
STAKEHOLDERS INDUSTRY LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
WASTE.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL -- RETAIL SIDE
MANUFACTURING AS IT WAS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INTERESTS AROUND.
PACKED THEIR IN THE ROOM.
AND THE IDEA NOW IS THAT WE'RE
GOING TO SET UP -- SMALLER.
WE'RE WE'RE BASICALLY BREAKING
UP ASPECTS OF THE BILL.
AND THEN HAVING -- SMALLER
STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS ON THOSE
VARIOUS TOPICS.
AND THAT WAY PEOPLE EITHER THEIR
THIRD YOU KNOW THERE MAY BE SOME
INDUSTRY GROUP THAT MAYBE JUST
IN ONE PARTICULAR PART OF THE
BILL THAT IS NEED TO BE THERE
FOREVER CIVIL DISCUSSION AND
THERE'S SOME OTHER FOLKS MIGHT
BE THERE FOR MORE THAN MEETINGS
OTHERS -- AND SO -- WE'RE WORD.
THAT THAT'S WHAT'S GOING THAT'S
WHAT ACTUALLY GOING TO BE
HAPPENING OVER THE NEXT. TWO
MONTHS EFFECTIVELY AND AND WE'RE
JUST GOING TO SIT DOWN THERE AND
AND TRY.
TO BANG OUT EVERY EVERY EVERY
KIND OF AREA OF CONTENTION AND
CONTROVERSY AND WE MAY NOT BE
ABLE TO SEE I HAD I HAD EVERY
ISSUE IN THE END OF THE DAY.
THIS IS A BOLD -- BUT YOU KNOW
THERE'S A BIG DEAL OF THE WEEK
WE DO WANT TO GET IT GET IT
RIGHT AND AND I WE'RE YOU KNOW
WE'RE VERY COMMITTED.
TO YOU KNOW INTENSE.
ALL HANDS ON DECK STAKEHOLDER
DISCUSSION -- SOMETIMES IT TAKES.
GETTING TOWARD THE END OF THE
LINE TO GET PEOPLE TO REALLY
START TALKING -- BUT THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO ENGAGE IN.
OKAY AND THEN -- SECONDLY.
I KNOW THAT -- IF YOU THE BILL
HAS A DATE OF TWENTY THIRTY CELL.
I LOOK I HAVE YOUR SAME JOB WE
HAVE TO THREAD A NEEDLE YET
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THIS
COMPLEX ISSUE IN IN YOU HAVE
SOME PEOPLE WHO.
WANT TO GET RID OF THIS -- TODAY
OR TOMORROW AND THEY DON'T WANT
TO WAIT TILL TWENTY THIRD --
YEAH YEAH AND THEN -- FROM THEM
YEAH IN THE INDUSTRY.
THAT -- YOU LOOK AT THE AT THE
THE WEATHER IS READILY AVAILABLE
TECHNOLOGY TO DEAL WITH SOME
ISSUES LIKE FOOD AND PROCESSING
AND CERTAIN PRODUCTS AND SO.
SO HEY HOW DO YOU HOW DO YOU
REASSURE -- BOTH SIDES THAT YOU
WERE ABLE TO ADDRESS THAT THE
GOALS.
WASTE REDUCTION AND HAVE
SOMETHING THAT'S ACHIEVABLE TO
THE INDUSTRY AND BASICALLY THE
CONSUMER SO IT'S NOT GOING TO
UPSET THE APPLE CART TOO MUCH AS
FAR AS YEAH.
WHAT CONSUMERS DO NOT TAKE BROWN
A REALLY BASIS BY FOOD BY
PRODUCTS BY?
YOU KNOW.
WHAT HAVE YOU RIGHT I MEAN
THAT'S ULTIMATELY WHY THE BILL
REALLY SEEKS TO BE FLEXIBLE YOU
KNOW IT THE? EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
EIGHT INSTEAD OF I MEAN I I I
HEARD THE COMMENTS MADE BY THE
LEGISLATING ABOUT WHAT ABOUT
MORE LEGISLATING ASIAN AND AND
MANY LIVES OF USER NO QUESTION
ABOUT IT.
BUT I HAVE I MEAN I'M SURE THE
FROM A CALL THE COMMITTEE WE
HAVE SEEN A COUPLE BILLS.
THAT HAVE BEEN VERY PRESCRIPTIVE
ABOUT THE WAY THAT WE'RE GONNA
DRESS A CERTAIN ENVIRONMENTAL
CHALLENGE.
AND VERY PRESCRIPTIVE GOING WAY
OUT IN THE FUTURE.
AND ONE OF THINGS WE STRUGGLED
WITH WHEN WE'RE LOOKING AT THOSE
BILLS WAS THE QUESTION OF WELL
YOU KNOW.
TECHNOLOGY CHANGES I MEAN YOU
WHO WOULD HAVE IMAGINED DID
TWENTY YEARS AGO WE WOULD ALL BE
WALKING AROUND WITH THE COMPUTER
IN OUR POCKETS THE SIZE OF THE?
YOU KNOW THE COMPUTER THAT
BROUGHT THE FIRST MAN TO THE
MOON -- IT THINGS CHANGE NEEDS
CHANGE OUR ISSUES CHANGE AND AND
WHAT WE WANTED TO DO WITH WITH
THIS BILL WAS PROVIDE ADEQUATE
FLEXIBILITY SO THAT.
I'VE AS THE WORLD CHANGES AND
PERHAPS DRAMATICALLY OF NEXT
FIVE TEN TWENTY YEARS THERE WILL
BE AT LEAST FIVE TO TEN YEARS --
THERE WERE THERE WILL BE YEAH --
ANY AGENCY THAT AND AND STAY IN
THIS THIS CONTINUING PROCESS
WHEREBY PEOPLE WILL BE ABLE. TO
TO RECALIBRATE AND TWEAK AND
CHANGE.
ON UNLIKE SOME OF THE OTHER
BILLS THAT HAVE COME THROUGH
THAT THAT REALLY ARE ARE SO.
THEY'RE VERY PRESCRIPTIVE AND
THEY'RE VERY MUCH BASED ON OUR
CURRENT.
THINKING ABOUT THE WAY THE WORLD
WORKS.
AND SO -- FLEXIBILITY IS THE KEY
WITH WITH KIND OF A A STRONG SET
OF OF GOALS IN MIND.
AND THAT'S THAT'S I THINK WHAT'S
AT THE HEART OF THE OF THE BILL
NOW I YOU KNOW I I THINK THAT'S
WHAT MAKES THE BILL SO STRONG I
I ALSO YOU KNOW WHAT PART OF THE
QUESTIONS WE JUST GOT TODAY.
THE FLEXIBILITY LEADS TO A
CERTAIN CONCERN OVER VAGUENESS
SORT FOR OUR LACK OF SPECIFICITY
THAT WE'VE WE'VE GRAPPLED WITH
AS THE BILL'S MAYBE MEETS WAY
THROUGH.
THE MORE SPECIFICITY WE PUT IN.
THE MOREWE MAY BE TYING THE
HANDS OF THE PROCESS IN WAYS
THAT ACTUALLY MAY BE
DISADVANTAGEOUS TO BOTH THE
BARBELL SIDE OR THE OR INDUSTRY --
AND THAT'S WHY I THINK WE'VE
BEEN A LITTLE RELUCTANT -- TO
YOU KNOW. TO TO TO TO TO TAKE
AWAY THE FLEXIBILITY MORE THAN
WE'VE WITH THEM WITH THAT WE
THAT WE NEED.
TO THAT MAKES SENSE YEAH.
THANK YOU FOR FONG.
THANK YOU AS AS A FILLING IN AYE
AYE AYE AYE BUDGET IS ALREADY
BEEN ASKED BUT I WAS WONDERING
IF -- YOU KNOW HOW MUCH IS BILL
COSTS IMPLEMENT FORCE
[inaudible] EIGHT YEAH I THINK
THE ESTIMATE OVER IN A PROBES
WITH SHOWING THREE THREE POINT.
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION --
OVER THE LIFE CYCLE.
OF THE BILL IS THE ESTIMATE THAT
WE GOT FROM APPROPRIATIONS.
THREE POINT EIGHT MILLION YEAH.
OVER THE THE A PER YEAR NO NO NO --
TOTAL [inaudible]
YEAH.
IN TOTAL THE TOTAL SO THAT'S
INCLUDING PERSONNEL COSTS AND
EVERYTHING THAT AND AND TO
EXECUTE EVERYTHING YEAH THE THE
THE CONTRACT THAT THE THE PLENTY
OF THE SCOPING PLAN THAT
[inaudible]
IMPLEMENTATION.
THANK YOU YEAH.
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
ACTUALLY JUST HAVE ONE KIND OF
FOLLOW UP WITH SOME WOMAN
EGGMAN'S QUESTION -- ON THE
SCOPING PLAN IF THAT'S NOT DONE
BY TWENTY TWENTY FOR THE FIRST
REGULATION.
IS SUPPOSED TO GO AND PUT IN
EFFECT IN JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR IF THAT PLAN IS NOT
IN PLACE DOES THAT AUTOMATICALLY
PUSH THOSE NUMBERS BACKED.
WE GET SOME CLARITY ON EXACTLY
WHAT THAT MEANS IF THE PLAN IS
NOT IN PLACE.
YEAH RIGHT YEAH I'M SO THE BILL
SAYS IT DID THIS CALL VOTE HAS
TO BE IN PLACE.
FOR THE RAGS TO KICK AND SO --
THERE'S NOT A MECHANISM FOR THEM
TO KICKING WITHOUT THE SCOPING
PLANNED PROCESS HAVING BEEN
[inaudible]
HAVEN'T FINALIZED.
SO THAT'S THAT IS IN THE BILL.
I AM NOW THE THE SHE WAS ASKING
ABOUT WHETHER THERE BE SOME SORT
OF LIKE.
GAP IN TIME AFTER THAT SCOOBY
PLAN IS FINISHED IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION.
AND THAT THE BILL DOES NOT
SPECIFY BUT BUT BUT THE THE REX
CAN'T GO INTO EFFECT IN LESS THE
SCOPING PLAN PROCESS IS COMPLETE.
WITH DISCOVERED PLANS DONE IN
DECEMBER.
AND JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
FOUR ROLLS AROUND WE TALK WE
HAVE A MONTH TIME FRAME THAT TO
PUT ALL THIS IN PLACE.
NO I MEAN THE THE THE MEMBER
MEMBER FIRST OF ALL IT'S A IT'S
A IT'S A GRADUAL IMPLEMENTATION
PLAN TOWARD.
TWENTY THIRTY ODD. TO BE TO BE
HONEST I'M SURE IF IF YOU WANT
TO SIT DOWN AND TALK SHOP ABOUT
HOW WE CAN LIKE.
IT SURE AT YOU KNOW A SMOOTHER
TIME FRAME LIKE DELINEATING THE
LOSSES HERE BECAUSE I'M I'M SURE
WE CAN WORK THIS OUT I THIS IS.
VISIT DIVERT TO THE LEAST OF MY
WORRIES PROJECT.
IT MAY BE BUT FOR OUR INDUSTRY
THE FOLK FOR THOSE OF US IN ACT
I PACKAGING IN THOSE THINK IT'S
A BIG CONCERN OF OURS IS ALSO I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS TO
WORK ON IT WILL BE IN TOUCH
HAPPY TALK ABOUT THAT THANK YOU.
WELL I WANT TO THANK YOU BRING
THIS FORWARD INTO THIS IS BEEN A
LARGE PART OF YOUR WORK IS
WORKING ON THIS BILL.
I FOR ONE APPRECIATE THE ART THE
WAY THAT YOU'RE TRYING TO TACKLE
THIS WHICH IS BY GIVING.
GOALS THAT VAN GIVE THE AGENCIES
FLEXIBILITY AS TO AND THE
INDUSTRY AS TO HOW TO ACHIEVE
THOSE GOALS RATHER THAN BEING
PRESCRIPTIVE.
IT'S THE SAME TACK THAT WAS
TAKING WITH SB THIRTY TWO AND
IT'S WORKED EXTREMELY WELL
BETTER THAN WE HAD EVER PLAN
BECAUSE IT DOES HAVE THAT
FLEXIBILITY BUILT INTO THE WAYS
THE CURSOR MATT.
I'M KIND OF LIKE -- SB THIRTY
TWO I ALSO.
LOOK AT THE IMPACTS THAT
PLASTICS HAVE HAD IN OUR
ENVIRONMENT YOU KNOW BOTH IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW TO
OUR OCEANS WHICH IS REALLY HIT
DRASTIC LEVELS AND I THINK A LOT
OF PEOPLE ARE IN DENIAL ABOUT
THE EFFECTS THAT THAT'S HAVING.
BUT THEY'RE HAVING INCREDIBLY
NEGATIVE A FAX AND IF WE DON'T
HAVE AN OCEAN WITH ON THE PLANET --
THE FACT THAT NOW THERE'S
PLASTICS DETECTABLE IN PEOPLE'S
BLOOD.
IN THE BLOOD OF UNBORN FETUSES
WITH AND WE DON'T KNOW THE
HEALTH IMPACT ABOUT EVEN THOUGH
WE KNOW PLASTICS ARE POWERFUL
ENDOCRINE DISRUPTORS WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT.
THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF AND FOOD
SAFETY WELL I WOULD ARGUE THAT
THERE'S MORE SAFETY FROM HAVING
CLASSICS AROUND FOOD THAN AROUND
NOT HAVING PLASTICS AROUND FOOD.
AND THAT'S BECOMING MORE AND
MORE CLEAR.
SO GIVEN ALL OF THOSE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS I DON'T
THINK THAT YOU CAN LOOK AT
PLASTICS IN ANY OTHER WAY THAN
AS A HAZARD HAZARDOUS PRODUCT.
AND IT'S A HAZARDOUS PRODUCT TO
OUR PLANET.
THAT HAS BEEN DUMPED INTO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
WITH THE EXPECTATION THAT IT'S
THE COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF DEALING WITH
IT.
AND RIGHT NOW WE KNOW THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE A HUGE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF HAVING TO
DEAL WITH THE WITH THE PLASTICS
THAT COME INTO THE COMMUNITY.
BECAUSE SO FAR THE MANUFACTURERS
IN THE INDUSTRY HAS REALLY DONE
VERY LITTLE. TO HELP OFFSET THE
INCREDIBLE EXPENSE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE IN.
THE FACT OR TAXPAYERS HAVE AS
THEY PAY FOR THEIRS THERE WERE
THERE.
ARE TRASH.
FEES WHICH NOW WE'RE GOING TO GO
UP AND UP AND UP BECAUSE THEY
HAVE TO DEAL WITH THIS TOXIC
MATERIAL AND DEAL WITH TRYING TO
KEEP IT OUT OF THE WATER WAYS IN
THOSE OF US WHO WORK.
ON RIVERS AND HAVE STORM DRAINS
THAT DRAIN INTO THE OCEAN OUR
PERSONALLY HAVING YOU KNOW THE
THE CITIES HAVE TO PAY FOR THAT.
AND THE COMMUNITIES HAVE TO PAY
FOR THE CLEAN UP IN THE IMPACT
OF LITTER SO THERE'S BEEN
TREMENDOUS IMPACTS.
AND THE INDUSTRY HAS HAD MANY
YEARS TO DEAL WITH THIS THEY'VE
HAD.
DOT YOU KNOW DOZENS AND DOZENS
OF YEARS AND YET WE HAVEN'T SEEN
ANY REAL MEANING.
FOR MOVEMENT IN FACT IT'S GONE
THE OTHER DIRECTION AS ASIAN
DOESN'T WANT PLASTICS DUMPED ON
THEM.
WE'RE SEEING AN INCREASE IN THE
AMOUNT OF PLASTICS THAT ARE
COMING INTO THE ENVIRONMENT MY
GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE MORE
MORE PLASTICS BEING FORCED ON ME
AS A CONSUMER OF FOOD OR OTHER
PRODUCTS.
WHEN WE GET OUR LITTLE PINS YOU
KNOW THAT WE GET ALL THE TIME UP
HERE FROM DIFFERENT GROUPS THERE
MORE MORE THEY'RE WRAPPED IN
PLASTIC FOR SOME UNKNOWN REASON?
SO I DON'T SEE AN INDUSTRY
THAT'S TAKEN MUCH RESPONSIBILITY%
BUT I SEE THESE INCREDIBLY
HARMFUL EFFECTS OF THIS PRODUCT
WE DIDN'T ASK WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT WE DON'T ASK THE COAL
INDUSTRY TO BE AT THE TABLE WITH
US WITH AT WITH SB.
THIRTY TWO WE SAID THESE AREGOALS USUALLY THE VALUES OF
CALIFORNIA THIS IS WHAT WE HAVE
TO DO TO PROTECT OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN.
AND YOU GUYS GO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO ACHIEVE THAT AND ASKING THEM
TO TAKE THE RESPONSIBILITY AND
CREATE A CIRCULAR ECONOMY TO
REDUCE WASTE IN A MEANINGFUL WAY.
NOT JUST GIVE US PRODUCTS THAT
ARE.
CONCEPTUALLY RECYCLABLE IN OUR
LABORATORY BUT SAYING WE WANT
THOSE PRODUCTS TO BE RECYCLED
PRODUCTS SO THAT WE KNOW THAT
IT'S SUSTAINABLE OR ELSE YOU
CAN'T SELL THEM IN OUR STATE.
AND THAT'S THE GOALS THAT WE
SHOULD BE SETTING BECAUSE THAT'S
WHAT OUR COMMUNITIES DESERVE AND
THEN THERE THE MANUFACTURERS YOU
GUYS GO FIGURE IT OUT WITH CAL
RECYCLABLE WE CAN'T BE SITTING
UP HERE IN FIGURING THAT OUT.
BUT THE TRADE OFF IS IF WE DON'T
DO IT LARA READY IN A CRISIS.
YOU KNOW MY DAUGHTER SIX YEARS
OLD ARE YOU TELLING ME THAT
SHE'S SUPPOSED TO FIGURE THIS
OUT TEN TWENTY YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD.
NO WE HAVE TO FIGURE THIS OUT
NOW AND YOU HAVE TO BE AT THE
TABLE FINANCIALLY AND EVERY
OTHER WAY BECAUSE YOU'VE DONE TO
HARMFUL PRODUCT.
INTO ONTO OUR PLANET.
AND WE'RE TO CRISIS LEVEL SO I
DON'T THINK WE CAN PASS THIS
FAST ENOUGH DEVELOP THE
REGULATIONS FAST ENOUGH I WORRY
THAT THIS IS TOO LITTLE TOO LATE.
SO I'M NOT INTERESTED IN YOU
WORKING WITH THEM TO GET TO
WHERE THEY'RE SATISFIED WITH
THIS BILL OR FINDING A WAY FOR
CAL RECYCLE TO GIVE LESS.
MINIMUM CONTENT IN THESE
PRODUCTS I'M NOT INTERESTED IN
THAT BUT I DON'T THINK THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES DESERVE THAT THEY
DESERVE A LOT BETTER.
SO DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED WOULD
YOU.
WE NEED A SECOND FROM SOMEONE.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK YOU DID A GREAT JOB
MANAGER.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE YOUR
COMMENTS AND AND I MEAN YOU I
THINK YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE
HEAD AND YOU THE DAY.
ALL THE STUFF WE TALKED ABOUT
THE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
IMPLEMENTATION WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT FEASIBILITY WORKABILITY --
BUT A NEW DAY WE'VE GOT AN
ENORMOUS CRISIS ON OUR HANDS I
APPRECIATE YOU BRING US BACK TO
THE THE REASONS WHY WE'RE HERE
IN THE FIRST PLACE -- AND THAT'S
FOR YOU KNOW YOUR DAUGHTER MY
SIGN IN AND AND AND AND AND AND
ENSURING THAT WE HAVE THAT WE
GIVE THEM A SHOT.
AT AT CUT BEING ABLE.
TO ADDRESS THIS ENORMOUS
INFRASTRUCTURAL.
AND TOXIC PROBLEM THAT WE HAVE.
AND AT AT THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT STEP TOWARD ADDRESSING
A GLOBAL PROBLEM AND I HOPE THAT
WILL BE REALLY PROUD OF WHAT WE
DO HERE TODAY.
THANK YOU AND HAVE A WE HAVE A
MOTION ALL SECOND IT.
WE ROLL CALL.
ITEM FIVE SB FIFTY FOUR BY
SENATOR ALLEN THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
FONG.
FONG NO GARCIA.
GARCIA I LOW MOAN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
RIGHT SURGERY.
STONE.
SO. NINE THREE THREE THREE THREE
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU.
MR GLORIA YOU'VE BEEN EXTREMELY
PATIENT [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
OR YOU KNOW.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY -- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR THEY FOR
ALLOW ME PRESENT ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION NUMBER SEVEN TODAY.
AGE ARE SEVEN URGES CONGRESS TO
PURSUE POLICIES UNDER THE GREEN
NEW DEAL THE BUILT ON
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE ACTIONS AND
FOCUS ON PROVIDING BENEFITS TO
ALL COMMUNITIES.
ESPECIALLY THOSE THE MOST
ECONOMICALLY AND ENVIRONMENTALLY
VULNERABLE.
SAYING CALIFORNIA WE KNOW AND
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A REAL
EMERGENCY AND WE MUST ADDRESS.
THE BILL.
EXCEPT WE ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE --
IT WITH ME -- THIS AFTERNOON IS
A OUT ADAM VEGA ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIANS FOR PESTICIDE
BEFORE THANK YOU -- GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS OF ONE OF FIRST TAKE A
MOMENT RECOGNIZE AND HONOR THE
INDIGENOUS I MIGHT DO PEOPLE THE
ORIGINAL STEWARDS OF THIS
BEAUTIFUL AND IT BRINGS ME GREAT
JOY TO BE HERE WITH YOU ALL
TODAY -- ADAM BAGO ORGANIZED
WITH CALIFORNIA THAT'S RIGHT
REFORM COORDINATOR FOR THE
VENTURA COUNTY COALITION OUT
BECAME FAST THAT SAFETY.
SERVE ON THE BOARD OF THE
ABUNDANT TABLE A FIVE ACRE
CERTIFIED ORGANIC COMMUNITY
SUPPORT AGRICULTURAL FARM OR
GROW HEALTHY FOOD IN COMMITTEE
ALIKE -- I SERVE ON THE BOARD OF
THE CENTRAL COAST LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND I'M THE
VICE CHAIR OF THE IT'S GONNA LET
YOU KNOW CAUCUS OF THE
CALIFORNIA DEMOCRATIC PARTY
REGION.
FIVE WHICH IS OF COURSE AS WE
KNOW INDIGENOUS TO MATCH LAND I
SUPPORT ASSEMBLY JOINT
RESOLUTION SEVEN IN THE GREEN
YOU DEAL AS THERE'S NOTHING MORE
EXCITING THAN AN IDEA WHOSE TIME
HAS FINALLY COME.
AMONG THE GROUPS OF PEOPLE MOST
IMPACTED BY CLIMATE CHANGE OUR
FARMERS AND FARM WORKING
COMMUNITIES COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE MUSIC WERE DIRECTLY
IMPACTED BY THE THOMAS AND WAS
THE FIRES.
OF INTER IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
FARMERS AND FARM WORKERS ARE AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF THE SOLUTION.
THE INDIGENOUS KNOWLEDGE OF OUR
ECOLOGICAL ADDRESS ALLOWS US TO
REMAIN RESILIENT IN THE FACE OF
CLIMATE CHAOS BECAUSE WE ARE
WORKING WITH NATURE AND NOT
AGAINST IT.
WE WANT TO BUILD UPON THIS
KNOWLEDGE AND SHARE IT WITH
OTHERS WERE SOLVING PLANETARY
LEVEL PROBLEMS BY INCREASING OUR
SOILS WATER AND CARBON CAPTURING
CAPACITY.
THE REGENERATIVE FORMS OF
AGRICULTURE AND THE APPLICATION
OF INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT --
AND I PM APPROACH WHICH IS
PREFERRED METHOD OF SCIENTISTS
REGULATORS AND PRACTITIONERS
ALIKE -- HISTORICALLY LARGE
FINANCIAL INSTITUTION ON VETS
MINUTES BEEN DEDICATED TO
ANSWERING THE QUESTION OF
FEEDING A FUTURE WITH A MUCH
LARGER POPULATION BUT HAVING
LESS.
LAND IN ORDER TO DO SO THIS IS
WHY WE NEED THE HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN CONGRESS TO PURSUE
POLICIES UNDER THE GREEN YOU
DEAL THE BILL THE FINE
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE ACTIONS FOR
TOO LONG.
OUR CURRENT CONVENTIONAL SYSTEM
OF FOOD AND FIBER PRODUCTION HAS
BEEN THE ANSWER PETROCHEMICAL
BASED PESTICIDES AND FERTILIZERS
RELEASE HARMFUL LEVELS
GREENHOUSE GASES THAT CONTAINED
CONTAMINATE THE AIR WATER AND
SOIL OVER PLANTS PEOPLE ON
PLANET.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IS AN EXTRACT
OF ONE WE MIND THE SOIL FOR
NUTRIENTS WE DON'T NEED TO LOOK
FARFOR THE SOLUTION WE NEED TO
LOOK DOWN THE SOLUTION IS RIGHT
UNDER FEET.
IN THIS CASE SEVERAL FEET --
THIS WAS A SOLUTION OVER 90% OF
THE FOOD WE EAT COME FROM IT SO
IF YOU EAT YOUR IN YOU GET IT.
HUNDREDS OF RURAL DEVELOPMENT
AGRICULTURAL EXPERTS LONG WITH
SIX IN A NATIONAL BODIES CONVENE
BY THE WORLD BANK CONFIRM THIS
THEY CONCLUDE THAT ARE
EXTRACTIVE PATRICK CHEMICAL
SYSTEM OF FARMING IS NO LONGER
SUSTAINABLE.
THERE IS AMPLE EVIDENCE THAT
MORE BIODIVERSE REGENERATIVE
LOCALLY FOCUS FARMING SYSTEMS
ARE ACTUALLY MORE PRODUCTIVE PER
UNIT -- THESE ARE SYSTEMS THAT
CAN TRULY SEE THE WORLD.
ASSEMBLY JOINT RESOLUTION SEVEN
WILL CONTINUE TO BUILD UPON WHAT
THE STATE IS ALREADY DOING
CALIFORNIA'S IMPLEMENTED A
NUMBER OF INNOVATIVE PROGRAMS
SUCH AS A HEALTHY SOLD PROGRAM
WHICH WE AT THE BEEN TAPE WERE
TAKING PART IN.
OTHER EXAMPLES ARE SALK SWEEP AB
SIX SEVENTEEN BY SUPPORTING THIS
RESOLUTION WE CAN CONTINUE TO
RESTORE OUR NATURAL RESOURCE
BASE WELL GROWING HEALTHY
NUTRIENT DENSE FOOD IN THE SAME
PLACE AT THE SAME TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GREEN NEW
DEAL GND GOOD FOR YOU GOOD FOR
ME THANK YOU.
THAT'S A GREAT ENDING THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE RESOLUTION.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
BEST SMOKER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
PUT IN FROM THE NETWORK IN
SUPPORT.
TARDELLI WITH THREE FIFTY BAY
AREA ACTION IN SUPPORT STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE KID ACCORDING TO THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
BRENT AND ALSO THERE KEL
CALIFORNIANS.
REBEKAH MARKETS REPRESENTING
PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
FOUNDATION AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
WISHING TO VOICE OPPOSITION TO
THE RESOLUTION.
OR CONCERNS ABOUT THE RESOLUTION.
OKAY WITHOUT WILL MOVE UP TO THE
DíAS ANY COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
OKAY SINGH NANDA WE HAVE A
MOTION -- I'M SORRY I BEG YOUR
PARDON WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU CAN HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
ITEM ONE HR SEVEN BY SENATOR
GLORIA THE MOTION IS BE ADOPTED
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA NO CHILD.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG NO GARCIA.
GARCIA ISLA MON.
Là MON I MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
WHERE?
THIRTY STONE.
SO. NINE FIVE TWO FIVE TWO TWO
WILL LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TAKING A CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS [inaudible]
SENATOR LABOR [inaudible]
WELCOME.
YOU ARE HERE WITH SB TWO TEN I
AM.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR TO YOU AND
YOUR COMMITTEE FOR ALL OF YOUR
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT BILL IS
MUCH APPRECIATED.
MEMBERS SB TWO TEN ESTABLISHES A
SMOG CHECK REQUIREMENT FOR
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THIS BILL WILL APPLY SIMILAR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO TRUCK
OPERATORS TO MAINTAIN THEIR
EMISSION CONTROLS AS WE ALREADY
REQUIRE OF THE CALLER CARS THAT
WE ALL DRIVE EVERY DAY.
UNLIKE PERSONAL PASSENGER
VEHICLES CURRENT LAW DOES NOT
REQUIRE HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS EVERY
OTHER SMOG CHECKS TO ENSURE THAT
THERE ARE MISSION CONTROL
SYSTEMS ARE WORKING PROPERLY
DRIVE ACROSS CALIFORNIA ROADS
ANNUALLY.
AND ARE MAJOR CONTRIBUTORS TO
THE STATE'S POOR AIR QUALITY.
STATEWIDE NEARLY TWELVE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS LIVING COMMUNITIES
THAT FAIL TO MEET FEDERAL CLEAN
AIR STANDARDS HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS
OPERATING CALIFORNIA ACCOUNT FOR
NEARLY 60%.
OF THE HARMFUL KNOCKS 82% OF
DIESEL PM TO FIVE A POTENTIALLY
CAUGHT CANCER CAUSING AIR
CONTAMINANT.
MEMBERS THIRTY YEAR COST
CALIFORNIA OVER TWENTY BILLION
AND HOSPITALIZATIONS VISITS TO
EMERGENCY ROOMS AND CHRONIC
ILLNESSES THE CONSEQUENCES ARE
MUCH WORSE IN CERTAIN REGIONS
ACROSS THE STATE.
LIKE THE INLAND EMPIRE AND THE
CENTRAL VALLEY WHICH ARE GREATLY
AFFECTED BY LARGE TRUCK TRAFFIC
IN CONGESTED FREEWAYS.
DESPITE THE INVESTMENTS WE HAVE
MADE TO SUPPORT A TRANSITION.
TWO ZERO AND NEAR ZERO EMISSION
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES DIESEL
TRUCKS WILL CONTINUE TO OPERATE
ON OUR ROADS FOR DECADES TO COME
WE HAVE TO TAKE THE BOLD STEP OF
MAKING SURE THAT THEY MAINTAIN
THEIR MISSION CONTROLS.
THROUGHOUT THE TRUCKS LIFESPAN
THIS SECTION ALONE WILL PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT AIR QUALITY AND
PUBLIC HEALTH BENEFITS.
OVER THE NEXT DECADE SB TWO TEN
WILL ASSIST IN THE REMOVAL OF
SIXTEEN HUNDRED TONS OF HARMFUL
PARTICULATE MATTER EQUIVALENT TO
TAKING THREE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND TRUCKS.
OFF THE ROAD NOT ONLY WILL SB
TWO TEN HELP INSURE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND AIR QUALITY IT WILL
ALSO IMPROVE THE LIFE EXPECTANCY
OF HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS.
AS BECAUSE THEY BECOME MORE
FREQUENTLY MAINTAINED THIS BILL
ALSO APPLIES TO OUT OF STATE
TRUCKS I WILL HELP LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD FOR A LAW ABIDING
CALIFORNIA TRUCK OWNERS AND
OPERATORS.
SIMPLY PUT TO TEN WILL BE A WIN
WIN FOR CALIFORNIA INDUSTRIES
AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS I'VE
WORKED DILIGENTLY WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO BRING FORWARD A
BALANCED MAJOR THE ADVANCES
CLEAN AIR AND CORPORATE INDUSTRY
INPUT.
WITH THE MOST RECENT AMENDMENTS
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS HAVE MOVED
TO NEUTRAL INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA TRUCKING ASSOCIATION
ORGANIZATIONS LIKE THE
AND CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU HAVE
BEEN ACTIVELY ENGAGED ON THIS
ISSUE OF SHARED IMPORTANCE.
AS THEY TOO WANT THE STATE TO
FAIRLY ENFORCE VEHICLE STANDARDS
ANIMATION LAWS.
I REMAIN COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY AND CLEAR CLEAN
AIR ADVOCATES IN ORDER TO CREATE
A BALANCED AND SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM.
THIS INCLUDES WORKING TO ENSURE
THAT VEHICLES HAVE A REASONABLE
AND COST EFFECTIVE PATH TOWARDS
COMPLIANCE SB TWO TEN IS
SUPPORTED BY DOZENS OF IMAC FIRE
MENTAL HEALTH AND CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION ORGANIZATIONS.
HERE WITH ME TODAY BILL MCGOVERN
POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
COALITION OF CLEAN AIR AND
MEREDITH ALEXANDER POLICY
DIRECTOR FOR CAL START
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MANAGER MEMBERS ON BILL THE
GOVERNMENT CALLS FOR CLEAN AIR
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH CENTER
LEYVA ON THIS BILL FOR ABOUT TWO
AND A HALF YEARS NOW BECAUSE OF
ITS IMPORTANCE TO AIR QUALITY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH.
AND I AM SURE THE VAST MAJORITY
OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS WOULD
ACTUALLY BE SHOCKED TO FIND OUT
THAT THERE IS NO.
CURRENTLY SMOG CHECK PROGRAM FOR
HEAVY DUTY TRUCKS THE WAY THAT
THERE IS FOR CARS AND LIGHT
TRUCKS BECAUSE ACTUALLY.
MORE THE POLLUTION COMES FROM
THOSE TRUCKS THAN IT DOES FROM
THE CARS YET WE REQUIRE CARS
WHEN THEY REACH A CERTAIN AGE TO
GO IN AND GET SMOG BUT THERE IS
NO COMPREHENSIVE INSPECTION AND
MAINTENANCE PROGRAM. FOR HEAVY
DUTY TRUCKS RUNNING ON DIESEL
FUEL AND THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
INSPECTION MAINTENANCE IS THAT
TESTS HAVE SHOWN THAT.
A LOT OF THESE TRUCKS ARE
ACTUALLY HAVING EMISSIONS THAT
ARE SEVERAL TIMES HIGHER THAN
THE EMISSIONS THAT THE ENGINES
ARE CERTIFIED.
TO SO IT'S ONE THING TO HAVE A
TRUCK A BE REQUIRED TO HAVE AN
ENGINE OF A CERTAIN VINTAGE TO
HAVE A DIESEL PARTICULATE FILTER
BUT IT'S ANOTHER TO ACTUALLY GO
IN AND CHECK AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE EMISSIONS ARE WHAT THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE.
AND THE MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION HAS BEEN CLAIMING
THAT THEY'RE ALREADY REGULATED
FOR THIS PURPOSE WELL THEY'RE
NOT THEY DON'T HAVE AN
INSPECTION MAINTENANCE PROGRAM --
NOBODY DOES CURRENTLY BEYOND THE
CHECK FOR VISIBLE SMOKE.
SO THIS IS SOMETHING THAT IS
ACTUALLY ALREADY PART OF THE
STATE'S PLAN FOR COMING INTO
ATTAINMENT WITH FEDERAL AIR
QUALITY GUIDELINES -- IT'S
IMPORTANT TO CLEAN UP THE SMOG
IN PARTICULAR POLLUTION THAT WE
CONTINUE TO SUFFER FROM AROUND
THE STATE THERE'S A LOT WE NEED
TO DO TO CLEAN UP DIESEL
POLLUTION.
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT PIECE AND
PROBABLY THE LONGEST OVERDUE
PIECE SO -- WE THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING AND HOPE THAT YOU'LL
PROVE THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR FRIEDMAN
THE MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MEREDITH ALEXANDER AND
I'M HERE AND THE POLICY DIRECTOR
CAL STAR.
CAL START AS A CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION TECHNOLOGY
CONSORTIUM FOCUSED ON GROWING
THE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY AND OUR MEMBERS INCLUDE
TWO HUNDRED BUSINESS -- TWO
HUNDRED MEMBERS INCLUDING FLEET
SUCH AS UPS AND FEDEX LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER NON
PROFITS.
SO MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY
VEHICLES AS YOU KNOW ARE THE
BACKBONE OF OUR FREIGHT SYSTEM
WHICH IS A MAJOR ENGINE FOR OUR
STATE'S ECONOMY HOWEVER THERE
THEY ALSO LIMITED
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
CRITERIA POLLUTANTS AND
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS.
OUR MEMBERS WERE CONFIDENT
MAINTAIN THEIR FLEETS
RESPONSIBLY TO ENSURE THEIR IN
COMPLIANCE WITH APPLICABLE LAWS
HOWEVER SOME FLEETS ARE GROSS
POLLUTERS TO THE DETRIMENT OF
OUR COMMUNITIES HEALTH.
AND IT'S ACTUALLY CURRENT
CREATES A COMPETITIVE
DISADVANTAGE FOR THE FLEET TO
HAVE RESPONSIBLE WELL MAINTAINED
EQUIPMENT.
THE CURRENT LACK OF SMOG CHECKS
EQUATES TO AN UNFAIR TAX ON
THOSE RESPONSIBLE BUSINESSES AN
UNFAIR TAX ON OUR COMMUNITY
MEMBERS LONGS.
SB TWO TEVIN WILL LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD ACROSS COMMERCIAL
TRUCK OPERATORS BY ENSURING THAT
EVERYONE IS HELD TO THESAME
STANDARD.
AND THIS WOULD ACTUALLY HELP
MANY FLEETS BY STOPPING THOSE
LOWER AND OPERATORS -- FROM
UNDER CUTTING MORE PROFESSIONAL
MORE WELL MAINTAINED OPERATIONS.
THIS BILL IS DONE IN A SENSIBLE
WAY AND IS MEANT TO BE A LIGHT
TOUCH SYSTEM EVEN LIGHTER TOUCH
THAN OUR CURRENT VEHICLE SMOG
CHECKS.
IMPORTANTLY IT SENDS OUT A
STREAMLINED PROCESS FOR FLEETS
THAT HAVING A STEP ESTABLISH
COMPLIANCE HISTORY WHICH
ADDRESSES SOME OF THE OTHER
CONCERNS REGARDING THE BILL.
AND OBVIOUSLY CAR WOULD
ULTIMATELY HAVE TO DETERMINE THE
DETAILS AND PROCESS THROUGH A
FULL RULE MAKING WITH FULL
STAKEHOLDER PARTICIPATION.
SO NO FLEET OPERATORS SHOULD BE
ALLOWED TO CIRCUMVENT STATE
VEHICLE EMISSION STANDARDS AND
SB TWO TEN WILL ENSURE PARITY
ACROSS ALL INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS.
AND IN SOME THE BILL PROVIDES
VERY WORKABLE APPROACH TO
TAMPING DOWN ON GROSS POLLUTERS
WHILE AVOIDING UNNECESSARY RED
TAPE. FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHERS WITNESS OTHERS
INTERESTED IN TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
FRIEND ALSO SIERRA CALIFORNIA
SUPPORT.
JUST KNOWN FOR SERIES AND WAS
THE ENVIRONMENT HEALTH DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION.
NATALIE KNOCK SOME HAVE A BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
SUPPORT.
NIKITA KARATE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
RUSS BUT THE ON BEHALF OF ST
BERKELEY OKAY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY AND THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT.
I LANDED ON ON BEHALF OF NEXT
AND CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
RIVER NOW ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT.
JOSIAH YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE
BIO ENERGY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND ALSO THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
TARDELLI ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY BAY AREA AND THREE FIFTY
RIVERSIDE AND SUPPORT.
JIM WHEN BURKE FOR THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
YES MY FROM BATH THE DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE IN SUPPORT.
JASMINE JOHNSON REGISTERING FOR
SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA BERMAN
JUSTICE ALLIANCE THINK.
BILL ALLEY -- FOR THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP AND
ALSO ON BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
PREDATORS YOU WITH VALLEY
CLEANER NOW IN SUPPORT.
CAROLE WADE WITH SUSTAINABLE
ROSS MORE SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER WITH ALSO
FREE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
JANET CARTS FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WITNESSES AN OFFICER
IN OPPOSITION PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON NO -- CREAMERS OF
THE CAL CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION.
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THIS BILL AND
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT WE'RE NOT
OPPOSED TO THE CONCEPT OF THE
BILL WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE.
PARAMETERS IN PLACE THAT WILL
ALLOW.
THE TRUCKS THAT AGRICULTURAL.
THAT OUR AGRICULTURAL COMMUNITY
DID DEPEND UPON TO REMAIN
AVAILABLE.
AND SO WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN IN
THE TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE
WHICH PROVIDE.
TRUCKS USED EXCLUSIVELY IN
AGRICULTURE TO HAVE SEVENTY FIVE
DAYS FOR REPAIRS SO WHAT COULD
HAPPEN IS.
A TRUCK HAULING TOMATO SAY IF
THAT CHECK ENGINE LIGHT COMES IN
COMES ON AT THE VERY BEGINNING
OF THE TOMATO HARVEST.
UNDER THE FORTY FIVE DAY
REQUIREMENT GIVEN THE LENGTH OF
TIME THIS IS THAT IT HITS TAKING
TO GET REPAIRS RIGHT NOW.
THEY WOULD HAVE TO BE PULLED
FROM USE AND THAT TRUCK WOULD
NOT BE AVAILABLE TO HELP HARVEST
THOSE TOMATOES.
SO THE SEVENTY FIVE DAYS WILL
MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA
PRODUCTS AREN'T LEFT ROTTING IN
THE FIELDS ULTIMATELY SO WE
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SEVENTY
FIVE DAY LENGTH FOR THAT.
THE ONE REMAINING ISSUE THAT WE
HAVE IS HOW DO WE DEAL WITH
TRUCKS THAT ARE.
COMPLYING WITH THE TRUCK AND BUS
RULE UNDER THE LOW USE
PROVISIONS OF THE DRIVING UNDER
THOUSAND MILES OR THOSE THAT ARE
LICENSED A SPECIAL EQUIPMENT.
BOTH OF THOSE IF THEY ARE FORCED.
TO DRIVE THOSE TRUCKS TO A
FACILITY TO GET TESTEDCOULD BE
IN VIOLATION OF THEIR SPECIAL
EQUIPMENT LICENSE AND
REGISTRATION OR THEY COULD.
NO LONGER BE COMPLIANT WITH THE
TRUCK AND BUS ROLE BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOW DRIVING OVER A
THOUSAND MILES AND SO UP WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR TO TRY TO FIND A SOLUTION
TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE TRUCKS.
I'M CAN GET TESTED ON SITE
RATHER THAN HAVING TO DRIVE
THOSE VEHICLES -- AND ONCE THAT
AMENDMENT IS TAKEN AND WE COULD
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION CAN I
WOULD JUST SAY THAT'S OUR GOAL
TO IS TO DO ON SITE TESTING.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
A FAD THAT MIGHT THAT MIGHT JUST
NEGATE ANYTHING I SAY RIGHT
THERE -- THE MICROBES YEAR ON
BEHALF THE COVERING USUALLY
CHILES ASSOCIATION REALLY --
MAIN THING ONE USE CLARIFY FOR
THE SIERRA CLUB WHAT WHAT WE'VE
BEEN SAYING AND IF I HAVEN'T
BEEN SAYING IT CORRECTLY AND
OTHER HEARINGS I APOLOGIZE.
THE MUNICIPAL UTILITIES.
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES ARE
REGULATED BY CAR RIGHT NOW UNDER
SOMETHING CALLED THE FLEET
REGULATION FOR PUBLIC UTILITIES
AND LOCAL AGENCIES I HAVEN'T MET
TO INFER THAT THAT MEANS THAT
THEY RARELY GET REGULATED TO THE
SAME RIGOROUS -- SMOG CHECK
PROGRAM AS PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
BUT THEY ARE REGULATED IN AND
AND THEIR WILLINGLY REGULATED
AND THEY DO -- PATSY TESTING ON
SITE WHICH IS SOMETHING WE'VE
BEEN WANTING -- IN THIS BILLS TO
ALLOW THE PUBLIC UTILITIES TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE ON SITE TESTING
BY THEIR POPE BY THEIR EMPLOYEES
AND USING WHATEVER EQUIPMENT IS
NEEDED TO DO THAT IS IT'S
DETERMINED BY CARBON THEIR SMOG
CHECK FOR IN THIS NEW SMOG CHECK
PROGRAM.
THAT'S THE MAIN AMEND THAT WE'VE
BEEN SEEKING IN IN THIS BILL
THERE'S SOME OTHER THINGS THAT
WE BROUGHT UP ANOTHER COMMITTEE
HEARINGS THE CAN GET CLARIFIED
PROBABLY MORE LIKELY IN THE
FISCAL COMMITTEE ON DEALING
MAKING SURE THAT -- FEES ARE
BEING PAID BY OUT OF STATE TRUCK
DRIVERS AND THAT WE'RE NOT
SUBSIDIZING THE COMPLIANCE COSTS
ABOUT STATE TRUCK DRIVERS BUT
OTHERWISE I THINK -- THE AUTHORS
COVERED MY CONCERN THANK YOU
WE'RE GETTING THERE.
THANK YOU -- ANYONE ELSE WHO --
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
OF THE BILL.
JUST A TWEENER HERE I HAVEN'T
MET ROOM WITH COPPER TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION -- WE WOULD JUST
LIKE TO SAY WE APPRECIATE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN TAKEN
TO TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE WE
BELIEVE THAT GOES A LONG WAY TO
ENSURING THAT THERE'S PROPER --
OVERSIGHT OVER THE PROGRAM AND
THAT THE AUTHORITY REMAINS WITH
THE LEGISLATURE NOT DELEGATED TO
THE AGENCY THANK.
JOHN WINGER ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA FEELS INCONVENIENCE
ALLIANCE WE REPRESENT 95%.
OF THE FUEL MARKETERS AND COMMON
CARRIERS THAT DELIVER FUEL IN
THE STATE -- DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK THAT'S
GONE INTO THE BILL AND SOME OF
THE ADDITIONAL LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT THAT'S BEEN PUT INTO
THE BILL.
I THINK GIVEN OUR PAST
EXPERIENCES WITH CAR WOULD LIKE
TO SEE SOME MORE -- LEGISLATIVE
AUTHORITY TAKEN PRIOR TO THE
OFFICIAL PROGRAM GOING INTO
PLACE AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS
REMAIN OPPOSED THANKS.
YES THE RIVER IN CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
PERIMENOPAUSE LISTEN AMENDED FOR
THE REASONS OUTLINED BY MY
COLLEAGUE AT THE FARM BUREAU.
ANTHONY CAN HELP CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING SPECIAL DISTRICTS
WHICH ARE PUBLIC AGENCIES.
OPPOSE UNLESS A MAN AND A LINE
OUR COMMENTS WITH IN IN
MUNICIPAL UTILITIES ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING KURT BLACK AND I
HAVE THE WESTERN STATES TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
ALL RIGHT SIGNAL TO GET UP TO
THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EGGMAN.
THANK YOU SO THAT THOSE ARE SOME
MY CONCERNS YES AS A SOMEBODY
WHO STAND.
TRY TO AVOID THOSE CHECKPOINTS
AS MUCH AS HE COULD WE DON'T
WANT WE DON'T WANT A WHOLE
SYSTEM WHERE PEOPLE ARE JUST
TRYING -- TO DOING ALL THE TIME
AVOIDING THINGS THAT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU ARE WORKING WE OPPOSITION
AND YOU ARE DETERMINED. TO GET
THERE BUT BEFORE IT GETS TO THE
FLOOR YES WE REALLY ARE AND WE
YOU KNOW CARP WILL THEY WANT
ALSO TO HAVE THESE MOBILE
TESTING UNITS.
SO WE JUST DON'T HAVE ALL OF THE
THE DETAILS BUT THAT'S
EVERYONE'S GOAL.
WITH THAT I I WILL MOVE THE BALL
AND MEN.
LOOKS LIKE IT'S SUPPOSED TO WHEN
I GUESS THE FLOOR THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT [inaudible]
ANYONE ELSE.
I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION -- IT HAS
TO DO WITH US SEVENTY TWO DAY --
FIX IT ENFORCEMENT SEVENTY TWO
OR SEVENTY FIVE SEVENTY SORRY
SEVENTY FIVE DAY FIX THE TICKET
SO.
DOES THAT MEAN THAT YOU I DIDN'T
SEE IN THE BILL ANYTHING THAT
LIMITS THE AMOUNT OF FIX THE
TICKETS THAT CAN BE ISSUED SO IF.
AN AG USER FOR INSTANCE GETS
THEIR FIX A TICKET THEY GET
THROUGH THE SEASON THEY HARVEST
THEIR TOMATOES DOES THAT MEAN
THAT NEXT YEAR THEY CAN JUST ASK
FOR ANOTHER FIX THE TICKET.
HOW DO YOU ADDRESS KIND OF IS
THERE SOME POINT AT WHICH THEY
HAVE TO FIX IT THIS IS A GREAT
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW IF THE
BILL OUTLINES THAT EXACTLY I
WILL LOOK TO ANY HELP THAT --
ANYWAY GIVE ME BUT WHAT I'M
THINKING IS THAT YOU HAVE THESE
TRUCKS HAVE TO BE CERTIFIED
EVERY YEAR SO IF THEY ARE NOT
CERTIFIED AND THEY'D GO OVER
THERE SEVENTY FIVE DAYS.
IT IS GOING TO BE CAUGHT THE
NEXT TIME THEY GO TO GET THE
SORT OF THE OPERATORS -- PERMIT.
BUT I JUST WANT TO SUGGEST THAT
YOU ADD SOME CLARITY THAT MAYBE
THEIR LIMITED EACH VEHICLE TO
YOU KNOW ONE OR TWO OR SOMETHING
IN A CERTAIN PERIOD OF TIME JUST
AS YOU MOVE FORWARD AND I I
UNDERSTAND THAT THEY'LL BE
REGULATION SETTING AS YOU MOVE
FORWARD BECAUSE I WAS.
JUST A CONCERN AND APPARENTLY
WE'RE WORKING WITH C. H. P. ON
THIS SO I'M HAPPY TO ADDRESS
THAT GREAT THING I WILL SAY I I
I APPRECIATE YOU BRING THIS
FORWARD IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I'M
REALLY GLAD THAT THE
STAKEHOLDERS ARE AT THE TABLE
AND THAT PEOPLE ARE SORT OF
MOVING.
TOWARDS A PLACE OF OF MAKING IT
WORKABLE FOR EVERYBODY AND AND
DRESSING THE CONCERNS I WILL
JUST SAY AS A SIDE THAT I'M NOT.
NECESSARILY CONVINCED THAT.
AGRICULTURAL TRUCKERS YOU KNOW
OUR SORT OF SPECIAL OVER A SMALL
INDEPENDENT OPERATOR LET'S SAY
WHO STILL MIGHT NEED TO GET FOOD
OUT OF A PROCESSING PLANT BEFORE
THE FOOD GOES BAD -- AND SOME OF
THAT AGRICULTURAL FLEETS YOU
KNOW CAN HAVE A HUNDRED TRUCKS
IN THEM -- YOU KNOW AS OPPOSED
TO SOMEONE WORKING OUT OF THE
PORTS MAYBE IT'S ONE PERSON WITH
ONE TRUCK AND THEY'RE NOT HAVING
QUITE THE KIND OF LEEWAY THAT
WE'RE GIVING.
TO THE AGRICULTURAL -- TRUCKERS
SO I JUST SORT OF QUESTION THAT
YOU KNOW ON THE BASIS OF
FAIRNESS BUT SOMETHING ELSE TO
CONSIDER AS YOU MOVE FORWARD
MAYBE HAVING A LITTLE BIT.
LESS.
CHARITY WITH THE LARGER FLEETS
BECAUSE IF YOU'VE GOT A HUNDRED
FIFTY TRUCKS.
IN ROTATION YOU STILL SHOULD BE
ABLE TO CYCLE THEM THROUGH TO
DEAL WITH ALL THE ISSUES YOU
KNOW ON THE FARM HOPEFULLY OR
YOU HAVE THE WHERE WITH ALL TO
AT LEAST MAINTAIN THEM TO WHERE
THEY CAN PASS.
OR YOU TEST THEM BEFORE YOUR
SEVENTY TWO DAY WINDOW -- BUT
THE POINT IS WE'RE NOT GIVING
THAT SAME DISCRETION TO AN AN AN
OPERATOR WHO MIGHT HAVE ONE
TRUCK.
WHO STILL YOU KNOW IS PUTTING
FOOD ON THEIR TABLE I'M GIVING
THEM A LESS AMOUNT OF TIME SO
THERE'S JUST SORT OF A?
THE FAIRNESS ISSUE.
YEAH I I DON'T I DON'T DISAGREE
WITH YOU -- MADAM CHAIR I THINK
THAT OUR HOPE OVER THE LAST TWO
AND A HALF YEARS WORKING ON THIS
BILL IS A WE GET SOMETHING
REALLY SIGNIFICANT THAT IS GOING
TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
MIGHT WE HAVE TO COME BACK IN
THE FUTURE ABSOLUTELY BUT THIS
BILL IF I WE GET OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE GETS OFFER FORGETS THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK AND ASSIGN WILL
MAKE SUCH A SIGNIFICANT IMPACT
ON THE HEALTH -- UP ALL
CALIFORNIANS AND OF THE AIR
QUALITY MATT CLOSE NOW ARE YOU
DONE.
I'M DONE OKAY BUT I I AGREE WITH
YOU I THINK IT'S YOU KNOW IT'S A
GREAT BILL AND SO I YOU KNOW
I'VE JUST BRING THIS UP IS AS
THOUGHTS BUT NO I WE CERTAINLY
DIDN'T.
FORCE ANY AMENDMENTS ON YOU SO
WE JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE AWARE OF SOME OF OUR
THOUGHTS BUT PLEASE.
AND I ONLY I I APPRECIATE AND I
SAID BECAUSE I'M GETTING A
LITTLE BIT FIRED UP SO YOU KNOW
WHEN I WAS A LITTLE GIRL WE
DIDN'T SEE THE MOUNTAINS -- THE
WE HAD SMOG DAYS EVERY DAY AND I
WAS IN THE EARLY SEVENTIES AND
IT WOULDN'T SOME PEOPLE COME
TRAVEL TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
NINETY MINUTE THERE ARE
MOUNTAINS THERE AND WE'VE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF WORK NOT
MYSELF BUT OTHERS.
SO WE SEE THE MOUNTAINS ALMOST
EVERY DAY NOW IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA BUT THE AIR QUALITY
IS JUST AS BAD AND IT'S BECAUSE
THE PARTICULATES ARE SMALLER --
WHEN I LAND IN ONTARIO SOMETIMES
I LOOK ON MY HANDY DANDY APT TO
SEE WHAT THE TEMPERATURE IS AN
ALMOST EVERY THURSDAY WHEN I
LANDED ON TERRIO ITS SAYS?
ERROR UNHEALTHY FOR SOME GROUPS
SO WE ARE DOING SOMETHING WRONG
AND I THINK THIS BILL GOES A
LONG WAY.
IN ADDRESSING A LOT OF CONCERNS
MAKING SURE THAT THE TRUCK
DRIVERS FROM OUT OF STATE ARE
COMING IN AND NOT COMPLYING LIKE
ARE GOOD CALIFORNIA TRUCKING
ASSOCIATION AND DRIVERS ARE
DOING.
SO I EIGHT THINK ABOUT YOU HEARD
A LOT OF PEOPLE TALK ABOUT THE
PLASTICS AND THEIR CHILDREN I'M
GONNA BE A GRAMMA AND NOVEMBER
AND I WANT TO LEAVE THE WORLD A
LITTLE BIT BETTER FOR MY
GRANDDAUGHTER -- THEN WE HAVE IT
NOW AND I THINK THAT THIS BILL
GOES A LONG WAY IN DOING THAT
AND WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
EVERYONE AND GET TO A PLACE
WHERE EVERYBODY IS MAYBE A
LITTLE BIT HAPPY AND A LITTLE
BIT UNHAPPY.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THE ROLL CALL PLEASE ITEM
NINE A THREE TO TEN BY SENATOR
LEYVA THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA [inaudible]
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
BUT WHEN I FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA.
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
WHERE THIRTY HIGH RENT TO GI
STONE?
STONE I FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO WE
WILL BE THE BILL ON CALL FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MA'AM
CHAIR THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THANK YOU I HAVE TO UNDERSTOOD
ARE NEXT ON THE LIST BY.
DO NOT SEE HER I SAW SENATOR
BRADFORD IN HER A MOMENT AGO IF
HE'S OUT IN THE HALL.
A GOOD TIME TO COME IN.
NOW LET'S GO AHEAD AND DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
THE MOTION A SECOND ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
TRIAL.
EGGMAN EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GARCIA.
LIMóN [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
RIGHT TO TREAT MURATSUCHI I
FLORA FLORA [inaudible]
STONE.
JOHN I HAAS BUT LIMóN.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
LOW MOAN LIMON I SIX ZERO SIX
ZERO WE WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND WE ARE STILL LOOKING FOR
SENATE AUTHORS -- LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE COMING IN.
YEAH WHY DON'T WE GO THROUGH.
PERHAPS THE NUMBERS TO WE GET
SOMEONE.
ITEM ONE EIGHT YEAH.
ITEM ONE AJ ARE SEVEN GLORIA
MOTION AS THE ADAPTER CURRENT
VOTERS FIVE TWO TWO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU [inaudible]
MATHIS MCCARTY. TO TREAT.
RIGHT TO GI [inaudible] SIX TWO
THE BILL IS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN.
ITEM TWO SB ONE ATKINS TO PASS
REFER TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE IS.
SIXTY TWO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I ABSENT MEMBERS FONG.
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI IEIGHT TWO EIGHT TWO
THAT THOSE ARE REALLY THE ROLE
OPEN.
ITEM FIVE SB FIFTY FOUR BY ALAN
TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTERS.
THREE TO THREE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
EGGMAN.
LIMóN.
HI Là MON I MCCARTY. TO CHECK
MURATSUCHI I FIVE THREE FIVE
THREE WE WILL LEAVE THAT THE
LONG CALL.
ITEM EIGHT SB ONE NINETY BY DODD
TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
THREE TO ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN.
HI FRIEDMAN I CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
LIMóN.
LIMON I MCCARTY.
WROTE TO CHEAT.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE I EIGHT ZERO EIGHT ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN.
ITEM NINE SB TWO TEN BY LEYVA
[inaudible]
WHEN?
SORRY TO PASS REFERRED -- PROBST.
COMMITTEE CARVE OUT FIVE ZERO
WITH THE TRAVELING I ABSENT
MEMBER FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU [inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible] FIVE ONE IT
WILL LEAVE THAT THE ONE CALL.
ITEM ELEVEN SB TWO FORTY SEVEN
BY DODD TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE AS FIVE
TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE.
LIMóN.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI.
RIGHT TO GI STONE.
STONE I NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THAT
THOSE OUT WILL LEAVE WITH THE
ROLE OPEN.
ITEM THIRTEEN US BEFORE FIFTY BY
AMBERG DO PASS REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FORTY ONE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA I'D CHAU.
FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
LIMóN.
NOT VOTING.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
WE HAVE TO GI [inaudible] SIX
ONE SIX ONE THE BILL WAS OUT
LIBERAL OPEN.
ITEM NINETEEN SB FIVE SEVENTY
SIX AMBERG TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FIVE ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I HAVE SOME MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
FONG [inaudible]
LIMóN [inaudible]
LIMON I RIGHT TO CHOOSE
[inaudible]
THROUGH GI. EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO THAT BILLS OUT LIBERAL OPEN
SENATOR JACKSON.
HELLO GOOD WHAT IS THIS --
ALMOST GOOD EVENING -- MY
APOLOGIES -- BUT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TO SB.
FIVE FIFTY ONE IT'S A BILL THAT
AUTHORIZES THE DIVISION OF OIL
GAS AND GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES
LOVINGLY KNOWN AS DARKER -- TO
FULLY ACCOUNT FOR THE COST OF
DECOMMISSIONING AND REMEDIATING
OIL AND GAS INFRASTRUCTURE IN
OUR STATE OF THE BILL.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR OF OF
BILLS.
AND ASKED BUT KNOWING THIS LATE
HOUR IT BASICALLY -- WE KNOW AND
I KNOW THAT THEIR COLLEAGUES ON
THIS COMMITTEE.
WHO UNDERSTAND AND HAVE BEEN
ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN THIS ISSUE
FOR QUITE SOME TIME?
THE COST OF THIS INFRASTRUCTURE
TO THE STATE IS NOT HYPOTHETICAL.
IN MY DISTRICT ALONE WHICH I
MONNING TO SHARE WITH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEE KNOWN INSURANCE THE
PAST FEW YEARS WE SPENT UPWARD
TO ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
OF TAXPAYER FUNDS FOR TO
FACILITIES IN A SERIES OF
ABANDONED COSTA WELLS.
WITH MANY MILLIONS YET TO SPEND.
THROUGHOUT THE STATE WE HAVE THE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF THESE WELLS
FACILITY STORAGE TANKS
PRODUCTION PIPELINES OF RIGHT
NOW.
WE HAVE LITTLE ABILITY TO
ACCOUNT FOR TO PLAN FOR PREPARE
FOR OR TO MITIGATE BEFORE THE
COSTS AT THE STATE TAX PAYER.
THIS IS ALREADY PROVING TO BE A
BUDGET IMPACTING PROBLEM FOR
JURISDICTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
WESTERN NORTH AMERICA INCLUDING
AN OIL AND GAS INTENSIVE STATES.
AND PROVINCES LIKE WYOMING
COLORADO IN ALBERTA CANADA THIS
IS NOT JUST UNIQUE TO US BUT IT
IS A VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT
WE'RE HAVING TO ADDRESS.
SO THIS BILL DIRECTS DARKER TO
REQUIRE OIL AND GAS OPERATORS TO
OPEN THEIR BOOKS TO THE DIVISION
ON A REGULAR BASIS.
SO THAT THE DIVISION CAN MAKE AN
ACCURATE ASSESSMENT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE COSTS WHICH
INCLUDE NACHOS ACOSTA PLUGGING
IN ABANDONING WELLS.
BUT ALSO THE COST FOR
DECOMMISSIONING ALL RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FOR RESTORING
PRODUCTION SITE TO USABLE
CONDITION.
THIS PROPOSAL BUILT OFF OF
EXISTING AUTHORITIES INCLUDING
EXISTING REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
FROM PASSED LEGISLATION DONE BY --
FORMER.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SANTA
BARBARA -- DOS WILLIAMS THIS
PROPOSAL ALSO SYNCS WITH CURRENT
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS INCLUDING
AS I MENTIONED A GREAT BILL FROM
MY COLLEAGUE AND PARTNER FROM
SANTA BARBARA.
ON BONDING LIMITS FOR ONSHORE
PRODUCTION FACILITIES.
WITH THIS BILL BOTH THE DIVISION
AND STATE POLICYMAKERS WILL HAVE
THE TRANSPARENCY WE NEED TO
BETTER UNDERSTAND THE FULL SCOPE
OF THIS PROBLEM AND A PLAN FOR
THE LIABILITIES.
IN AN UP FRONT AN ORDERLY WAY
BASICALLY BOTTOM LINE WE OWE
THIS TO THE TAXPAYERS CALIFORNIA
WITH THAT.
I HAVE AN AKITA KARATE FROM THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE CENTER
TO SPEAK ON BEHALF OF THE BILL
SENATOR ARE YOU GONNA BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS -- YES I'M SORRY I
DIDN'T PUT THAT IN THE I DIDN'T
PUT THAT IN THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS AUTHORS
MOMENTS AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS THANK YOU.
I THINK YOU CHEN MEMBERS NIKITA
CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL HERE
IN SUPPORT OF SB.
FIVE FIVE ONE WITHOUT THE
ABILITY TO SYSTEMATICALLY IN
COMPREHENSIVELY ASSESS OIL AND
GAS INFRASTRUCTURE THAT IS CLOSE
TO RETIREMENT OR THAT MAY BE
DISCONTINUED OR ABANDONED.
THE STATE LACKS THE ABILITY TO
FORECAST BUDGET AND PLAN FOR
FUTURE LIABILITIES FORCING THE
STATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY TAXPAYERS TO
SHOULDER SIGNIFICANT COSTS OFTEN
IN THE HNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS.
AS YOU HEARD FROM THE SENATOR
THIS IS NOT A HYPOTHETICAL
SITUATION IT'S ALREADY HAPPENING
AND IT'S COSTING THE STATE
SUBSTANTIAL RESOURCES AN ONGOING
AN UNFORESEEN EXPENDITURES.
SB FIVE FIVE ONE ALONG WITH THE
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS PROPOSED PROPOSES A
REASONABLE APPROACH WITH RESPECT
TO DETERMINING OPERATOR%
LIABILITY.
PRIORITIZING INSPECTING WELLS
AND ESTIMATING THE COST TO PLUG
ABANDONED AND THE COMMISSION
FACILITIES TO BETTER PROTECT THE
STATE TAX PAYERS AND OUR
ENVIRONMENT FROM THE RISKS POSED
BY ABANDONED OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE.
I'D LIKE TO THANK THE SENATOR
FOR CONTINUED LEADERSHIP ON THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND AFTER I
BOUGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY -- FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS THE WORKING GROUP WE
SUPPORT THE BILL TO BETTER
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT AND
PUBLIC HEALTH THANK YOU.
WILL BRING YOUR ANTENNA
GALLAGHER FROM THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT.
AND WITH YOUR PERMISSION I JUST
LIKE TO REMIND THE COMMITTEE
WERE SURPRISINGLY CLOSE TO THE
TIME.
WHEN THE OIL AND GAS IS GOING TO
BE RELATIVELY WORTHLESS AS
TECHNOLOGY IS CHANGING FEELS
CHANGE?
THANK YOU JUST NAME IN AND OUR
FIRST REPRESENT THANKS.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO PASS
ALONG THE SUPPORT OF AUDUBON
CALIFORNIA AND A SCHOOL.
AND BRIAN -- WIKIS CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN SUPPORT
AND I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO PASS
ALONG THE SUPPORT OF ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA THANK.
BRAND ALSO IS HERE CO
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. ONE CLUE I
WITH CALIFORNIA'S COOPER LINES
IN SUPPORT.
SO OFTEN I'M WITH THE PACIFIC
COAST FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
JANET **** FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JUST MILAN FOR HEAL THE BAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU FOR ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
GOOD EVENING CHAIR MEMBERS WE
SUCH AS WITH THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION WE OPPOSE
SB FIVE FIVE ONE BECAUSE WE
BELIEVE THAT IT ESSENTIALLY
REQUIRES DAGR. TO ENGAGE IN
PREMATURELY AND HIGHLY SPEAKING
OF ANALYSIS RELATED TO THE
REMEDIATION COSTS FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE RELATED TO OIL
AND GAS OPERATIONS.
THE BILL OBVIOUSLY IGNORES THE
RIGHTS OF PROPERTY OWNERS TO
EVALUATE -- ALTERNATIVE LAND USE
IS -- ONCE A FACILITY COULD BE
REACH ITS POTENTIAL END OF LIFE --
NOW AS IT PERTAINS TO WHAT'S
BEEN PROPOSED IN THE ANALYSIS.
THAT WE BELIEVE THAT THE ADDED
COST OF A THIRD PARTY CONSOLE IS
ENTIRELY UNNECESSARY I THAT ADDS
NO VALUE TO DOCTOR GIVEN THE
FACT THAT THE MODEL INTENDED TO
PROVIDE THE DIVISION -- IS AN
ESTIMATE ON EACH OPERATORS
OBLIGATION -- ADDING ADDITIONAL
REGULATORY REQUIREMENTS ON DOG
ON ON COULD POTENTIALLY DISTRACT.
FROM THE AGENCY FROM FOCUSING ON
ABANDONING OR FROM WELLS
ENSURING OPERATORS ARE
MAINTAINING COMPLIANCE.
WITH THEIR I. TO WELL
ABANDONMENT SCHEDULES -- THE
DATA THAT COULD BE DERIVED FROM
WHAT'S BEEN PROPOSED WERE RESULT
IN SECURING OUT OF CONTEXT
INFORMATION THAT WOULD LEAD TO
REGULATORY CONFUSION.
AS AN ATTEMPT TO PREMATURELY
ESTIMATE AND INDIVIDUALS
OPERATORS DECOMMISSIONING
OBLIGATIONS THAT FAILS TO AGAIN
ACCOUNT.
FOR MITIGATION AND MANAGEMENT
COSTS DRIVEN BY SYKORA ADVANCE
IN REMEDIATION TECHNIQUES
ALTERNATIVE SITE USES SO FOR
THESE REASONS WHAT SPA.
OPPOSES THE BILL IN PRINT AND AS
WELL AS THE MEMBERS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY WITHOUT WILL COME UP TO THE
DíAS TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
NO OKAY SEE NOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE -- YEAH -- DON'T KNOW
WHERE TO BEGIN WITH WAS PICKS UP
TO TELL YOU THAT -- THIS IS ALL
SORT OF A THE DESIRE NOT.
TO NOT TO HAVE US NOHL BY THE
EXPENSES ASSOCIATED WITH THE
pIT'S A SPECULATIVE -- OR
ENTIRELY UNNECESSARY WE WANT TO
DOCTOR TO KNOW SO THEY CAN TELL
US THIS IS A TRANSPARENCY BILL --
A IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE HAVE
THIRD POT PARTIES TO BE
OBJECTIVE AND INDEPENDENT WHICH
RESPONSES SORT OF A
CONTRADICTION I THINK THE
ARGUMENT SORT OF SELF
CONTRADICTORY BUT I THINK THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT ISSUE IF WE ARE
ULTIMATELY GOING TO END UP
HAVING -- TO PAY TO DECOMMISSION
REMEDIATE.
WE SHOULD KNOW AS QUICKLY AS WE
CAN SO THAT WE CAN CONSIDER ALL
OUR OPTIONS AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS DESIGNED TO DO AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR YOUR IPHONE THANK YOU.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOTION AS HE SAID THAT THE
SERVER YEAH.
OKAY SORRY WE WERE ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
ITEM EIGHTEEN SB FIVE FIFTY ONE
BY SENATOR JACKSON THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
I'VE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
GARCIA LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI. THREE THREE AYE
STONE.
STONE I SIX ONE SIX ONE THE BILL
IS NOT LEAVE THE ROLE OPENED
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS
[inaudible]
YES.
RED.
WAY OKAY -- SKINNER.
YEAH OKAY.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
IF [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ALL THE BUDGET RIGHT SOMEONE
ARTICULATION REPUBLICAN WANT TO
GO AHEAD AND START.
AND THE SECOND QUESTION.
LIKE WHY DON'T.
WHEN THE NEXT?
AND YOU KNOW YOU COULD INJURE.
WE WILL WITH.
AND THAT'S HOW WE'LL. ZERO ONE
OF THE THINGS I WANT TO MAKE
MOVES ON THE FLOOR.
THE BILL YEAH THE GENERAL THE
PROBLEMS IN CALIFORNIA.
AND THAT THE MOST UNHEALTHY.
SOURCE OF AIR POLLUTION THE
QUANTITY OF IT.
IS FROM OUR IT.
REGULAR DIESEL POWERED.
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES.
THAT PARTICULAR I SAY PARTICULAR
POLLUTION IS PARTICULATE MATTER --
BUT IT IS ONE OF OUR PRIMARY
CAUSES OF ASTHMA WHICH WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT RATE SEVEN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THERE'S LINKS TO MANY OTHER --
HEALTH RELATED CONDITION
BASICALLY WHAT S. B. FORTY FOUR
DOES HIS DIRECT OUR AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO UPDATE PLANS
FOR HOW WE CAN ASSIST.
OUR FLEET OWNERS AND DRIVERS OF
MEDIUM AND HEAVY DUTY VEHICLES
TO BE ABLE -- TO MEET OUR
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR STANDARDS.
IN OTHER GOALS THE CALIFORNIA
HAVES BY TRANSITIONING OFF OF
THAT DIESEL AND WITH THAT I
WOULD LIKE FOR AND MY WITNESSES
I HAVE MERIT ALEXANDER FROM CAL
START.
AND I ALSO HAVE.
COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH FOR FIRST WITH THIS IN
TWO MINUTES PLEASE.
HELLO AGAIN MEREDITH ALEXANDER
FROM CAL START -- SO I'LL SKIP
MY INTRODUCTION BUT CALIFORNIA'S
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE GOALS HAVE
GIVEN RISEN TO A RENAISSANCE IN
VEHICLE MANUFACTURING IN THE
STATE.
AND WE ARE SEEING COMPANIES
SETTING UP SHOP HERE TO RESEARCH
DESIGN AND BUILD CLEAN VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGIES ACROSS ALL VEHICLE
CLASSES.
SO AS A RESULT MANY NEW VEHICLE
CLASSES ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
BECOMING OR HAVE ALREADY BEEN
COMMERCIALIZED.
SO AS LONG AS THE STATE STAYS
THE COURSE WITH ITS CLIMATE
COMMITMENTS THESE TRENDS WILL
NOT ONLY CONTINUE WE EXPECT BUT
INCREASE.
SO SB FORTY FOUR REPRESENTS THE
NEXT LOGICAL STEP IN OUR STATES
PLANNING EFFORTS TO KEEP
RATCHETING DOWN A VEHICLE
EMISSIONS AND SIGNALING TO
MANUFACTURERS THAT WE'RE NOT
BACKING DOWN FROM OUR
COMMITMENTS.
SO TO BUILD NEW CLEAN MEDIUM AND
HEAVY DUTY VEHICLE TECHNOLOGIES
WE NEED CLEAR SIGNALS FROM THE
STATE AND A COMPREHENSIVE POLICY
FRAMEWORK TO SUPPORT THIS VISION.
IT TAKES MANUFACTURERS ABOUT
FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS TO BRING A
NEW PRODUCT TO MARKET.
AND THEY'RE UNLIKELY TO START
THIS PROCESS UNLESS THEY CAN
LOOK OUT AND SEE WHERE THE STATE
IS GOING AND HOW IT PLANS TO GET
THERE.
SO BUSINESSES IN CLOSING ARE
MAKING INVESTMENT DECISIONS ON A
LONG TERM BASIS AND WE NEED THE
STATE TO MORE CLOSELY THINK IT'S
PLANNING AND APPROPRIATIONS FOR
PROGRAMS WITH THOSE INVESTMENT
CYCLES.
WHICH WOULD HELP BRING TO MARKET
MORE OF THESE MEDIUM AND HEAVY
DUTY VEHICLES MORE QUICKLY.
AND CONTINUE TO DROP MORE
MANUFACTURERS AND THEIR
INVESTORS TO THE STATE SO FOR
THESE REASONS WE REQUEST WE'VE
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR IPHONE.
BILL MY GOVERNMENT COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT ABOUT
TWENTY YEARS AGO CALIFORNIA
FIRST DECLARED DIESEL EXHAUST TO
BE A TOXIC AIR CONTAMINANT.
AND THE STATE'S TAKEN A NUMBER
OF STEPS SINCE THEN TO REDUCE
DIESEL EMISSIONS BUT IT'S NOT
NEARLY ENOUGH BECAUSE WE STILL
HAVE EXCESSIVE LEVELS OF SMOG
AND PARTICULAR POLLUTION.
IN MOST OF THE STATE AND THAT
CAUSES HEART AND LUNG DISEASE
AND PREMATURE DEATH AND WE ALSO
HAVE DIESEL MAKING A
CONTRIBUTION TO THE CLIMATE
CRISIS.
THAT WE FIND OURSELVES IN SO FOR
ALL THESE REASONS WE THINK THIS
IS A GOOD BILL WHERE THE FOR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL -- JULIE NOW AND ASK IF
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRIC TRANSPORTATION
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
SILVIO FOR ARMY HAPPEN NESTING
OVER ON IN SUPPORT.
NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF OF BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS AND
SUPPORT.
ROSS BUT THE ON BEHALF OF BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN SUPPORT.
ROD BREWER FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON HERE IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
BROWN AND ASSOCIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JUST LEARN TO SERIES ON THE
ENVIRONMENT HEALTH DIRECTORS AND
SUPPORT.
NIKITA CROWDED WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER RUN
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
BE WAY THE IN SUPPORT.
HOUSING BROWN ON BEHALF OF THREE
FIFTY BEAR ACTION AND THREE
FIFTY RIVERSIDE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
PERSONAL GET US HERE ON BEHALF
OF ADVANCE ENERGY ECONOMY IN
SUPPORT.
YES WITH OUR AND CAL CHAMBER IN
JANET CARTS FOR THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
JIM WOOD BURKE FOR THE FRIENDS
COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION A
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
READING OF ZERO THE ELECTION
VEHICLE CHARGING CESSATION AND
SEE OUR IN OUR LIMA TO SERVICES
AND SUPPORT.
CHRISTINE SHOEMAKER WITH ALSO
FREE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
TIM CARMICHAEL AND HAVE A
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY
AND SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC IN
SUPPORT.
A JUST A YOUNG ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS VEHICLES
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
CAROL WE'D WITH TIME.
SENATOR RUSS MORE IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT
BACK UP TO THE DíAS WE DO HAVE
A MOTION A SECOND.
OKAY SEEING NO COMMENTS
[inaudible]
PARK MIRACLE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU ASKED FOR A VOTE SORRY
THAT WASN'T A HEN I JUST ORGAN.
DOOR.
SLATE.
ITEM FOR SB FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR SKINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA.
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
RESEARCH THE AYE STONE
[inaudible]
STONE I SIX ZERO SIX ZERO THE
BILLS OUT WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
FOR SEVEN RESOURCES [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
GET INFORMATION [inaudible]
NEXT.
THE FOOD CHAIN OKAY [inaudible]
SEVENTEEN THE PEOPLE.
SHE SEVEN ON EVERYTHING EXCEPT
ONE RIGHT.
BUT LET'S GO AHEAD AND CALL WILL
WILL ADD ON TO THAT BILL BECAUSE
WE'VE ON MR CHOW IS ALSO HERE.
TWO ONE ONE YEAH WE'LL START
WITH THAT WE'RE GONNA DO SOME
ADD ONS THEN WE CAN.
I WAS GONNA WAIT TO DO THE REST
BECAUSE YOU WITH.
IF YOU DON'T MIND BUT WE'LL DO
THE ONE RIGHT NOW.
AS LONG AS YOU'RE YOU'RE ARE YOU
PLANNING TO STAY UNTIL THE END.
OKAY AND WE'LL JUST WAIT ON THE
OTHER.
ONE ON ITEM TWENTY TWO SB SEVEN
FORTY FOUR BY CABALLERO THE
MOTION WAS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FOR DOES
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA I CHAU CHOW I PHONE.
GARCIA.
LIMóN.
LIMON NOT VOTING.
BROUGHT TO CHIEF.
MURATSUCHI AYE [inaudible]
SEVEN
ZERO YES
[inaudible]
WELL
THE REPRESENTATIVE [inaudible]
YEAH
.
OKAY THANK YOU.
WE WERE JUST.
DISCUSSING HAVING SOMEBODY ELSE
TO THE PRESENT THE BILL FOR YOU
FLOOD HAVE PERSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- MADAM
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO YOUR
INNER COMMITTED FOR WORKING WITH
US -- AND HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEES ARE AMENDMENTS TO THE
BILL.
SB SIXTY NINE THE OCEAN
RESILIENCY OCT TWENTY NINETEEN
WILL HELP RESTORE HABITATS
ENCOURAGE PRACTICES THAT
INCREASED.
INCREASE SEQUESTRATION OF SO
CALLED BLUE CARBON.
OF THE CARBON STORED IN MARINE
ECOSYSTEMS AND SETTLEMENTS.
ARE WE ALSO NEED TO PROTECT OUR
ECOLOGICALLY CRITICAL SPECIES
INCLUDING THOSE A COASTAL
ECONOMIES RELY ON BUT THIS BILL
PROTECT WHALES BY CODIFYING
EXISTING FALL VOLUNTARY PROGRAM
AIMED AT PREVENTING SHIP STRIKES.
IT ALSO TAKES A LONG OVERDUE --
STEP TOWARD REBUILDING OUR
SALMON FISHERIES INCLUDING PRINT
PLACING NEW PROTECTIONS ON THE
FOUR STREAMS WHERE THEY SPAWN.
A TOGETHER THE MEASURES IN THIS
BILL WILL HELP INSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A STRATEGY AND
THE ABILITY. TOMEDICAID TO
MITIGATE THE EFFECTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE IN THE OCEAN TO SEQUESTER
GREATER AMOUNTS OF CARBON UNTIL
A COASTAL COMMUNITIES TO
CONTINUE THEIR WAY OF LIFE.
INTO THE FUTURE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND WITH ME HERE
TODAY ARE HI CAITLYN CLUE OF OF
THE COAST KEEPERS ALLIANCE.
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE KEEP RELIANCE.
AND OPPENHEIMER THE PACIFIC
COAST FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS.
THANK YOU WITNESS PLEASE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON TURKEY MAN THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS CAITLYN KALU I AM THE POLICY
ANALYST WITH THE COMPANY BECAUSE
KEEPER ALLIANCE WHICH REPRESENTS
LOCAL WATER KEEP ORGANIZATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE -- SPEAKING
SAYING CLEARLY IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB -- SIXTY NINE WE SEE THIS
IS A CRITICAL ACTION ORIENTED.
BILLS INCREASE RIDDLE A
RESILIENCE OF CRITICAL CARE --
KEYSTONE SPECIES ALONG THE
CALIFORNIA COAST AS WELL AS THE
ACTUAL ECOSYSTEMS THAT PROTECT
BOTH THE SPECIES.
AND THE COMMUNITIES WELL
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
SB SIXTY NINE INCLUDES I KEY
STATEWIDE ACTIONS THAT SICK
EMPHASIS ON ACTIONS NOT SIMPLY
PLANS FOR CALIFORNIA TO INCREASE
ITS RESILIENCE WORKING THESE
SPECIES.
THIS INCLUDES -- THREE ITEMS
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THAT INCLUDES
A BENEFICIAL RE YEARS OF DREDGE
SETTLEMENT -- TO RESTORE
WETLANDS LONGER COAST -- THAT IS --
ESSENTIALLY OVER THE ADDRESSING
THE FACT THAT OVER THE PAST
CENTURY CALIFORNIA WETLANDS HAVE
BEEN -- HAVE HISTORICALLY
BUILDER CONVERTED TO OTHER USES
WE ARE LEFT -- WITH 10% OF OUR
STATES INSERT WETLANDS THIS BILL.
WILL ACHIEVE -- WILL.
SET SO CHEAP ACTUAL GAINES
BECAUSE WETLANDS FOR REVIVING
CALIFORNIA'S KNOW THAT LOS
POLICY BY SUPPORTING THE BENEFIT
BENEFICIAL RE USE OF DRUGS
SEGMENT FOR ONE BUTTON
RESTORATION.
SECOND ITEM THE CUT FELT A
VOLUNTARY VESSEL SPEED REDUCTION
PROGRAM.
IS AN EXISTING PROGRAM WITHIN
THE SANTA BARBARA CHANNEL AS
WELL AS SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
THAT HAS RESULTED IN TWELVE
SHIPPING COMPANIES. TO SLOW AND
REDUCE VEHICLE FATAL -- WILL
STRIKES ALONG THE CALIFORNIA
COAST THIS BILL SEEKS TO EXPAND
UPON THE EXCEPT SUCCESS OF THAT
PROGRAM. TO REDUCE SMOG --
EMITTING.
ALONG THE COAST LINE AS WELL AS
REDUCING THIS BATTLE WILL
STRIKES AND LASTLY I THIS BILL
WILL IMPROVE CRITICAL INSTREAM
FLOW AND SEVEN HABITAT
ACKNOWLEDGING THE FACT THAT
SALMON ARE.
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SPECIES
THAT CONNECTS FRESH WATER IN
MARINE ECOSYSTEMS.
AS SENATOR WE KNOW THIS OTHER
SIDE I THIS IS A VERY CRITICAL
BUILDING THAT TOGETHER THESE
PROGRAMS AND SPECIFIC ACTIONS
WILL PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
BENEFITS TO GOES LIKE A SYSTEMS
AND WE ORDER SURPLUS YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS KNOW OPPENHEIM
WITH THE PACIFIC COAST
FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS REPRESENTING
FOURTEEN ORGANIZATIONS --
PROSECUTING COMMERCIAL FISHERIES
FROM SANTA BARBARA TO THE OREGON
BORDER AND IT'S OUR PLEASURE --
TO CO SPONSOR SENATE BILL SIXTY
NINE THE OCEAN RESILIENCY ACT.
VERY BRIEFLY THIS BILL HAS SOME
KEY PROVISIONS THAT WOULD
ENHANCE THE RESILIENCE OF
COASTAL COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
THE STATE -- FROM SUPPORTING
HABITAT -- TO OF COURSE -- OUR
HATCHERY PROGRAMS IN TIMES OF
DROUGHT AND RESTORING SOME OF
OURS SAID IN AN IMPAIRED
WATERSHEDS IN THE NORTH COAST
AND BEYOND -- KEY COMPONENTS OF
A HEALTHY AND FUNCTIONAL COASTAL
AND INLAND ECOSYSTEM SUPPORTING
FISHING COMMUNITIES AND OF
COURSE THE SPECIES THAT THEY
RELY UPON -- THANK YOU VERY MUCH --
FOR THE WORK WITH THE COMMITTEE --
TO FIND ACCEPTABLE AMENDMENTS
THAT -- WE WE WORKED WITH
OPPOSITION ON AND WITH THAT I
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
JUST MULLIN FOR HEAL THE BAY IN
SUPPORT.
BILL MCGOVERN COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR AND SUPPORT BECAUSE
THE SPEED REDUCTION.
BRENNAN DAWSON SIERRA CLUB IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE.
YOU CAN WE JUST COME UP TO FIVE
PERSONAL GET US ON BEHALF OF
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION WE HAVE SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION ALL WORKING
WITH THE AUTHORS OFFICE -- ON
REGARDING THE SECTION THE
BUILDING WITH THE VESSEL SPEED
REDUCTION AND WE CAN CONTINUE
WORKING WITH OFFICE AND THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
YOUR SINGLE BECKY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
WHEN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THE BILL AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE THE CHAIR AND
THE COMMITTEE STAFFS WORK TO
PROVIDE SOME.
COMPROMISE AMENDMENTS -- ONCE
THE AMENDMENTS ARE IN PRINT WILL
BE REMOVING OUR OPPOSITION THANK
YOU.
VALERIE NEVER FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WERE IN THE
SAME PLACE AND THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR TAKING THE AMENDMENTS AND
THAT CHAIR.
FOR WORKING SO HARD ON THIS.
YES LARA CAMP I'M A SMALL NINE
USHER LANDOWNER AND ALSO
REGISTER FOR SURE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND I'M REPRESENTING
FOREST LANDOWNERS A CALIFORNIA
AND ALSO.
CALIFORNIA LICENSE FOR FREE
ASSOCIATION -- WE WILL -- WHICH
ARE OPPOSITION -- WHEN WE SEE
THE AMENDMENTS IN PRINT WE'D
ALSO LIKE TO THANK -- BOTH THE
AUTHOR AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AND MEMBERS OF STAFF -- TO WORK.
TO RESOLVE THE ISSUES WE HAD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU.
MANAGER CHRIS MAKAYLA ON BEHALF
OF THEM A MENDOCINO IN HUMBOLDT
REDWOOD COMPANIES AND ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF OUR ASSOCIATION CFA
AND THANK YOU COMMITTEE STAFF
AND THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF --
CARLSON ASSOCIATE CALVARY
LOGGERS THAT SAY WITH THE TIMBER
INDUSTRY AND WE TO OPPOSE LESSEN
MENTON FEELING PRETTY GOOD ABOUT
THESE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU. THREE I'M WTHOUT
WILL WE'RE BRING IT BACK TO THE
DíAS OF ANYONE IS ANY COMMENTS.
WELL I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AND FOR WORKING US SO
HARD TO GET TO THAT SWEET SPOT
WHICH YOU KNOW YOU SEEM TO HAVE
FOUND WITH.
HAVING HAPPY SPONSORS HAPPY
FISHERMAN.
PROTECTING -- THE WILDLIFE IN
THE OCEAN AND ALSO -- WORKING
WITH THE FORESTRY INDUSTRY SO
THANK YOU WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
GET A HEALTH -- BAY -- CHAIR WHO
IS A MAGIC TOUCH ON MANY
DIFFERENT ALSO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COOPERATION I'M SURE WE'RE
DEEPLY APPRECIATIVE AND I
RESPECT LAST FROM A VOTE.
THANK YOU I'M DO WE HAVE A
MOTION.
SECOND TAKE WILL MOTION MULTIPLE
MOTIONS IN SECONDS WE HAVE A
ROLL CALL.
ITEM SIX SB SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR WINNER THE MOTION IS TO
PASS IS AMENDED THAT REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
FONG GARCIA.
LIMON [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI WROTE TO GI
STONE.
STONE I FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO WILL
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
YEAH
[inaudible]
SENATORS.
WE'RE GONNA DO WE'RE GONNA COME --
BUT ON A FEW OF THE BILLS THAT
ARE ON CALL. ONE BILL OKAY.
ON ITEM ELEVEN SB TWO FORTY
SEVEN BY SENATOR DODD TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT -- IS NINE TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
TROUT I MCCARTY I ELEVEN ZERO
ELEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT --
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH.
A ROLL CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ON THIS NUMBER.
ARE YOU SURE WHAT I'M AND THIS
NOBLE.
WHAT ABOUT THE WINNER BILL?
YES ON THE BILL WE JUST OKAY.
LET'S GO AHEAD AND DO SB.
SIXTY NINE PERHAPS A MEMBERS.
ITEM SIX SB SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR WIENER TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE AS FIVE
TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN
[inaudible]
FONG [inaudible]
GARCIA [inaudible]
LIMóN.
LIMóN AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
SIX ZERO HELLO [inaudible]
MARK [inaudible]
YES.
HI MISTER SPENDING ON YOUR BILL --
IF YOU HAVE A SUPPORT
[inaudible]
RUN.
FOR MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY THE
BILL WE HAVE A GREAT DEAL.
WE DON'T.
HAVE A INTO YOUR BILL RIGHT --
NO WE DON'T HAVE TO WORRY.
THANK YOU.
THERE'S A MAN.
OKAY.
REQUIRE.
MR SO IF YOU'RE GOING TO PRESENT --
MISTER REQUIRES BILLS.
YES THANK YOU SB AT TWO SIXTY
TWO WE WOULD LIKE YOU KNOW
BEHALF OF CENTER REQUIRE HAVING
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS.
AS THE VICE CHAIR OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE ON FISHERIES AND
AQUACULTURE ABOUT APPROPRIATE TO
ASSIST CENTER MCGUIRE.
AND REALLY SAY THIS THIS BILL IT.
IN LINE WITH WHAT THE JOINT
COMMITTEE HAS BEEN DOING IT SETS
COMMERCIAL FISHING LANDING FEE
SCHEDULE FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY
CALENDAR YEAR REQUIRES FISH
WILDLIFE TO ADJUST THE RATE
SCHEDULE.
ANNUALLY.
REQUIRES THAT CHANGES THE
CURRENT.
RATES AND FEES -- CALCULATIONS
BE REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE GOVERNOR STANDS A SUNSET
PROVISION ON COMMERCIAL TAKE.
FOR SEA CUCUMBERS.
TO APRIL FIRST TWENTY THIRTY
SPECIFIES GEAR RETRIEVAL OF THE
LAST REMAINING COMMERCIAL
DUNGEON THAT'S CRAP.
RETRIEVAL PROGRAMS WILL BE
ALLOWED DURING THE PRE OF TIME
WHICH THE DIRECTOR.
OF PART IN FISH AND WILDLIFE
RESTRICTS THAT TAKE ATTENTION S.
CRAP THIS IS TO REDUCE MARINE
ENTANGLEMENT.
INTO REQURES THE COMMISSION IN
CONSULTATION WITH THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH WILDLIFE AND OTHER
RELEVANT COSTA PERMITTING
AGENCIES TO DEVELOP GUIDELINES.
ASPECTS BUT BY DECEMBER TWENTY
BUT SUMMER THIRTY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR APPLICANTS OF COURSE
THE GOVERNMENT PERMITS FOR
SHELLFISH SEAWEED OTHER LOW
TRAFFIC MARINE PRODUCTION AND
RESTORATION AGAIN SOMETHING
WE'VE BEEN WORKING FOR QUITE
SOME TIME ON I ASK. FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU AND WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS LOOK IS FOR X. ABOUT THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY I'M STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL LOST ABANDONED
CRAP GEARS ENTANGLEMENT THREAT
TO WHALES OFF CONFERENCE COAST.
YOU KNOW SB TWO SIXTY TWO IS
ESSENTIAL TO ENSURING THAT THOSE
EFFORTS ARE EFFECTIVE MOVING
FORWARD AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE.
MANAGER JUST MULLIN ON HEREON
BEHALF OF THE PACIFICA SHELLFISH
GROWS WE HAVE PARTICULARLY IN
AMERICA ULTRA SECTION RECORDED
LOW TRAFFIC MARICULTURE BECAUSE
IT'S LIKE BIODYNAMIC AGRICULTURE
NO INPUTS.
NO IMPACTS AND WE VERY PLEASED
TO HAVE WORKED WITH THE COAST
COMMISSION ON BASICALLY FIGURING
OUT HOW WE CAN FACILITATE THE
PERMITTING THIS IS NO -- QUICK
WAY TO GET THERE IT'S JUST A A
WAY TO IMPROVE THE EFFICIENCY OF
THE PERMITTING PROCESS SO WE CAN
GET MORE OF THE SHELLFISH.
AND THE KILL PRODUCTION UNDERWAY
AND WE DID CIRCULATE LED A FROM
A CONTROLLABILITY YOU'LL SEE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT MADAM CHAIR ROB ROSS AND
THEY HAVE THE CALIFORNIA.
FISHERIES AND SEAFOOD INSTITUTE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MANAGER MEMBERS KNOW OPPENHEIM
WITH PACIFIC COAST FEDERATION OF
FISHERMEN'S ASSOCIATIONS THANKS
MISTER VICE CHAIR FOR PRESENTING
THE BILL -- WE ARE STRONG
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SIGNAL WILL COME BACK TO
THE DíAS TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
COMMENTS.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
MOVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM TWELVE SB TWO SIXTY TWO BY
SENATOR MCGUIRE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
FONG.
FONG AYE GARCIA [inaudible]
LIMON.
LIMON I MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
AYE STONE.
STONE AYE. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
THE BILLS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN A SENATOR BRADFORD.
WELCOME YOU'RE HERE FOR SB ONE
FIFTY FIVE YEAH THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEMBERS I'M HERE THE
PRESENT.
SB ONE FIVE FIVE I ACCEPT
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND I'M
GONNA THINK -- THE CHEERING
STAFF FOR YOUR WORK ON THIS
MEASURE ONE FIVE FIVE IS JUST A
SIMPLE MEASURE THAT HELPS
IMPROVE EXISTING ON ENERGY
PROGRAMS INCREASING
ACCOUNTABILITY IN.
BOTH I OUR P. AND R. P. S. -- IT
DOES NOT CREATE NEW REQUIREMENTS
JUST IMPROVES WHAT IS OUR EXISTS
IN A FULL LOAD SIR SERVING ANY
COMPLIES WITH THE EXISTING
REQUIREMENTS THEY HAVE NOTHING
TO FEAR -- WITH ME TODAY IT'S
GOT WET AND I HAVE COLIN BECAUSE
SHE FROM SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE.
AND I'M CHAIR MEMBERS GOT WHICH
ABOUT THE CALIFORNIA COALITION
OF UTILITY EMPLOYEES.
THIS IS A REALLY OF IMPORTANT
BILL DOES TOO CRITICAL THINGS.
IT ESTABLISHES THAT.
IF ANY RETAIL SELLER OF ANY SPOT --
STRIPE.
SUBMITS ITS ANNUAL OUR PS
COMPLIANCE REPORT TO THE
COMMISSION.
AND THE COMMISSION DEEMS THAT
THEY ARE NOT ON TRACK TO MEET
THEIR OUR PS REQUIREMENTS.
THE P. YOU SEE IS TO MAKE
RECOMMEND MAKE THAT PUBLIC AND
ALSO MAKE RECOMMENDATIONS AS TO
WHAT THEY SHOULD DO TO GET INTO
COMPLIANCE.
WITH THE OUR PS SECONDLY IT
MAKES IT CLEAR THAT THE P. YOU
SEE HAS THE ABILITY TO ENFORCE.
THE I. R. P..
SAYS WHICH IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR US MEETING OUR ALL
OF OUR RELIABILITY NEEDS AND SO
WE WOULD URGE AND I'VE THANK YOU.
YES THANK YOU -- HAVE MADAM
CHAIR AND AND COMMISSION MEMBERS
OF MY NAME'S CAUCUS HIM A VICE
PRESIDENT SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON RESPONSIBLE FOR OUR POWER
SUPPLY OPERATIONS.
I'M HERE TO REALLY SPEAK ON THE
ISSUE OF RELIABILITY -- SB ONE
FIFTY FIVE FOR A PROVIDES A VERY
IMPORTANT -- OF CONFIRMATION
THAT THE CPC HAS THE ABILITY TO
ENFORCE AYE ARE PEAS ON ALL VOTE
SERVING ENTITIES.
IT PROBABLY GOES WITHOUT SAYING
THAT THE FOLKS KNOW THAT -- SOLD
ONLY OPERATES WHEN THE SUN
SHINES AND SO -- SOMETHING THAT
MAY NOT BE FULLY -- KNOWN TO THE
COMMITTEE HERE IS -- ARTNET PEAK
REQUIREMENTS ON THE SYSTEM ARE
SHIFTING TO THE EARLY EVENING
HOURS SO HISTORICALLY OF OUR OUR
TO PEAK DEMAND IS BEEN DURING
THE DAY.
IT'S NOW START TO BECOME IN THE
EVENING IN MANY MONTHS WHEN THE
THE SOLAR DOES NOT REALLY WORK --
AND SO IT'S GONNA BE IMPORTANT
THROUGH THE IRP PROCESS THAT THE
CPC BE ABLE TO ENFORCE
RELIABILITY REQUIREMENTS ON
ALTHOUGH CERVANTES SO THAT IN
MEETING OUR RESPECTIVE RE NOBLES
REQUIREMENTS WE'RE DOING SO IN A
WAY THAT ENSURES A RELIABLE GREG
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T HAVE A
RELIABLE GRAD.
CALIFORNIA WILL -- WILL NOT
SUPPORT OUR CLEAN ENERGY
OBJECTIVES -- IS A FINAL POINT
ON THIS -- THE CPC -- HAS ISSUE
JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO ON JUNE
TWENTIETH A ASSIGNED
COMMISSIONER RULING REQUIRING
THAT LOAD SERVING ID'S PROCURE.
UP TO TWO THOUSAND MEGAWATTS A
NEW RESOURCES BY AUGUST OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE A TYPICALLY
TAKES THREE TO FIVE YEARS TO
DEVELOP NEW RESOURCES OF THIS IS
GOING TO BE A SPRINT TO DO THIS.
EDISON'S OWN ANALYSIS SAYS THAT
WE PROBABLY NEED SEVEN THOUSAND
MEGAWATTS TO GIVE YOU SOME
CONTEXT SEVEN THOUSAND MEGAWATTS
IS ABOUT 15% OF THE PEAK DEMAND
ON THE SYSTEM.
THIS IS WHY IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT THAT THE CPC HAVE
ENFORCEMENT AUTHORITY SO
CALIFORNIA DOESN'T GO BLACK
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
I'M SORRY SUPPORT SUPPORT.
IT'S BEEN A LONG TIME.
JUST KEEPING YOU ON YOUR TOES.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
OKAY THOSE WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION COME ON UP.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF MAKE
THIS QUICK -- SHAMA DEAL WITH
KELSEY CA WE WERE -- OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED OR WE ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED HOWEVER BASED ON
THE RECENT AMENDMENTS -- WE
THINK THAT WE CAN MOVE TO A
NEUTRAL POSITION BUT IT'S GONNA
TAKE A COUPLE DAYS FAR MORE TO
TO TAKE A VOTE.
RIGHT THANK YOU.
HIGH HOUSING BROWN ON BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY BEAR ACTION AT THREE
FIFTY SOUTH LA CLIMATE ACTION
GROUP SO CAL THREE FIFTY THREE
THIRTY VENTURE CLIMATE HAVE
INDIVISIBLE VENTURE AT
INDIVIDUAL -- HIGH INDIVIDUAL
BURBANK INDIVISIBLE CAL GREEN
TEAM THROUGH FIFTY RIVERSIDE AND
SENIOR THREE FIFTY THANKS FOR
BEING WITH ME THROUGH THE LAST
I'M JUST WANT TO SECOND MUCH ON
SAID FROM CAL CCA.
STILL KIND OF DIGESTING THE
AMENDMENTS AYE WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR TAKING SOME TIME TO
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS.
AND HOPE THAT WE CAN JUST MAKE
SURE THAT WE PREVENT THE PC FROM
BEING GRANTED NEW AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE PROCUREMENT OF SPECIFIC
RESOURCES THANKS SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME.
JENNIFER TANNEHILL WITH ERIN
READ AND ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF
THE SILICON VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY
WERE NEUTRAL WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
COULD YOU MAKE YOUR ASSEMBLY HUB
OF THE CITY OF SOUTH PASADENA
AND THE CITY OF SOLANA BEACH
WERE REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS
AND THAT WILL TAKE A LOOK AT
THEM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MARK
FENSTER MAKER FOR PENINSULA
CLEAN ENERGY AND VALLEY CLEAN
ENERGY A SIMILAR POSITION TO
KELSEY CA.
I'LL HAVE ANOTHER NUMBER PERCENT
EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY ALSO
REVIEW IN THE MOMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL COME UP
TO THE DíAS WELL I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US AND FOR TAKING THE
AMENDMENTS I REALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE IT -- ANY COMMENTS
MANY WOMEN.
DO WE HAVE A MOTION YES WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND FOR ME I
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSER.
ARE I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THIS IS ABOUT SYSTEM
RELIABILITY AS INDIVIDUAL WHO
SPENT QUITE A BIT OF TIME IN
THIS SPACE.
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING IS
RELIABILITY AND SAFETY THEN COST
THIS IS A SHEARER'S BASED ON SB.
THREE FIFTY AND ALL THE MEASURES
THAT HAVE LED UP TO HEAR THAT WE
HAVE RELIABLE POWER WHEN WE
NEEDED TO I LIVE DO WE ALL LIVE
TO THE ENERGY CRISIS IN.
TWO THOUSAND ONE AND WE DON'T
WANT THAT TO HAPPEN SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ROLL CALL PLEASE ITEM
SEVEN SB ONE FIFTY FIVE BY
SENATOR BRADFORD THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA
FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
FONG.
FONG AYE GARCIA.
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
THE AYE MURATSUCHI ROAD TO GI
STONE.
STONE AYE. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPENED THINK MANAGER MEMBERS
THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SELECT
.
UNLIKE GOOGLE CHANGE.
YEAH.
WHICH ARE.
THAT'S WHY.
WE OPEN THE ROLE ONE SB.
SB.
SEVEN FORTY FOUR ITEM TWENTY TWO
SB SEVEN FORTY FOUR BY CABALLERO
TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. FOR
ABOUT SEVEN ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS FONG
[inaudible]
FONG I GARCIA [inaudible]
LIMON [inaudible]
LIMON I NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THAT
THOSE OUT.
IF YOU WANT TO DO SOME MORE WILL
JUST MORE PROPS AND MEMBERS.
WHEN I GO AHEAD AND START AT THE
TOP FOR ABSENT MEMBERS?
WE HAVE A MEMBER UNTIL WE HAVE A
SENATOR.
AND I WANT TO THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER FONG FOR SOMETHING TODAY.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
ON ITEM ONE AJ ARE SEVEN BY
GLORIA.
MOTIONS BE ADOPTED CURRENT VOTE
SIXTY TWO WITH THE TRUE VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU.
NOT VOTING.
THE SEVENTIES.
OKAY.
UPSET MEMBER MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I SEVEN THREE THANK.
WHICH ONE WAS THE BAKER.
ONE EIGHT EIGHT ZERO ONE SEVEN I
DON'T NEED YOUR SEVEN SEVEN
SEVENTY THREE THE RESOLUTION IS
OUT.
ITEM TWO SB ONE BY ATKINS TO
PASS REFER TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE KERR VOTE EIGHT TO TO
WHAT THE SURE VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBER FONG [inaudible]
FONG NO. NINE TWO NINE TWO THAT
THOSE OUT.
WAIT A MINUTE.
NO I'M SORRY. NINE THREE EIGHT
THREE EIGHT THREE EIGHTY THREE
THE BILL IS STILL OUT THANK YOU
FOR THE CORRECTION YES. EIGHTY
THREE YEAH THANK YOU.
ITEM FOUR SB FORTY FOUR BY
SKINNER TO PASS AND REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE SIX TO ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN
[inaudible]
FONG.
FONG NO.
GARCIA [inaudible]
MATHIS. FOR MORE YES.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I SEVEN TO SEVENTY TWO
THAT THOSE OUT [inaudible]
MMHM. ONE CALL AND IT STRONG
IT'S STILL WILL LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN PERHAPS MEMBERS.
ITEM FIVE SB FIFTY FOUR BY ALLEN
TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONSCOMMITTEE.
KERR ABOUT FIVE TO THREE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
HE SAID I THE I.. SEVEN THREE
SEVEN THREE THAT THOSE OUT.
KEEPING IT OPEN LEAVE IT OPEN.
ITEM SIX SB SIXTY NINE BY
SENATOR WIENER DO PASSES AMONG
MENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERR
ABOUT SIX TO ZERO WITH THE
TRAVELING I ABSENT MEMBERS
EGGMAN [inaudible]
FONG.
FONG NO GARCIA.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO. SIX TWO SIX THE TO
THE BILLS OUT WILL BE THE ROLE
OPEN.
ITEM SEVEN SB ONE FIFTY FIVE AYE
BRADFORD TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE. NINE
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN
[inaudible]
GARCIA.
BELIEVE.
NINE ZERO ITEM A SB ONE NINETY
BY DODD DO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE.
EIGHT ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING
I ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU IPHONE.
FONG FONG I MCCARTY I ELEVEN
ZERO LIVE IN FEAR THAT GOES OUT.
ITEM NINE SB TWO TEN BY LEYVA TO
PASS AND REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHOW I FONG.
FONG NO GARCIA [inaudible]
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I SEVEN THREE SEVEN
THREE THE BULLS OUT WILL BE FOR
ALL OPEN.
ITEM TWELVE SB TWO SIXTY TWO BY
MCGUIRE DO PASSES AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE. NINE TO
ZERO WITH THAT YOU'RE VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
GARCIA.
IF THEY'RE OPEN AGAIN.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB FOUR FIFTY ON
BIRD TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE WITH
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ONE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
TRIAL.
TRIAL AYE FONG.
FONG I EIGHT ONE IT'S ONE THE
BILLS OUT LIBERAL OPEN.
ITEM EIGHTEEN SB FIVE FIFTY ONE
JACKSON TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE -- VOTE SIX TO ONE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS FONG.
FONG NO GARCIA.
MATHIS MATHIS NO MCCARTY
[inaudible]
MCCARTY I SEVEN THREE SEVEN
THREE THE BILL'S NOT LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN.
ITEM NINETEEN SB. FIVE SEVEN SIX
BY AMBER TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
TROUT I FONG [inaudible]
FONG NO. SEVENTY NINE NINE ONE
YEAH.
ONE UPLOADING SO THAT WENT OUT.
THAT ONE GETS OUT.
AND ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR --
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU.
CHOW IPHONE.
FONG AYE.
GARCIA.
MATHIS.
YEAH.
MATHIS FIVE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY I GEN [inaudible]
ZERO THAT [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
ALSO [inaudible]
OKAY.
MISTER FLORES GOING TO PRESENT.
FOR SENATOR GALGIANI SB.
SIX THIRTY TWO WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
AND THERE ARE MOMENTS.
I THINK THE SENATOR IS GONNA
TAKE YOU MEMBERS FIRST SB.
SIX THIRTY TWO THAT'S CORRECT.
PERFECT WE'RE HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE AMENDMENTS AND WE'VE GOT.
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YOUR SINGLE PARTY WITH A
CALIFORNIA FORESTRY ASSOCIATION
WITH THE SPONSORS THE BILL WERE
ASKING FOR SUPPORT WE'RE HAPPY
TO TAKE THE AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR CHRISTMAS
KAYLEE ON BEHALF OF HUMBLE
MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES ALSO
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
I'M SORRY WHICH BILL IS THIS SB
SIX THIRTY TWO JUST WANT TO
CLARIFY ALL OF YOUR TESTIFYING
ON SIX THIRTY TWO YES OKAY.
TERRIFIC THANK YOU I'M SORRY
JOHN KENNEDY WITH RC RC ON
BEHALF OF THE RURAL COUNTIES IN
SUPPORT.
ROD BREWER FOR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON HERE IN
SUPPORT.
AT A REGULAR BE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANKS.
RIGHT ANYONE WISHING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NUMBER BRING IT BACK
THERE ANY COMMENTS.
OKAY WE ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM TWENTY ONE SB SIX THIRTY
TWO BY SENATOR GALGIANI DO
PASSES AMENDED AND REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
LARA AYE CHAU CHOW I EGGMAN.
FONG FONG AYE GARCIA.
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
THE AYE MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO GI
STONE.
STONE AYE. NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
WILL THE BILL IS NOT LEAVE THE
ROLE OPENS CRAFT MEMBERS ARE YOU
GOING TO BE ALSO PRESENTING SB
TWO SIXTEEN YES IT'S A PRIVILEGE
RISEN SB 216% OR GALGIANI AND
SHE IS GOING TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS.
THANK YOU I'M WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
YES I'M JUST OUR YOUNG ABOUT FOR
THE CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS
VEHICLES COALITION WITH THE
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL WE JUST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING THESE AMENDMENTS OUT.
WE ALSO WANT TO JUST INDICATE
OUR WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT --
IN THE DRESSING YOU KNOW ANY
FURTHER CONCERNS THAT REMAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT JOHN
KENNEDY WITH RC RC IN SUPPORT.
PROSECUTORS HERE ON BEHALF
ADVANCE ENERGY ECONOMY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OKAY
ANOTHER SUPPORT EVEN HEARD WAS
SOUTH CLOSER QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT AS WELL --
WE'RE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
FOR AMENDMENTS AND WE'RE HOPEFUL
TO OTHERS AMENDMENTS -- TO BE
AGREED UPON.
THANK YOU THANK YOU WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEING NONE I BELIEVE WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
NOT YET.
LITTLE.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM TENNIS BE TO SIXTEEN BY
SENATOR GALGIANI THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED OR REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FLORA AYE
FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
PHONE FONG AYE GARCIA.
LIMON.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I'M READ TO CHEAT.
RIGHT TO GI STONE.
STONE AYE NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
THE BILL IS ALL BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN I WANT TO THANK THE VICE
CHAIR. FOR PRESENTING THE BILLS.
WE HAVE [inaudible] ONE ONE OR
WELL -- WORK SENATOR STERN STOP
IS HERE DID YOU WANT TO PRESENT
THE BILL OR ALLOW ONE OF THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS 2% WHATEVER.
YEAH GOING UP TO YOU.
YEAH.
OKAY WHY DON'T WE USE SIT TIGHT
FOR A MOMENT WHILE SHE FINDS OUT
WHAT THE SENATOR WOULD LIKE US
TO DO.
THE BILL ALONG WITH WILL
[inaudible]
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
RIGHT.
THE ALARM GOES OFF.
IS THAT.
IN ALL THE TIME.
YEAH YEAH LIVE.
AFTER AFTER YEAH.
YEAH OKAY I CALL THEIR OFFICE.
AND THEY SAID OKAY ON STUFF.
OKAY -- FOR SERVICES
[inaudible]
WE WERE WE WERE JUST TOLD FROM
THE OFFICE FOR THE STAFF I DON'T
KNOW OF OKAY [inaudible]
WELCOME.
THIS IS FOR BOTH THE OKAY.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU READY TO MORE I AM A
CONSULTANT FOR THE SENATE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE I'M HAPPY TO PRESENT
THIS BILL.
FOR SENATOR STERN HE THANK YOU
HAVE PHASES BACK [inaudible]
WORK ON THIS BILL WAS A RESPONSE
TO THE YEAH.
SO CANYON NATURAL GAS STORAGE
FACILITY -- DID YOU KNOW THAT.
GAS STORAGE FACILITY IS LOCATED
IN SENATOR STERN'S DISTRICT.
AND SO THE INTENTION WITH THIS
BILL IS TO REQUIRE IN THE
INTERESTS OF DOING A BETTER JOB
OF UNDERSTANDING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACTS OF A BIG NATURAL
GAS STORAGE WELL LEAKS.
LEAKS ON PAR WITH A LISA CANYON
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THE PUBLIC
HEALTH IMPACTS OF THAT A LITTLE
BETTER BY REQUIRING CHEMICAL
DISCLOSURE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH DID A
GREAT JOB -- OTHERS WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT.
MELISSA WITNESS IN SUPPORT HAD
TO LEAVE UP WAIT YOU HAVE A FEW
BEHIND YOU SO THANK YOU.
ALYSSA ROMERO THE CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
PRINTED ASSOCIATES OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
TWEENER.
WINNERS WHY GOOD EVENING CAM
CARMICHAEL ON BEHALF OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY VERY MUCH
WE'RE IN A DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION THE BILL THE
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
COMMITTEE'S WORK AND THE
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS.
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR -- TAKING
THOSE AMENDMENTS AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH BOTH ON
THE DETAILS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WAS THERE ANYONE
OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
WELCOME TO COME TO THE TABLE OR
SPEAK AT THE MIKE WHATEVER YOU
PREFER.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMMENT ON SENATE BILL.
FOUR SIXTY THREE MY NAME IS
CHARLIE STANCE AND I'M A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL ENGINEER.
REPRESENTING YOUR RANT STORAGE
AND THE INDEPENDENT STORY
PROVIDERS ISP COALITION.
WHICH IS COMPRISED OF YOUR RANT
STORAGE CENTRAL VALLEY WILD
GOOSE AND LOAD I GUESS STORAGE
COMPANIES.
ALL OF FACILITIES LOCATED
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA PRIMARILY IN
RURAL AREAS.
I'M GONNA REPEAT MY COMMENTS
GIVEN THIS LATE HOUR SO -- I'LL
BE IS AS SHORT AS I CAN.
WE ARE WORKING WITH CENTER STERN
STAFF FOR THE PAST FEW MONTHS TO
AMEND THE BILL BUT THE
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED ON JULY THIRD
UNFORTUNATELYDID NOT ADDRESS
ARE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS WE FIND
OURSELVES HAVING TO OPPOSE
SENATE BILL.
FOUR SIXTY THREE AS WRITTEN IT
ADDRESSES PROBLEMS STEMMING FROM
THE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
INCIDENT AT LEAST SO CANYON AS
DETAILED IN THE RECENTLY.
PUBLISHED ROOT CAUSE ANALYSIS.
THE RCA REPORT IS SPECIFIC TO
THE FAIR THE SS TWENTY FIVE WELL
AT LEAST SO.
AND NOT AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STORAGE INDUSTRY.
THE I. S. P.'S FACILITIES ARE
FUNDAMENTALLY UNLIKE A LISA
CANYON.
OUR STORAGE RESERVOIRS ARE DRY
GAS ONLY NO OIL.
THE WELLS WERE NOT REPURPOSE BUT
DESIGNED AND CONSTRUCTED
SPECIFICALLY FOR NATURAL GAS
STORAGE ARE ALL LESSEN TWENTY
YEARS OLD.
AND OUR FACILITIES ARE LARGELY
RURAL NOT COMMON AREAS.
OUR PRIMARY CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL -- OUTLINED IN OUR LETTER
TO THE COMMITTEE AND WE WERE
ABLE TO DISCUSS THESE -- WITH
CENTER STERN NOT JUST PRIOR TO
THIS MEETING ACTUALLY
IN CONCLUSION WE BELIEVE MANY OF
OUR OF THE PROVISIONS IN SB FOUR
SIXTY THREE OR UNNECESSARY FOR
THE ISPS AND IF ADOPTED WOULD
NOT IMPROVE OUR FACILITY SAFETY
PERFORMANCE.
THE I. S. P. STORAGE FACILITIES
ARE FUNDAMENTALLY DIFFERENT FROM
LISA CANYON WE DO NOT AGREE THAT
THE PROVISIONS OF SB.
FOUR SIXTY THREE AFFECTING ALL
UNDERGROUND GAS STORAGE IN
CALIFORNIA IN A ONE SIZE FITS
ALL APPROACH.
ARE APPROPRIATE AS FOR NECESSARY.
WERE ENCOURAGE BIRD MEETINGS
WITH CENTER STERN AND STAFF
APPRECIATE HIS TIME MEETING WITH
US.
AND COMMIT TO WORKING WITH THEM
TO RESOLVE THE ISSUES THAT LEAD
OUR APP OPPOSITION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY WILL BRING IT BACK UP TO
THE DíAS.
I'LL JUST SAY THAT FOR SENATOR
STERN I APPRECIATE HIM TAKING
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND HIS
STUFF FOR AND I HOPE THAT HE
CONTINUES TO WORK WITH THE
INDUSTRY TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS MOVING FORWARD -- I WAS
PERSON THAT HIS MEETING WITH THE
I. S. P.'S EARLIER TODAY AND
THAT'S CERTAINLY HIS INTENTION.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH ALL
EXCEPT THAT IS YOUR CLOTHES WE
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND WAVE
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM FIFTEEN SB FOUR SIXTY THREE
BY SENATOR STERN THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE FONG.
FONG NOT VOTING.
GARCIA.
LIMON.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS NO [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI EYES STONE.
STONE AYE. SEVEN TWO SEVEN TO
THE BILLS OUT WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ANOTHER FIVE OR
SIX MINUTES.
ACTUALLY WE'RE GOING TO LEAVE IT
OPEN THINK YOU'LL.
YEAH OKAY.
OKAY WHY DON'T WE START AT THE
TOP THEM WITH YOU ABOUT SOME
MEMBERS ON OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY YEAH.
ON ITEM FOR SB FORTY FOUR I
SKINNER TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TO TO WHAT THE TRUE
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I NINE TWO NINE TWO THAT
THOSE OUT.
ITEM FIVE SB FIFTY FOUR BY ALLEN
TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE SEVENTY THREE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
EGGMAN.
SB FIFTY FOUR ALLEN.
ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING.
YEAH.
I'M SORRY HAVE YOU YEAH.
SO IT'S SEVEN THREE SEVEN THREE
THE BILL ITSELF.
ITEM SIX SB SIXTY NINE WIENER DO
PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
SIX TO TWO BUT THE CHAIR VOTING
I ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I EIGHT TWO EIGHT TWO
THAT THOSE OUT.
ITEM SEVEN SB ONE FIFTY FIVE BY
BRADFORD TO PASS AS AMENDED.
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE KERR VOTE NINE ZERO
ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
THURSDAY I ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NINE
SB TWO TEN BY LEYVA TO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SEVEN
THREE BUT THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBER GARCIA.
GARCIA HI [inaudible] EIGHT
EIGHT THREE ITEM TEN SB TWO
SIXTEEN MICHAEL JOHNNY TO PASS
AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE.
NINE ZERO WITH THE TRAVELING I
ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE.
GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE ELEVEN
ZERO THAT FILLS OUT.
ITEM TWELVE SB TWO SIXTY TWO BY
MCGUIRE DO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE NINE TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO
THAT PHYLLIS OUT.
ITEM THIRTEEN SB FOUR FIFTY ON
BURKE TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE EIGHT TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING AYE.
ABSENT MEMBER GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING. EIGHT ONE
EIGHT ONE THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM FIFTEEN SB FOUR SIXTY THREE
BY STERN DO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE SEVENTY
TWO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBER GARCIA.
GARCIA I EIGHT TWO EIGHT TWO
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM EIGHTEEN SB FIVE FIFTY ONE
JACKSON TO PASS AS AMENDED REFER
TO APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE.
SEVENTY THREE WITH THE CHAIR
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBER GARCIA.
RCI [inaudible]
EIGHT THREE THOSE UP.
ITEM TWENTY ONE SB SIX THIRTY
TWO GALGIANI TWO PASSES AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE NINE TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I ELEVEN ZERO THOSE UP.
ITEM TWENTY TWO SB SEVEN FORTY
FOUR CABALLERO TO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE.
NINE TO ZERO ABSENT MEMBER
GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING [inaudible]
NINE ZERO THEN ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
ABSENT MEMBER GARCIA.
GARCIA I ELEVEN ZERO SEN
CALENDARS ADOPTED.
THAT CONCLUDES OUR MEETING THE
MEETING IS ADJOURNED